[Music]
hi everyone welcome to this artificial
intelligence 2022 full course video by
simplyloan
artificial intelligence applications are
being widely used in various fields to
solve business problems in this video
you will learn the important skills that
will help you understand ai and its
implementation better
our highly proficient trainers will take
you through this course
so let's look at the agenda for today's
topic
we will start by learning the basics of
ai from a short animated video
then you will learn the top 10 ai
technologies and companies for 2022
next you will understand machine
learning in detail and explore some of
the top machine learning algorithms that
are used to build intelligent machines
so here you will look at linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k-means clustering k nn pca and
other techniques such as regularization
reinforcement learning and q-learning
moving forward you will understand the
working of artificial neural networks
and deep learning algorithms such as
convolutional neural network recurrent
neural network keras image
classification and sequential model so
let's get started
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the house a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but ai may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact a.i is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an ai do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the ai robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot artificially
intelligent in short ai provides
machines with the capability to adapt
reason and provide solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
an ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai
you might say alexa is definitely not a
weak ai since it can perform multiple
tasks well that's not really true when
you ask alexa to play despacito it picks
up the keywords play and despacito
and runs a program it is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question it
isn't trained to answer for instance try
asking alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to and
that brings us to our second category of
ai strong ai
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technique to achieve ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain this
means through deep learning data and
patterns can be better perceived
ray kurzweil a well-known futurist
predicts that by the year 2045 we would
have robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of singularity
well that's not all
in fact elon musk predicts that the
human mind and body will be enhanced by
ai implants which would make us partly
cyborgs
so here's a question for you which of
the below ai projects don't exist yet
a an ai robot with citizenship
b a robot with a muscular skeletal
system
c ai that can read its owner's emotions
d ai that develops emotions over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below since the
human brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains
for now ai is built to work with humans
and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us well
that is artificial intelligence for you
in short do not forget to leave your
answer to the quiz in the comment
section below also like share and
subscribe to our channel if you enjoyed
this video stay tuned and keep learning
now
let's look at the different types of
artificial intelligence
so ai can be classified based on
capabilities and functionalities
under capabilities there are three types
of artificial intelligence
they are narrow ai general ai and super
ai
under functionalities we have four types
of artificial intelligence reactive
machine limited memory theory of mind
and self-awareness
let's look at them one by one
first we will look at the different
types of artificial intelligence based
on capabilities
so what is narrow ai
narrow ai also known as vki focuses on
one narrow task and cannot perform
beyond its limitations
it aims at a single subset of cognitive
abilities and advances in that spectrum
applications of narrow ai are becoming
increasingly common in our day-to-day
lives as machine learning and deep
learning methods continue to evolve
apple siri is a simple example of an
arrow ai that operates with a limited
predefined range of functions
siri often has challenges with tasks
outside its range of abilities ibm
watson supercomputer is another example
of narrow ai which applies cognitive
computing machine learning and natural
language processing to process
information and answer your questions
ibm watson once outperformed human
contestant ken jenkins to become the
champion on the popular game show
jeopardy
other examples of narrow ai include
google translate image recognition
software recommendation systems spam
filtering and google's page ranking
algorithm
next we have general artificial
intelligence or general ai
general ai also known as strong ai has
the ability to understand and learn any
intellectual task that a human can
general artificial intelligence has
received a one billion dollar investment
from microsoft through openai
it allows the machine to apply knowledge
and skills in different contexts
ai researchers and scientists have not
achieved strong ai so far to succeed
they would need to find a way to make
machines conscious programming a full
set of cognitive abilities
fujitsu built the k computer which is
one of the fastest computers in the
world
it is one of the most notable attempts
at achieving strong ai
it took 40 minutes to simulate a single
second of neural activity so it is
difficult to determine whether or not
strong ai will be achieved in the near
future
tianhe 2
is a supercomputer created by china's
national university of defense
technology
it currently holds the record for cps at
33.86 petaflops
although it sounds exciting the human
brain is estimated to be capable of one
example
now cps means characters per second that
a system can process
third in the list of ai that is based on
capabilities we have super ai
super ai exceeds human intelligence and
can't perform any task better than a
human
the concept of artificial super
intelligence sees ai evolve to be so
akin to human emotions and experiences
that it doesn't just understand them it
evokes emotions needs beliefs and
desires of its own its existence is
still hypothetical some of the key
characteristics of super ai include the
ability to think solve puzzles make
judgments and decisions on its own
now if you have enjoyed watching this
video so far please make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to stay updated with all
the latest technologies
also if you have any questions related
to this video please put it in the chat
section our team of experts will help
you address your questions
moving ahead now we will see the
different types of artificial
intelligence based on functionalities
in this category first we have reactive
machine
a reactive machine is the basic form of
ai that does not store memories or use
past experiences to determine future
actions
it works only with present data they
simply perceive the world and react to
it
reactive machines are given certain
tasks and don't have capabilities beyond
those duties
ibm's deep blue which defeated chess
grandmaster gary kasparov is a reactive
machine that sees the pieces on a chess
board and reacts to them
it cannot refer to any of its prior
experiences and cannot improve with
practice
deep blue can identify the pieces on a
chessboard and know how each moves
it can make predictions about what moves
might be next for it and its opponent
it can choose the most optimal moves
from among the possibilities
deep blue ignores everything before the
present moment
all it does is look at the pieces on the
chessboard as it stands right now and
choose from possible next moves
up next we have limited memory limited
memory ai learns from past data to make
decisions
the memory of such systems is
short-lived
while they can use this data for a
specific period of time they cannot add
it to a library of their experiences
this kind of technology is used for
self-driving vehicles
they observe how other vehicles are
moving around them in the present and as
time passes
that ongoing collected data gets added
to the static data within the ai machine
such as lean markers and traffic lights
they are included when the vehicle
decides to change lanes to avoid cutting
of another driver or being hit by a
nearby vehicle
mitsubishi electric
is a company that has been figuring out
how to improve such technology for
applications like self-driving cars
then we have theory of mind
theory of mind represents a very
advanced class of technology and exists
as a concept
this kind of ai requires a thorough
understanding that the people and the
things within an environment can alter
feelings and behaviors
it should be able to understand people's
emotions sentiment and thoughts
even though a lot of improvements are
there in this field this kind of ai is
not complete yet
one real world example of theory of mind
ai is kismet a robot head made in the
late 90s by a massachusetts institute of
technology researcher
kismet can mimic human emotions and
recognize them
both abilities are key advancements in
theory of mind ai
but kismet can't follow gazes or convey
attention to humans
sophia
from hanson robotics is another example
where the theory of mind ai was
implemented
cameras within sophia's eyes combined
with computer algorithms allow her to
see
she can follow faces sustain eye contact
and recognize individuals
she is able to process speech and have
conversations using natural language
subsystem
finally we have self-awareness
self-awareness ai only exists
hypothetically
such systems understand that internal
traits states and conditions and
perceive human emotions
these machines will be smarter than the
human mind
this type of ai will not only be able to
understand and evoke emotions in those
it interacts with but also have emotions
needs and beliefs of its own
while we are probably far away from
creating machines that are self-aware we
should focus our efforts towards
understanding memory learning and the
ability to base decisions on past
experiences i am keef tana and today we
shall be talking about the top 10
artificial intelligence technologies
before getting into the video here's a
gentle reminder to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon so that
you wouldn't miss any update from us
so
without further ado let's quickly jump
into the topic
in the list we have
natural language generation smart
devices virtual agents
speech recognition
augmented reality
machine learning
robotic process automation
decision management
deep learning and
finally image recognition
please note that the list is in no
particular order
natural language generation
communicating or conveying the
information efficiently and
transparently is very much crucial in
communication
to say the right words in the right
sequence to convey the message clearly
humans often find it tricky and when it
comes to machines it's trickier
natural language generation is a
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence and is a trendy technology
that converts the structured data into a
native language
the machines are programmed in such a
way that the algorithms convert the data
into a desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service report generation and
summarizing business intelligence
insights
some of the sample vendors are a tvo
automated insights sas cambridge
semantics digital reasoning narrative
science
etc
on the list next we have smart devices
with every passing day smart devices are
becoming more popular and more trendy
technologies that people were using once
upon a time are now remodeled and
modified as smart devices
they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the operations
smart devices are everyday objects made
intelligent with advanced computations
which include artificial intelligence
and machine learning
they are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect share and interact with
its users and other smart devices
some of the smart devices are
smart watches smart glasses smart phones
smart speakers
etc
virtual agents
they are computer generated intelligence
that provides online customer assistance
they can effectively communicate with
humans
in most of the web and mobile
applications we see chatbots as customer
service agents who interact with us
answering our queries
in simple virtual agents are a
manifestation of a technology which aims
to create an effective
but digital impersonation of humans
virtual agents can make reservations
book an appointment
place an order and can even avail
product information
some of the best examples of virtual
agents are google assistant and amazon
alexa
and the companies that provide virtual
agents are microsoft google amazon and
assist ai
next we have speech recognition
speech recognition is yet another
subdiscipline of artificial intelligence
which is used to convert human speech
into a comprehensive and useful format
for computer applications to process
it can be said as a bridge between
computer interactions and humans
it's presently used on interactive voice
response systems and mobile applications
some of the companies offering speech
recognition services are nuanced
communications open text nice and varied
systems
augmented reality
yet another trendy technology in the
field of artificial intelligence
augmented reality is an enhanced version
of the real physical world that is
achieved using sound digital visual
elements and other sensory stimuli
delivered via technology
augmented reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make a new artificial environment it
alters the perception of the real world
environment
augmented reality is making its way into
several retail stores that make makeup
selection and furnishing much more fun
and interactive
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
machine learning
machine learning is an application and
an important branch of artificial
intelligence which refers to machines
being able to learn by themselves
without being explicitly programmed
it enables systems to learn and improve
from experience automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms
apis
big data and applications and training
tools
enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization
and prediction
some of the sample vendors are amazon
fractal analytics
google
microsoft etc robotic process automation
configuring a robot to interpret
communicate and analyze data is robotic
process automation
it uses scripts and other methods to
automate the human actions which in turn
supports efficient business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas where the physical
presence of a human is dangerous
fields like warfare mining etc is where
it's currently being used
we need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans but instead it is to complement
their abilities and reinforce human
talent
companies that are focusing on robotic
process automation are pika systems
automation anywhere blue prism
etc next on the list we have decision
management
decision management is yet another
technology in artificial intelligence
that helps companies make valid
decisions by providing up-to-date and
relevant information and performing
analytic
functions artificial intelligence when
combined with decision management helps
translate customer data into predictive
models of key trends
it also helps in making quick decisions
avoidance of risks and in the automation
of the process
decision management is widely used in
the health care sector financial sector
insurance sector
e-commerce and many more
some of the companies that provide this
service are informatica advanced systems
concepts pika systems
mana
etc
deep learning
deep learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence that mimics the workings of
the human brain in processing data
this data is used for a variety of
purposes like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making decisions
deep learning uses hierarchical level of
artificial neural networks for carrying
out the process of machine learning
which is used across several industries
for various applications
some of the sample vendors are deep
instinct fluid ai
math works
saffron technology
etc
at last we have image recognition
image recognition is the process of
detecting an object or feature in a
digital image or video
it can be used to analyze clients and
their opinions verify users based on
their faces detect license plates and
diagnose diseases the present-day image
recognition is comparable to human
visual perception
many social media platforms like
facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and aid visually impaired
users
clarify gums and sense time provide this
technology
decades ago the term artificial
intelligence was just another
frankenstein story but today it could be
a citizen in your next door
right from his genesis artificial
intelligence was programmed to probe
into human life and eliminate the
fortifications of the impossibilities in
many areas like healthcare
transportation communication and much
more
there are hundreds and thousands of
organizations tech communities and
engineers worldwide working round the
clock to make miracles a reality and
today we are going to discuss the top 10
amongst those who are contributing a
significant part
so here we are the top 10 artificial
intelligence companies to watch in 2022.
at number 10 we have this ai
this ai is a revolutionary approach to
dramatically improvise the way
healthcare is delivered
with ai focuses on implementing
artificial intelligence to diagnose and
detect
abnormalities in the human body via ct
cta mri x-ray ekg ultrasound etc
this ai coordinates both the patient and
healthcare professionals at the same
time
the patient reports are shared via
mobile to all the concerned medical
teams
results are astonishing with vis-a-i
there is a significant improvement in
productivity and reduction of time
required for patient treatment and
discharge
this ai was founded in 2016 and
established in november 2021.
the company runs with 223 employees and
the headquarters is in san francisco
this ai mainly focuses on improving and
filling all the gaps between patients
and healthcare professionals
this ai offers hands and salaries to its
employees
in india the salaries range from 4 lakhs
to 18 lakhs per annum and in america the
wages range from 110 000
to 210 000 dollars per annum
so at number nine we have farmwise
ten years ago an automated wheat killing
robo was science fiction
now its rise of practical weed killing
robos with millimeter precision thanks
to farmwise the first product of the
californian-based company was an
automated robo-weeder based on ai
computer vision and also robotics
the robot would eliminate weeds from the
vegetable fields
farmvise intends to build innovative
systems and efficient procedures that
help farmers streamline farming with
efficiency
farmwise was established in the year
2020 the company functions with 50
employees on board and actively looking
for expansion
the company follows the procedure of
paying farming equipment employees and
contract personnel hourly
farm buys makes an annual turnover of
8.5 million us dollars on average an
aiml engineer at farm wise earns
anywhere around
113 000 per annum
up next we have amp robotics at number
eight we have amp robotics
while others are busy trying to
revolutionize mankind with ai amp
robotics came up with an innovative idea
that happens to be a kind gesture of
gratitude towards nature
amp ai designed an artificial
intelligence robo that recycles e-waste
plastic waste and waste from
construction sites and much more
the robo precisely identifies paper
plastics and metals by learning and
recognizing them via color size shape
and a few more factors
the colorado based company is currently
operational with 137 employees in total
and looking forward to expand the idea
globally ap robotics aims to reimagining
recycling and to create a world without
waste through artificial intelligence
amp robotics pays handsome salaries to
their employees with an average salary
of an employee amp
robotics varies between ninety six
thousand dollars to one thirty one
thousand dollars per annum
coming up next is a giant at number
seven we have automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a global robotics
automation and software company founded
in the year 2003 the company's
headquarters is located in san jose
california
the global rpa leader offers cloud
native web-based intelligent automation
solutions to the world's leading cloud
companies
automation anyways automation 360 offers
a variety of intelligent tools and
self-learning systems to automate every
redundant task
automation anywhere is focusing on
transforming the companies to be rpa
oriented and the current kovit
situations have triggered the need for
automation even more
a recent survey states the rpa adoption
rates will increase by 57
in just one more year
the globally recognized multinational
company works with more than 2
200 plus employees on board
the company pays decent salaries as well
at number six we have microsoft ai
microsoft integrated ai into cloud
computing microsoft's ai platform
provides robust solutions to cloud
related problems microsoft's ai division
is headquartered in redmond washington
with around 5000 employees specifically
in the ai division and aims to train and
certify 15 000 employees by 2022.
microsoft ai is a robust framework
designed for developing ai solutions
using machine learning data science
robotics iot and more
ai enable services accelerate
productivity to a greater level
microsoft azure uses ai to get best of
breed infrastructure with enterprise
great security availability compliance
and manageability microsoft also pays
handsome salaries to their employees
the average salary of an employee at the
microsoft ai division earns up to 160
000 dollars per annum
at number five we have data robo
data robo has its headquarters in boston
it is one of the ai cloud leaders
providing a unified platform to its
cloud users to accelerate the delivery
of ai to the cloud
data robo aims to understand and
leverage the inherent capabilities of
the platform
data robo has the caliper to help
business analysts in building predictive
analytics with no knowledge of machine
learning
it uses automated ml to build and deploy
accurate predictive models in a short
span of time
the global cloud leader currently
operates with more than a thousand
employees worldwide
data robo compensates its employees with
handsome salaries an average employee at
data robo earns up to 160 000 per year
and up to three lakh four hundred
thousand rupees in india
at number four we have amazon the alexa
maker amazon is one of the tech giants
interested in adopting ai into its
various divisions amazon calls its ai
services amazon lex amazon poly amazon
recognition and amazon machine learning
these services are accessible through a
software api call or console the amazon
ai suite of services can have text or
voice conversations with an end user
using a conversational chat ops
interface
the seattle-based tech giant is
currently using ai for its smart home
solutions
ai companies like alexa and its business
intelligence needs amazon is also
conducting trials on drone delivery to
save time and efforts to deliver goods
and services to remote locations with
ease
amazon ai aims to provide biometric
payments to its customers at cash-free
stores
the approach is still in trials
amazon calls it just walk out technology
amazon has enormous teams and pays
decent salaries to its employees for
example an employee at amazon can earn
up to 20 lakh rupees per annum in india
and about a hundred thousand dollars per
annum in united states of america
at number three we have data bricks
databricks is one of the best data
driven companies
data bricks lake houses combine data
warehouses reliability performance and
governance with the openness and
flexibility of data lakes
data brick is headquartered in san
francisco california and has 15 office
locations across 11 countries
the company announces plans on
delivering keynote on data and machine
learning product innovations and the
rise of the lake house architecture
advancements
databricks currently operates with 2000
plus employees globally
the organization compensates its
employees with handsome salaries an
average employee at databricks makes
about 154 000 us dollars and around 2.1
lakh rupees per annum in india
next we have meta at number two we have
meta
meta formerly known as facebook is
innovating an advanced way of social
interaction
meta has integrated artificial
intelligence
and it's being called the meta ai
meta ai has its headquarters in toronto
canada
meta ai has redesigned a new material
and touch sensor with potential to boost
the development of metawars
a team of researchers at the metawars
have worked jointly with scientists at
carnegie mellon university to build
reskin a plastic three millimeter thick
membrane with magnetic particles capable
of measuring touch and sensation
a thrilling experiment meta has under
its sleeve i would say meta currently
operates remotely with about 350
employees on board
critiques also state that meta pays a
vast salary to its ai experts with an
average salary of 1 lakh 750 000
paid to the employees at meta ai
at number one we have google ai
google ai is the division of google
dedicated to artificial intelligence
ceo sundar pichai announced it at google
i o 2017 google ai has its headquarters
in california
google ai is demonstrating its quantum
computing supremacy with its new and
powerful cinema processor google's ai is
one of the most widespread technologies
it's almost everywhere
from your language translations to
helping people with speech impairments
to have a successful conversation
social media interactions shopping lists
and assisting users with gps sending
alerts to its users about natural
calamities and saving them
google ai has announced that its
research team is designing next
generation ai chips for a smart future
in addition a new ai model allows
artificial intelligence to perform chip
design that more efficiently solves
unique aspects of any problem with an
artificial neural network
google ai currently works with our four
divisions with massive teams we have
come to an end of this session on the
top 10 ai companies to watch out for in
2022. hello and welcome to machine
learning tutorial part one this is part
one of a machine learning series put on
by simply learn my name is richard
kirschner i'm with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead what's in it for
you today well we'll start off with a
brief explanation of why machine
learning and what is machine learning
and then we'll get into a few of the
types of machine learning machine
learning algorithms linear regression
decision trees support vector machine
and finally we'll do a use case where
we're going to classify whether recipe
is of a cupcake or a muffin using the
svm or the support vector machine sounds
like a delicious way to explore machine
learning so why machine learning why do
we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us well because
machines can now drive your car for you
still very in the infant stage but it's
just exploding as we see with google's
waymo and then uber had their program
which unfortunately crashed they know
that this is huge this is going to be
the huge industry to change our whole
transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now used to detect over 50
eye diseases do you know how amazing
that is to have a computer that double
checks for the doctor for things they
might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that in some
areas where maybe not for eyes but for
other diseases where they're using the
camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnose before you go and see the
doctor and because the machine can now
unlock your phone with your face i mean
that's just cool having it being able to
identify your face or your voice and be
able to turn stuff on and off for you
depending on where you're at and what
you need talking about an ultimate
automation or world we live in and as we
dig in deeper we have a nice example of
facebook as you can see here they have
the facebook post with halloween comment
yes if you want it order here nobody
likes spam post on facebook that annoy
them into interacting with likes shares
comments and other actions i remember
the original ones were all if you don't
click on here you will have bad luck or
some kind of fear factor well this is a
huge thing in a social media when people
are getting spammed and so this tactic
known as engagement bait takes advantage
of facebook's news feed algorithm by
choosing engagement in order to get the
greater reach
to eliminate engagement bait the company
reviewed and categorized hundreds of
thousands of posts to train a machine
learning model that detects different
types of engagement bait so in this case
we have we're using facebook but this is
of course across all the different
social media they have different tools
for building and the facebook scroll
jiff will be replaced kind of like a
virus coming in there and notices that
there's a certain setup with facebook
and it's able to replace it and they
have like vote baiting react baiting
share baiting they have all these
different these are kind of general
titles but there certainly are a lot of
way of baiting you to go in there and
click on something so they fed all this
this data was fed into the machine and
then they have the new post the new post
comes up that takes over part of the
facebook setup and that's what you're
looking at you're looking at this new
post that's replaced like a virus has
replaced that so what facebook do to
eliminate this is they start scanning
for keywords and phrases like this and
checks the click-through rate so starts
looking for people who are clicking
through it without even looking at it or
clicking through it it's not something
that normally would be clicked through
once facebook has scanned for these
keywords and phrases it is now able to
identify the spam coming in and this
makes your life easier so you're not
getting spammed it's not like walking
through an airport and a lot of
countries you have like hundreds of
people trying to sell you timeshare come
join us sign up for this eliminates that
annoyingness so now you can just enjoy
your facebook and your cat pictures or
maybe it's your family pictures mine is
family certainly people like their cat
pictures too another good example is
google's deepmind project alphago a
computer program that plays a board game
go has defeated the world's number one
go player and i hope i say his name
right kiji the ultimate go challenge
game of three of three was on may 27
2017 so it's just last year that this
happened and what makes this so
important is that
you know go is just is a game so it's
not like you're driving a car or
something in our real world but they are
using games to learn how to get the
machine learning program to learn they
want it to learn how to learn and that
is a huge step a lot of this is still in
its infant stage as far as development
as we saw what happened with the as i
referred to earlier the uber cars they
lost their whole division because they
jumped ahead too fast so it's still an
infant stage but boy is this like the
beginning of just an amazing world that
is automated in ways we can't even
imagine what tomorrow's going to look
like we've looked at a lot of examples
of machine learning so let's see if we
can give a little bit more of a concrete
definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is the science of making
computers learn and act like humans by
feeding data and information without
being explicitly programmed
we see here we have a nice little
diagram where we have our ordinary
system and your computer nowadays you
can even run a lot of the stuff on a
cell phone because cell phones advance
so much and then with artificial
intelligence and machine learning it now
takes the data and it learns from what
happened before and then it predicts
what's going to come next and then
really the biggest part right now in
machine learning that's going on is it
improves on that how do we find a new
solution so we go from descriptive words
learning about stuff and understanding
how it fits together to predicting what
it's going to do to post scripting
coming up with a new solution and when
we're working on machine learning
there's a number of different diagrams
that people have posted for what steps
to go through a lot of it might be very
domain specific so if you're working on
photo identification versus language
versus medical or physics some of these
are switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they're very specific
to the domain this is kind of a very
general diagram first you want to define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to collect the data that
matches
you spend a lot of time in data science
collecting data in the next step
preparing the data you've got to make
sure that your data is clean going in
there's the old saying bad data in bad
answer out or bad data out and then once
you've gone through and we've cleaned
all this stuff coming in then you're
going to select the algorithm which
algorithm are you going to use you're
going to train that algorithm in this
case i think we're going to be working
with svm the support vector machine then
you have to test the model does this
model work is this a valid model for
what we're doing and then once you've
tested it you want to run your
prediction you want to run your
prediction or your choice or whatever
output it's going to come up with and
then once everything is set and you've
done lots of testing then you want to go
ahead and deploy the model remember i
said domain specific this is very
general as far as the scope of doing
something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey i'm not
really getting the answers i need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model but it's a
very good model to start with and we do
have some basic divisions of what
machine learning does that's important
to know for instance do you want to
predict a category well if you're
categorizing thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease so in other
words i'm looking for a yes no answer is
it going up or is it going down and in
that case we'd actually say is it going
up true if it's not going up it's false
meaning it's going down this way it's a
yes no zero one do you want to predict a
quantity that's regression so remember
we just did classification now we're
looking at regression these are the two
major divisions in what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height weight health
and other factors so based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is
and then there are a lot of domain
specific things like do you want to
detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm i'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being able to
detect anomalies is very big in data
science these days
another question that comes up which is
on what we call untrained data is do you
want to discover structure in unexplored
data and that's called clustering for
instance finding groups of customers
with similar behavior given a large
database of customer data containing
their demographics and past buying
records and in this case we might notice
that anybody who's wearing certain set
of shoes go shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any arena you
might want to group people together
whether they're based on their different
areas and investments and financial
background whether you're going to give
them a loan or not before we even start
looking at whether they're a valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on unknown
data so you're not you don't know what
the data is going to tell you but you
want to cluster people together that
come together
let's take a quick detour for
quiz time oh my favorite so we're going
to have a couple questions here under
quiz time and we'll be posting the
answers in this part two of this
tutorial so let's go ahead and take a
look at these quiz times questions and
hopefully you'll get them all right
it'll get you thinking about how to
process data and what's going on can you
tell what's happening in the following
cases of course you're sitting there
with your cup of coffee and you have
your checkbox and your pen trying to
figure out what's your next step in your
data science analysis
so the first one is grouping documents
into different categories based on the
topic and content of each document very
big these days you know you have legal
documents you have maybe it's the sports
group documents maybe you're analyzing
newspaper postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world
b identifying handwritten digits in
images correctly
so we want to know whether they're
writing an a or capital a c
what are they writing out in their hand
digit their handwriting
c behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed
d predicting salary of an individual
based on his or her years of experience
with hr hiring uh set up there so stay
tuned for part two we'll go ahead and
answer these questions when we get to
the part two of this tutorial or you can
just simply write at the bottom and send
a note to simply learn and they'll
follow up with you on it
back to our regular content
now these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another way of
dividing our types of machine learning
and that is with supervised
unsupervised
and reinforcement learning supervised
learning is a method used to enable
machines to classify predict objects
problems or situations based on labeled
data fed to the machine and in here you
see we have a jungle of data with
circles triangles and squares then we
label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square and we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have a new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is uh being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on a loan
because i was talking about banks
earlier supervised learning on stock
market whether you're going to make
money or not that's always important and
if you are looking to make a fortune in
the stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very it
fluctuates and weighs you really hard to
predict so it's quite a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is what a triangle is
and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
they'll group it by the number of
corners and it notices that a number of
them all have three corners a number of
them all have four corners and a number
of them all have no corners and it's
able to filter those through and group
them together we talked about that
earlier with looking at a group of
people who are out shopping we want to
group them together to find out what
they have in common and of course once
you understand what people have in
common maybe you have one of them is a
customer at your store or you have five
of them our customer your store and they
have a lot in common with five others
who are not customers at your store how
do you market to those five who aren't
customers at your store yet they fit the
demographics of who's gonna shop there
and you'd like them to shop at your
store not the one next door of course
this is a simplified version you can see
very easily the difference between a
triangle and a circle which might not be
so easy in marketing reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is an
important type of machine learning where
an agent learns how to behave in an
environment by performing actions and
seeing the result we have here where the
in this case a baby it's actually great
that they used an infant for this slide
because the reinforcement learning is
very much in its infant stages but it's
also probably the biggest machine
learning demand out there right now or
in the future it's going to be coming up
over the next few years is reinforcement
learning and how to make that work for
us
and you can see here where we have our
action in the action on this one it goes
into the fire hopefully the baby didn't
it's just a little candle not a giant
fire pit like it looks like here when
the baby comes out and the new state is
the baby is sad and crying because they
got burned on the fire and then maybe
they take another action the baby's
called the agent because it's the one
taking the actions and in this case they
didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand because that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you burn yourself on the
stove don't do that anymore don't touch
the stove in the big picture being able
to have a machine learning program or an
ai be able to do this is huge because
now we're starting to learn how to learn
that's a big jump in the world of
computer and machine learning and we're
going to go back and just kind of go
back over supervised versus unsupervised
learning understanding this is huge
because this is going to come up in any
project you're working on
we have in supervised learning we have
labeled data we have direct feedback so
someone's already gone in there and said
yes that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised training it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data
find all these things that are connected
together and then somebody looks at
those and labels them now you can take
that label data and program something to
predict what's in the picture so you can
see how they go back and forth and you
can start connecting all these different
tools together to make a bigger picture
there are many interesting machine
learning algorithms let's have a look at
a few of them hopefully this gives you a
little flavor what's out there and these
are some of the most important ones that
are currently being used we'll take a
look at linear regression decision tree
and the support vector machine
let's start with a closer look at linear
regression linear regression is perhaps
one of the most well-known and
well-understood algorithms in statistics
and machine learning linear regression
is a linear model for example a model
that assumes a linear relationship
between the input variables x and the
single output variable y
and you'll see this if you remember from
your algebra classes y equals mx plus c
imagine we are predicting distance
traveled y from speed x our linear
regression model representation for this
problem would be y equals m times x plus
c or
distance equals m times speed plus c
where m is the coefficient and c is the
y-intercept and we're going to look at
two different variations of this first
we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness speed equals 10 meters
per second and so over a certain amount
of time his distance equals 36
kilometers we have a second bicyclist
who's going twice the speed or 20 meters
per second and you can guess if he's
going twice the speed and time is a
constant then he's going to go twice the
distance and that's easy to compute 36
times 2 you get 72 kilometers and so if
you had the question of
how fast would somebody is going three
times that speed or 30 meters per second
is you can easily compute the distance
in our head we can do that without
needing a computer but we want to do
this for more complicated data so it's
kind of nice to compare the two but
let's just take a look at that and what
that looks like in a graph
so in a linear regression model we have
our distance to the speed and we have
our m equals the ve slope of the line
and we'll notice that the line has a
plus slope and as the speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals mx plus c distance
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing it's
3 times 10 meters per second that this
is roughly 102 kilometers distance that
this third bicyclist has traveled one of
the key
definitions on here is positive
relationship so the slope of the line is
positive as distance increase so does
speed increase let's take a look at our
second example where we put distance is
a constant so we have speed equals 10
meters per second they have a certain
distance to go and it takes them 100
seconds to travel that distance and we
have our second bicyclist who's still
doing 20 meters per second since he's
going twice the speed we can guess that
he'll cover the distance in about half
the time 50 seconds and of course you
could probably guess on the third one
100 divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed you can easily guess
that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or graph if the
distance is assumed to be constant let's
see the relationship between speed and
time and as time goes up the amount of
speed to go that same distance goes down
so now your m equals a minus ve slope of
the line as the speed increases time
decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship depended on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's see with the mathematical
implementation of linear regression and
we'll take this data so suppose we have
this data set where we have x y x equals
1 2 3 4 5 standard series and the y
value is 3 2 2 4 3. when we take that
and we go ahead and plot these points on
a graph you can see there's kind of a
nice scattering and you could probably
eyeball a line through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression and the first
thing we do is we come up here we have
the mean of x i and remember mean is
basically the average so we added five
plus four plus three plus two plus one
and divide by five and that simply comes
out as three and then we'll do the same
for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by five and we
end up with the mean value of y of i
equals 2.8 where the x i reference is
it's an average or means value and the y
i also equals a means value of y and
when we plot that you'll see that we can
put in the y equals 2.8 and the x equals
3 in there on our graph we kind of give
it a little different color so you can
sort it out with the dashed lines on it
and it's important to note that when we
do the linear regression the linear
regression model should go through that
dot
now let's find our regression equation
to find the best fit line remember we go
ahead and take our y equals mx plus c so
we're looking for m and c so to find
this equation for our data we need to
find our slope of m and our coefficient
of c
and we have y equals mx plus c
where m equals the sum of x minus x
average times y minus y average or y
means and x means over the sum of x
minus x means squared that's how we get
the slope of the value of the line and
we can easily do that by creating some
columns here we have x y computers are
really good about iterating through data
and so we can easily compute this and
fill in a graph of data and in our graph
you can easily see that if we have our x
value of one and if you remember the x i
or the means value is three one minus
three equals a negative two and two
minus three equals a negative one so on
and so forth and we can easily fill in
the column of x minus x i y minus y i
and then from those we can compute x
minus x i squared and x minus x i times
y minus y i and you can guess it that
the next step is to go ahead and sum the
different columns for the answers we
need so we get a total of ten for our x
minus x i squared and a total of two for
x minus x i times y minus y i
and we plug those in we get two tenths
which equals 0.2 so now we know the
slope of our line equals 0.2 so we can
calculate the value of c that'd be the
next step is we need to know where it
crosses the y-axis and if you remember i
mentioned earlier that the linear
regression line has to pass through
the means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just flip back up there
to that graph and you can see right here
there's our means value which is 3
x equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value we can simply plug that
into our formula y equals 0.2 x plus c
so we plug that in we get 2.8 equals 0.2
times 3 plus c and you can just solve
for c so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line y equals 0.2 times x
plus 2.2 and then from this equation we
can compute new values so let's predict
the values of y using x equals 1 2 3 4 5
and plot the points remember the 1 2 3 4
5 was our original x values so now we're
going to see what y thinks they are not
what they actually are and we plug those
in we get y of designated with y of p
you can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals 2.6 and so on and so on
so we have our y predicted values of
what we think it's going to be when we
plug those numbers in and when we plot
the predicted values along with the
axial values we can see the difference
and this is one of the things that's
very important with linear aggression in
any of these models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted x and y and
y predict and we've drawn a little line
so you can sort of see what the error
looks like there between the different
points so our goal is to reduce this
error we want to minimize that error
value on our linear regression model
minimizing the distance there are lots
of ways to minimize the distance between
the line and the data points like sum of
squared errors sum of absolute errors
root mean square error etc we keep
moving this line through the data points
to make sure the best fit line has the
least square distance between the data
points and the regression line so to
recap with a very simple linear
regression model we first figure out the
formula of our line through the middle
and then we slowly adjust the line to
minimize the error keep in mind this is
a very simple formula the math gets even
though the math is very much the same it
gets much more complex as we add in
different dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals mx plus c but you
can take that out to x
z i j q all the different features in
there and they can plot a linear
regression model on all of those using
the different formulas to minimize the
error let's go ahead and take a look at
decision trees a very different way to
solve problems in the linear regression
model decision tree is a tree-shaped
algorithm used to determine a course of
action each branch of a tree represents
a possible decision occurrence or
reaction we have data which tells us if
it is a good day to play golf and if we
were to open this data up in a general
spreadsheet you can see we have the
outlook whether it's a rainy overcast
sunny temperature
hot mild cool humidity windy and did i
like to play golf that day yes or no so
we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not but you can
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would be fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next uh whatever you
know next mail out in this case is
tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in and so we
come up and let's uh determine if you
should play golf when the day is sunny
and windy so we found out the forecast
tomorrow is going to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity and
then we have our normal which is if it's
if you have a normal humidity you're
going to go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the outlook and if the outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do so if you know
that it's a very high humidity and it's
sunny you're probably not going to play
golf because you're going to be out
there miserable fighting off the
mosquitoes that are out joining you to
play golf with you maybe if it's raining
you probably don't want to play in the
rain but if it's slightly overcast you
get just the right
shadow that's a good day to play golf
and be outside out on the green now in
this example you can probably make your
own tree pretty easily because it's a
very simple set of data going in but the
question is how do you know what to
split where do you split your data what
if this is much more complicated data
where it's not something that you would
particularly understand like studying
cancer they take about 36 measurements
of the cancerous cells and then each one
of those measurements represents how
bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but since the question is going to
come up is this the right decision tree
for that we should calculate entropy and
information gain two important
vocabulary words there are the entropy
and the information gain entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or impurity
in the data set entropy should be low so
we want the chaos to be as low as
possible we don't want to look at it and
be confused by the images or what's
going on there with mixed data and the
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
information gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side in this case we're
going to denote entropy as i of p of and
n where p
is the probability that you're going to
play a game of golf and n is the
probability where you're not going to
play the game of golf now you don't
really have to memorize these formulas
there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log squared of p over p plus n minus n
over p plus n times the log squared of n
of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what actually looks like when
we're computing that from the computer
script side
entropy of a target class of the data
set is the whole entropy so we have
entropy play golf and we look at this if
we go back to the data you can simply
count how many yeses and no in our
complete data set for playing golf days
in our complete set we find we have five
days we did play golf and nine days we
did not play golf and so our i equals if
you had those together nine plus five is
fourteen and so our i equals five over
fourteen and nine over 14 that's our p
and n values that we plug into that
formula and you can go
5 over 14 equals 0.36 9 over 14 equals
0.64 and when you do the whole equation
you get the minus 0.36 log root squared
of 0.36 minus 0.64 log squared root of
0.64 and we get a set value we get
0.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf and the outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have
p of sunny times e of three of two and
that just comes out how many sunny days
yes and how many sunny days no over the
total which is five don't forget to put
the we'll divide that five out later on
uh equals p overcast equals four comma
zero plus rainy equals two comma three
and then when you do the whole set up we
have five over fourteen remember i said
there was a total of five five over
fourteen times the i of three of two
plus 4 over 14 times the 4 comma 0 and
514 over i of 2 3. and so we can now
compute the entropy of just the part
that has to do with the forecast and we
get 0.693 similarly we can calculate the
entropy of other predictors like
temperature humidity and wind and so we
look at the gain outlook how much are we
going to gain from this entropy play
golf minus entropy play golf outlook and
we can take the original 0.94 for the
whole set minus the entropy of just the
rainy day and temperature and we end up
with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy and we define an
information gain the higher the
information gained the lower the entropy
the better the information gain of the
other three attributes can be calculated
in the same way so we have our gain for
temperature equals 0.029
we have our gain for humidity equals
0.152 and our gain for a windy day
equals 0.048 and if you do a quick
comparison you'll see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest information
gain as the root node and then continue
to split each sub node with the largest
information gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see
that's a very easy to view visual model
we have our outlook we split it three
different directions if the outlook is
overcast we're going to play and then we
can split those further down if we want
so if the outlook is sunny but then it's
also windy if it's windy we're not going
to play if it's not windy we'll play so
we can easily build a nice decision tree
to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go outlook sunny outlook windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little smart watch pops up and says i'm
sorry tomorrow's not a good day for golf
it's going to be sunny and windy and if
you're a huge golf fan you might go
uh-oh
it's not a good day to play golf we can
go in and watch a golf game at home so
we'll sit in front of the tv instead of
being out playing golf in the wind
now that we've looked at our decision
tree let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating support
vector machine support vector machine is
a widely used classification algorithm
the idea of support vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner for
example dog or cat disease or no disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height and weight of males
and females
a new data point arrives and we want to
know whether it's going to be a male or
a female so we start by drawing a line
we draw decision lines but if we
consider decision line 1 then we will
classify the individual as a male and if
we consider decision line two then it'll
be a female so you can see this person
kind of lies in the middle of the two
groups so it's a little confusing trying
to figure out which line they should be
under we need to know which line divides
the classes correctly but how the goal
is to choose a hyperplane and that is
one of the key words they use when we
talk about support vector machines
choose a hyperplane with the greatest
possible margin between the decision
line and the nearest point within the
training set
so you can see here we have our support
vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyperplane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value and it should be
equal the distance between the two
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance so we
observe that line one has a maximum
distance margin so we'll classify the
new data point correctly and our result
on this one is going to be that the new
data point is mel one of the reasons we
call it a hyperplane versus a line
is that
a lot of times we're not looking at just
weight and height we might be looking at
36 different features or dimensions and
so when we cut it with a hyperplane it's
more of a three-dimensional cut in the
data multi-dimensional it cuts the data
a certain way and each plane continues
to cut it down until we get the best fit
or match let's understand this with the
help of an example problem statement i
always start with a problem statement
when you're going to put some code
together we're going to do some coding
now classifying muffin and cupcake
recipes using support vector machines so
the cupcake versus the muffin let's have
a look at our data set and we have the
different recipes here we have a muffin
recipe that has so much flour i'm not
sure what measurement 55 is in but it
has 55 maybe it's ounces
but a certain amount of flour certain
amount of milk sugar butter egg baking
powder vanilla and salt and so based on
these measurements we want to guess
whether we're making a muffin or a
cupcake and you can see in this one we
don't have just two features we don't
just have height and weight as we did
before between the male and female in
here we have a number of features
in fact in this we're looking at eight
different features to guess whether it's
a muffin or a cupcake what's the
difference between a muffin and a
cupcake turns out muffins have more
flour while cupcakes have more butter
and sugar so basically the cupcake's a
little bit more of a dessert where the
muffins a little bit more of a fancy
bread but how do we do that in python
how do we code that to go through
recipes and figure out what the recipe
is and i really just want to say
cupcakes versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
start in our cupcakes versus muffins we
are going to be working in python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just has so much stuff attached to it
it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda in jupyter notebook the
anaconda navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the anaconda
navigator you can change environments i
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python36
environment so this is in python version
3.6 although it doesn't matter too much
which version you use i usually try to
stay with the 3x because they're current
unless you have a project that's very
specifically in version 2x 27 i think is
usually what most people use in the
version 2. and then once we're in our
jupiter notebook editor i can go up and
create a new file and we'll just jump in
here
in this case we're doing svm muffin
versus cupcake and then let's start with
our packages
for
data analysis
and we almost always use a couple
there's a few very standard packages we
use
we use
imports import import
numpy
that's for number python they usually
denote it as np that's very comma
that's very common
and then we're going to import pandas as
pd
and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy
setup
as far as multiplying all the values in
an array in a numpy array data array
pandas
i can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set i think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a numpy array is that a data frame
is more like your excel spreadsheet you
have columns you have indexes you have
different ways of referencing it easily
viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so they you
need them both in there
and then finally we're working with the
support vector machine so
from sk learn we're going to use the sk
learn model
import svm support vector machine
and then
as a data scientist you should always
try to visualize your data some data
obviously is too complicated or doesn't
make any sense to the human but if it's
possible it's good to take a second look
at it so you can actually see what
you're doing now for that we're going to
use two packages we're going to import
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt
again very common
and we're going to import seaborn as sns
and we'll go ahead and set the font
scale in the sns right in our import
line that's what this
semicolon followed by a line of data
we're going to set the sns and these are
great because the seaborn sits on top of
matte plot library just like pandas hits
on numpy so it adds a lot more features
and uses and control we're obviously not
going to get into matplot library and
cborn that'd be its own tutorial we're
really just focusing on the svm the
support vector machine from sklearn and
since we're in jupiter notebook
we have to add a special line in here
for our matplot library and that's your
percentage sign or ambersign matplot
library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code project a lot of times i
use like notepad plus plus and i'll run
it from there you don't have to have
that line in there because it'll just
pop up as its own window on your
computer depending on how your
computer's set up because we're running
this in the jupyter notebook as a
browser setup this tells it to display
all of our graphics right below on the
page so that's what that line is for
remember the first time i ran this i
didn't know that i had to go look that
up years ago it's quite a headache so
matplot library inline is just because
we're running this on the web setup and
we can go ahead and run this make sure
all our modules are in they're all
imported which is great
if you don't have an import you'll need
to go ahead and pip use the pip or
however you do it there's a lot of other
install packages out there although pip
is the most common and you have to make
sure these are all installed on your
python setup the next step of course is
we got to look at the data you can't run
a
model for predicting data if you don't
have actual data so to do that let me go
and open this up and take a look and we
have our cupcakes versus muffins
and it's a csv file or dot csv meaning
that it's comma separated variable
and it's going to open it up in a nice
uh spreadsheet for me and you can see up
here we have the type we have muffin
muffin muffin cupcake cupcake cupcake
and then it's broken up into flour milk
sugar butter egg baking powder vanilla
and salt
so we can do is we can go ahead and look
at this data also in our python
let us create a variable recipes equals
we're going to use our pandas module
dot read
csv remember it's a comma separated
variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus muffins oops i got
double brackets there
do it this way
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program i loaded or the the
place i saved this particular python
program is in the same folder we get by
with just the file name but remember if
you're storing it in a different
location you have to also put down the
full path on there
and then because we're in pandas
we're going to go ahead and you can
actually inline you can do this but let
me do the full print you can just type
in
recipes.head
in the jupiter notebook but if you're
running in code in a different script
you need to go ahead and type out the
whole print recipes dot head
and panda's nose is that's going to do
the first five lines of data and if we
flip back on over to the spreadsheet
where we opened up our csv file
you can see where it starts on line two
this one calls it zero and then
two three four five six is going to
match
go and close that out so we don't need
that anymore
and it always starts at zero
and these are it automatically indexes
it since we didn't tell it to use an
index in here so that's the index number
for the left hand side and it
automatically took the top row
as labels so pandas
using it to read a csv is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas
not just because they're cute and cuddly
teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot our data
and i'm not going to plot all of it i'm
just going to plot the
sugar and flour
now obviously
you can see where they get really
complicated if we have tons of different
features
and so you'll break them up and maybe
look at just two of them at a time to
see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use seaborn
so that's our sns
and the command for that is sns.lmplot
and then the two different variables i'm
going to plot is flour and sugar
data equals recipes
the hue equals type
and this is a lot of fun because it
knows that this is pandas coming in
so this is one of the powerful things
about pandas mixed with seabourn and
doing
graphing
and then we're going to use a palette
set one there's a lot of different sets
in there you can go look them up for
seabourn or do a regular fit regular
equals false so we're not really trying
to fit anything
and it's a scatter kws
a lot of these settings you can look up
in seabourn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
doing a seaborn plot
let's go ahead and run that
and because it does it in line it just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on sugar and flour alone there's a
definite split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at and say hey if i drew a
line right between the middle of the
blue dots and the red dots
we'd be able to do an svm and a hyper
plane right there in the middle
then the next step is to
format or pre-process
our data
and we're going to break that up into
two parts
we need a type
label and remember we're going to decide
whether it's a muffin or cupcake well a
computer doesn't know muffin or cupcake
it knows zero and one
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
and p
where
and this is where we can do some logic
we take our recipes from our panda
and wherever type equals muffin it's
going to be zero and then if it doesn't
equal muffin which is cupcakes it's
going to be one so we create our type
label
this is the answer so when we're doing
our training model remember we have to
have a training data this is what we're
going to train it with is that it's 0 or
1. it's a muffin or it's not
and then we're going to create our
recipe
features
and if you remember correctly from right
up here the first column is type
so we really don't need the type columns
that's our muffin or cupcake
and in pandas we can easily sort that
out
we take our value recipes
dot
columns that's a pandas function built
into pandas
we've got values converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top
and we don't want the first one so what
we do is since it always starts at zero
we want one
colon till the end
and then
we want to go ahead and make this a list
and this converts it to a list of
strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features make sure it looks right
let me go ahead and run that
and i forgot the s on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s in there and then
run that and we can see we have flour
milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and that
matches what we have up here right where
we printed out everything but the type
so we have our features and we have our
label
now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns and we actually
need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients
and when you're doing this usually you
do but for our example we want to limit
it so you can easily see what's going on
because if we did all the ingredients
we have you know that's what uh
seven eight different hyper planes that
would be built into it we only want to
look at one so you can see what the svm
is doing
and so we'll take our recipes and we'll
do just flour and sugar
again you can replace that with your
recipe features and do all of them but
we're going to do just flour and sugar
and we're going to convert that to
values
we don't need to make a list out of it
because it's not string values these are
actual
values on there and we can go ahead and
just print
ingredients and you can see what that
looks like
uh and so we have just the amount of
flour and sugar just the two sets of
plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here and
take our recipe features
and so if we decided to use all the
recipe features
you'll see that it makes a nice column
of different data so it just strips out
all the labels and everything we just
have just the values
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a plot later on we'll go
ahead and take that and just do flower
and sugar
and we'll run that you'll see it's just
the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model
we'll go ahead and just call it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called svc
in this case we're going to go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific setup on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the svm
you'll see that there's about there's
eight of them here
three of them are for regression
three are for classification the svc
support vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and there's also one for detecting
outliers
and another one that has to do with
something a little bit more specific on
the model but svc and sbr are the two
most commonly used standing for support
vector classifier and support vector
regression remember regression is an
actual value a float value or
whatever you're trying to work on and
sbc is a classifier so it's a yes no
true false
but for this we want to know zero one
muffin cupcake
if we go ahead and create our model and
once we have our model created we're
going to do model dot fit and this is
very common especially in the sk learn
all their models are followed with the
fit command
and what we put into the fit what we're
training with it is we're putting in the
ingredients which in this case we
limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into uh
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
whether you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that it gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data
and let's go ahead and run this and now
we have our model fit
and i got an error here so let me fix
that real quick
capital sbc it turns out
i did it lowercase
support vector
classifier there we go let's go ahead
and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically
these are the defaults of the model
you notice that we change the kernel to
linear and there's our kernel linear on
the printout and there's other different
settings you can mess with
we're going to just leave that alone for
right now for this we don't really need
to mess with any of those
so next we're going to dig a little bit
into our newly trained model
and we're going to do this so we can
show you on a graph
and let's go ahead and get the
separating
we're going to say we're going to use a
w for our variable on here
we're going to do model
dot coefficient underscore zero
so what the heck is that again we're
digging into the model so we've already
got a prediction and a train
this is a math behind it that we're
looking at right now
and so
the w is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y equals mx plus c
so these coefficients are connected to
that
but in two-dimensional it's a plane
we don't want to spend
too much time on this because you can
get lost in the confusion of the math so
if you're a math whiz this is great you
can go through here and you'll see that
we have a equals minus w0 over w of one
remember there's two different values
there
and that's basically
the slope that we're generating
and then we're going to build an xx what
is xx we're going to set it up to a
numpy array there's our np dot line
space so we're creating a line
of values between 30 and 60. so it just
creates a set of numbers for x
and then if you remember correctly we
have
our formula y equals the slope times x
plus the intercept
well to make this work we can do this as
y y
equals the slope times each value in
that array that's the neat thing about
numpy so when i do a times x x which is
a whole numpy array of values it
multiplies a across all of them
and then it takes those same values and
we subtract the model intercept that's
here uh
where we had mx plus c so that'd be the
c from the formula y equals mx plus c
and that's where all these numbers come
from a little bit confusing because it's
digging out of these different arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it
so plot the parallels to separating
hyperplane that pass through the support
vectors
and so we're going to create b equals a
model
support vectors
pulling our support vectors out there
here's our y y which we now know is a
set of data and we have we're going to
create y y down
equals a times x x plus
b one minus a times b zero
and then model support vector b is going
to be set that to a new value the minus
one set up and y y up equals a times x x
plus b one minus a times b zero
and we go ahead and just run this to
load these variables up if you wanted to
understand a little bit more of what's
going on you can see if we print
y y let me just run that
you can see it's an array this is a line
it's going to have in this case between
30 and 60 so it's going to be 30
variables in here
and the same thing with yy up yy down
and we'll plot those in just a minute on
the graph so you can see what those look
like
i'll just go ahead and delete that out
of here
and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate
i'm just going to copy this from before
remember this our sns
our seabourn plot lm plot flower sugar
and i'll just go ahead and run that real
quick so you can see remember what that
looks like it's just a straight graph on
there
and then one of the new things is
because seaborn sits on top of pie plot
we can do the pi plot for the line going
through and that is simply plt dot plot
and that's our xx
and yy our two corresponding values xy
and then somebody played with this to
figure out that the line width equals
two in the color black would look nice
so let's go ahead and run this whole
thing with the pie plot on there
and you can see when we do this it's
just doing flour and sugar on here
corresponding line between the sugar and
the flour and the muffin versus cupcake
and then we generated the support
vectors the y y down and y y up so let's
take a look and see what that looks like
so we'll do our pl plot
and again this is all against x x
our x value but this time we have y y
down
and let's do something a little fun with
this
we can put in a k
dash dash
that just tells it to make it a dotted
line
and if we're going to do the down one
we also want to do the up one
so here's our yy
up
and when we run that it
both sets a line
and so here's our support and this is
what you expect you expect these two
lines to go through the nearest data
point so the dashed lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cupcake
when it's plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour
which one's a muffin or a cupcake
let's go ahead and create a function
to predict
muffin or cupcake
i've got my
recipes i pulled off the
internet and i want to see the
difference between a
muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through
and uh create a function with def
and let's call it muffin or cupcake and
remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today we're not doing all the
ingredients and that actually is a
pretty good split you really don't need
all the ingredients you know it's flour
and sugar
and let's go ahead and do an if else
statement so if model predict
is of flour and sugar equals zero
so we take our model and we do it run a
predict it's very common in sk learn we
have a dot predict you put the data in
and it's going to return a value in this
case if it equals zero then print you're
looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe
that's pretty straightforward for a
function or def for definition d e f is
how you do that in python
and of course we're going to create a
function you should run something in it
and so let's run a cupcake and we're
going to send it values 50 and 20 a
muffin or cupcake i don't know what it
is
and let's run this and just see what it
gives us
and it says oh it's a muffin you're
looking at a muffin recipe
so it very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake recipe
let's
plot this
there we go plot this on the graph so we
can see what that actually looks like
and i'm just going to copy and paste it
from below where we're plotting all the
points in there so this is nothing
different than we did before if i run it
you'll see it has all the points and the
lines on there and what we want to do is
we want to add another point
and we'll do plt plot
and if you remember correctly we did for
our test we did 50
and 20.
and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do a y-o for yellow or
it's kind of a oranges yellow color is
going to come out marker size nine those
are settings you can play with somebody
else played with them to come up with
the right setup so it looks good and you
can see there it is graphed
clearly a muffin
in this case in cupcakes versus muffins
the muffin has won
and if you'd like to do your own muffin
cupcake
contender series you certainly can send
a note down below and the team at simply
learn will send you over the data they
use for the muffin and cupcake and
that's true of any of the data we didn't
actually run a plot on it earlier we had
men versus women
you can also request that information to
run it on your data setup so you can
test that out
so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support vector machine
code we did a predict 40 parts flower 20
parts sugar i think was different than
the one we did whether it's a muffin or
a cupcake hence we have built a
classifier using svm which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin today in our second
tutorial we're going to cover k-means
and linear regression along with going
over the quiz questions we had during
our first tutorial
what's in it for you we're going to
cover clustering what is clustering k
means clustering which is one of the
most common use clustering tools out
there including a flowchart to
understand k-means clustering and how it
functions and then we'll do an actual
python live demo on clustering of cars
based on brands
then we're going to cover logistic
regression what is logistic regression
logistic regression curve and sigmoid
function and then we'll do another
python code demo to classify a tumor as
malignant or benign based on features
and let's start with clustering suppose
we have a pile of books of different
genres now we divide them into different
groups like fiction horror education and
as we can see from this young lady she
definitely is into heavy horror you can
just tell by those eyes and the maple
canadian leaf on her shirt but we have
fiction horror and education and we want
to go ahead and divide our books up well
organizing objects into groups based on
similarity is clustering and in this
case as we're looking at the books we're
talking about clustering things with
known categories but you can also use it
to explore data so you might not know
the categories you just know that you
need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case we're going to
be looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're going to use k means
clustering k means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library k-means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to cluster to different
groups define clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also introduced feature similarity
features being different features of the
data now with books we can easily see
fiction and
horror and history books but a lot of
times with data some of that information
isn't so easy to see right when we first
look at it and so k-means is one of
those tools where we can start finding
things that connect that match with each
other suppose we have these data points
and want to assign them into a cluster
now when i look at these data points i
would probably group them into two
clusters just by looking at them i'd say
two of these group of data kind of come
together but in k means we pick k
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the k clusters represents
two different clusters we pick k
clusters and cyrano centroids to the
clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroids now we form new
clusters based on minimum distances
and calculate the centroids so we figure
out what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stopped changing their
positions and become static
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stopped
changing and the positions become static
once the clusters become static then
k-means clustering algorithm is said to
be converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever math we're
using to figure out the answer has come
to a solution or it's converged on an
answer should we see the flowchart to
understand make a little bit more sense
by putting it into a nice easy
step-by-step so we start we choose k
we'll look at the elbow method in just a
moment we assign random centroids to
clusters and sometimes you pick the
centroids because you might look at the
data in a graph and say oh these are
probably the central points then we
compute the distance from the objects to
the centroids
we take that and we form new clusters
based on minimum distance and calculate
their centroids then we compute the
distance from objects to the new
centroids and then we go back and repeat
those last two steps we calculate the
distances so as we're doing it brings
into the new centroid and then we move
the centroid around and we figure out
what the best which objects are closest
to each centroid so the objects can
switch from one centroid to the other
the centroids are moved around and we
continue that until it is converged
let's see an example of this
suppose we have this data set of seven
individuals and their score on two
topics a and b so here's our subject
in this case referring to the person
taking the test
and then we have subject a where we see
what they've scored on their first
subject and we have subject b and we can
see what they score on the second
subject now let's take two farthest
apart points as initials cluster
centroids remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it
so we took the two furthest points one
and one and five and seven and now let's
take the two farthest apart points as
initial cluster centroids each point is
then assigned to the closest cluster
with respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
and you can see that if we measured each
of those distances and you use it the
pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the x and the
y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster uh the centroid
then moves over it becomes 1.8 comma 2.3
so remember was that one and one well
the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly 2 2 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the
second one if we wanted to make the
overall mean vector the average vector
of all the different distances to that
centroid we come up with 4 comma 1 and 5
4. so we've now moved the centroids we
compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean and to that of the
opposite cluster and we find
build a nice chart on here that the as
we move the centroid around we now have
a new different kind of clustering of
groups and using euclidean distance
between the points and the mean we get
the same formula you see new formulas
coming up so we have our individual dots
distance to the mean centroid of the
cluster and distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster
only individual 3 is nearer to the mean
of the opposite cluster cluster two then
its own cluster one and you can see here
in the diagram where we've kind of
circled that one in the middle so when
we've moved the cluster the centroids of
the clusters over one of the points
shifted to the other cluster because
it's closer to that group of individuals
thus individual 3 is relocated to
cluster 2 resulting in a new partition
and we regenerate all those numbers of
how close they are to the different
clusters
for the new clusters we will find the
actual cluster centroids so now we move
the centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here on comparing the
distance of each individual's distance
to its own cluster mean and to that of
the opposite cluster we find that the
data points are stable hence we have our
final clusters now if you remember i
brought up a concept earlier k-mean on
the k-means algorithm choosing the right
value of k will help in less number of
iterations and to find the appropriate
number of clusters in a data set we use
the elbow method and within sum of
squares wss is defined as the sum of the
squared distance between each member of
the cluster in its centroid and so you
see we've done here is we have the
number of clusters and as you do
the same k-means algorithm over the
different clusters and you calculate
what that centroid looks like and you
find the optimal you can actually find
the optimal number of clusters using the
elbow the graph is called as the elbow
method
and on this we guessed it two just by
looking at the data but as you can see
the slope you actually just look for
right there where the elbow is in the
slope and you have a clear answer that
we want two different to start with k
means equals two a lot of times people
end up computing k-means equals two
three four five until they find the
value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain remember domain i
mentioned that last time you'll know
that where to pick those numbers or
where to start guessing at what that k
value is
so let's take this and we're going to
use a use case using k-means clustering
to cluster cars into brands using
parameters such as horsepower cubic
inches make year etc so we're going to
use the data set cars data having
information about three brands of cars
toyota honda and nissan we'll go back to
my favorite tool the anaconda navigator
with the jupiter notebook and let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and in our jupiter notebook i'm
going to go ahead and just paste the
basic
code that we usually start a lot of
these off with we're not going to go too
much into this code because we've
already discussed numpy we've already
discussed matplot library and pandas
that'll be being the number array pandas
being the pandas dataframe and map plot
for the graphing and don't forget since
if you're using the jupiter notebook you
do need the matplot library inline so
that it plots everything on the screen
if you're using a different python
editor then you probably don't need that
because it'll have a pop-up window on
your computer we'll go ahead and run
this just to load our libraries and our
setup into here the next step is of
course to look at our data which i've
already opened up in a spreadsheet and
you can see here we have the miles per
gallon cylinders cubic inches horsepower
weight pounds how heavy it is time it
takes to get to 60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90. what year it is so this is you
can actually see this is kind of older
cars and then the brand toyota honda
nissan so the different cars are coming
from all the way from 1971 if we scroll
down
to the 80s we have between the 70s and
80s the number of cars that they've put
out
and let's uh we come back here we're
going to importing the data so we'll go
ahead and do data set equals and we'll
use pandas to read this in and it's uh
from a csv file remember you can always
post this in the comments and request
the data files for these either in the
comments here on the youtube video or go
to simplylearn.com and request that the
car csv i put it in the same folder as
the code that i've stored so my python
code is stored in the same folder so i
don't have to put the full path if you
store them in different folders you do
have to change this and double check
your name variables and we'll go ahead
and run this and we've chosen data set
arbitrarily because it's a data set
we're importing and we've now imported
our car csv into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the x data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there's a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
for i
and x dot columns so we're going to go
through each of the columns
and a lot of times it's important i'll
make lists of the columns and do this
because i might remove certain columns
or there might be columns that i want to
be processed differently but for this we
can go ahead and take x of i
and we want to go fill in a and that's a
pandas command but the question is what
are we going to fill the missing data
with we definitely don't want to just
put in a number that doesn't actually
mean something and so one of the tricks
you can do with this
is we can take x of i
and in addition to that we want to go
ahead and turn this into
an integer because a lot of these are
integers so we'll go ahead and keep it
integers and let me add the bracket here
and a lot of editors will do this
they'll think that you're closing one
bracket make sure you get that second
bracket in there if it's a double
bracket that's always something that
happens regularly so once we have our
integer of x of i this is going to fill
in any missing data with the average
and i was so busy closing one set of
brackets i forgot that the mean is also
has brackets in there for the pandas so
we can see here we're going to fill in
all the data with the average value for
that column so if there's missing data
it's in the average of the data it does
have then once we've done that we'll go
ahead and loop through it again
and just check and see
to make sure everything is filled in
correctly and we'll print and then we
take x
is null and this returns a set of the
null value or the how many lines are
null and we'll just sum that up to see
what that looks like and so when i run
this
and so with the x what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because that had the models that's what
we're trying to see if we can cluster
these things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the x out for one we could take the x
and we could go data set our variable
we're using and use the i location one
of the features that's in pandas
and we could take that and then take all
the rows
and all but the last column of the data
set
and at this time we could do values we
just converted to values so that's one
way to do this and if i let me just put
this down here and print
x
it's a capital x we chose and i run this
you can see it's just the values
we could also take out the values and
it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it what i like to do with this
is instead of doing the ilocation which
does integers more common is to come in
here and we have our data set and we're
going to do data set
dot or data set dot columns and remember
that lists all the columns so if i come
in here
let me just mark that as red
and i print
data set dot columns
you can see that i have my index here i
have my mpg cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand would
be to do data columns of everything but
the last one minus one so now if i print
this you'll see the brand disappears
and so i can actually just take
data set columns minus one
and i'll put it right in here for the
columns we're going to look
at and let's un mark this
and unmark this
and now if i do an x dot head
i have a new data frame and you can see
right here we have all the different
columns except for the brand at the end
of the year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set you're going to get an
error later on and it'll say cannot
convert string to float value and that's
because if for some reason these things
the way they recorded them must been
recorded as strings so we have a neat
feature in here
on pandas to convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert underscore
numeric numeric
equals
true and yes i did have to go look that
up i don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there if i'm working with a
lot of these things i remember them but
depending on where i'm at what i'm doing
i usually have to look it up and we run
that oops i must have missed something
in here let me double check my spelling
and when i double check my spelling
you'll see i missed the first underscore
in the convert objects when i run this
it now has everything converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data and eliminate null
values
most people when they're doing small
amounts working with small data pools
discover afterwards that they have a
null value and they have to go back and
do this
so you know be aware whenever we're
formatting this data things are going to
pop up and sometimes you go backwards to
fix it
and that's fine that's just part of
exploring the data and understanding
what you have
and i should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go
easier to see
so we'll do 4i in
working with x dot
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take
x of i and we're going to change that
we're going to alter it
and so
with this we want to go ahead and fill
in
x of i pandas has the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data
then we'll put my brackets up and
there's a lot of different ways to fill
this data
if you have a really large data set some
people just void out that data because
and then look at it later in a separate
exploration of data
one of the tricks we can do is we can
take our column
and we can find the means
and the means is in other are quotation
marks
so we take the columns we're going to
fill in the non-existing one with the
means the problem is that returns a
decimal float so some of these aren't
decimals
certainly let me be a little careful of
doing this but for this example we're
just going to fill it in with the
integer version of this keeps it on par
with the other data that isn't a decimal
point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check then you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right so we're
going to go through and test
for missing data
and one of the ways you can do that is
simply go in here
and take our x of i column so it's going
to go through the x of i column it says
is null so it's going to return any any
place there's a null value it actually
goes through all the rows of each column
is null and then we want to go ahead and
sum that so we take that and we add the
sum value and these are all pandas so is
null is a panda command and so is sum
and if we go through that we go ahead
and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data
and at this point we're actually going
to
start using the elbow method to find the
optimal number of clusters so we're now
actually getting into the sk learn part
the k means clustering on here
i guess we'll go ahead and zoom it up
one more not so you can see what i'm
typing in here
and then from
sk learn we're going to our sk learn
cluster
we're going to import
k
means
i always forget to capitalize the k and
the m when i do this
so it's capital k capital m k means
and we'll go and create a
array wcss equals when we get an empty
array if you remember from the elbow
method from our slide
within the sums of squares wss is
defined as the sum of square distance
between each member of the cluster and
its centroid so we're looking at that
change in differences as far as a square
distance and we're going to run this
over a number of k-mean values
in fact let's go for i in range we'll do
11 of them
rain 0 11
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create the actual
[Music]
all lower case
and so we're going to create this object
from the k-means that we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this is in
clusters we're going to set that equals
to i
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how increasing the
number of clusters
changes our answer there are a lot of
settings to the k means
our guys in the back did a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones that you see in a
lot of stuff is how you init your
k-means so we have k-means plus
plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a max
iteration we put in there
we have the infinite the random state
equals zero you really don't need to
worry too much about these when you're
first learning this as you start digging
in deeper you start finding that these
are shortcuts that will speed up the
process
as far as the setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in clusters
equals i so we're going to literally
train our k means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times
and if you're working with big data you
know the first thing you do is you run a
small sample of the data so you can test
all your stuff on it and you can already
see the problem that if i'm going to
iterate through a terabyte of data 11
times and then the k-means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times that's a heck of a process
so you got to be a little careful with
this a lot of times though you can find
your elbow using the elbow method find
your optimal number on a sample of data
especially if you're working with larger
data sources
so we want to go ahead and take our
k-means and we're just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the sklearn
very common you fit your model and if
you remember correctly our variable
we're using is the capital x
and once we fit this value we go back to
the array we made we want to go and just
depend that value on the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it generates
it it generates the value you're looking
for is inertia so k means dot inertia
will pull that specific value out that
we need
and let's get a visual on this we'll do
our plt plot
and what we're plotting here
is first the x axis which is range 0
11 so that will generate a nice little
plot there and the wcss for our y-axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title and let's get
some labels so let's go ahead and do plt
x label
and we'll do a number of clusters for
that
and plt y label
and for that we can do oops there we go
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there and finally we want to
go ahead and display our graph which is
simply plt dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline it'll appear in line
hopefully i didn't make a type error on
there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there at
2 and again right around three and four
and then after that there's not very
much
now as a data scientist if i was looking
at this
i would do either three or four and i'd
actually try both of them to see what
the
output look like and they've already
tried this in the back so we're just
going to use three as a setup on here
and let's go ahead and see what that
looks like when we actually use this
to show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the car's data set
and basically we're going to copy the
code that we loop through up above
where k-means equals k-means number of
clusters and we're just going to set the
number of clusters to 3.
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do 3 and 4 on this and
graph them just to see how they come up
differently be kind of curious to look
at that but for this we're just going to
set it to 3. go ahead and create our own
variable y
k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there to k means
but we're not going to do a fit we're
going to do a fit predict is the setup
you want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see a slightly
different cause usually you see fit and
then you see just the predict but we
want to both fit and predict the k-means
on this and that's fit underscore
predict and then our capital x is the
data we're working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick we're going
to take our x value and we're going to
set x as matrix
so we're converting this into a nice
rows and columns kind of set up but we
want the we're going to have columns
equals none so it's just going to be a
matrix of data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see these
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions instead of matrix now that it's
more common to set it dot values instead
of doing as matrix but math matrix works
just fine for right now and you'll want
to update that later on but let's go
ahead and dive in and plot this and see
what that looks like and before we dive
into plotting this data i always like to
take a look and see what i am plotting
so let's take a look at y
k means i'm just going to print that out
down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 1 2
so it's clustering these different
rows of data
based on the three different spaces it
thinks it's going to be
and then let's go ahead and print x and
see what we have for x and we'll see
that x is an array it's a matrix so we
have our different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array so we're only going to be
looking at the first
two or positions zero and one
and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting
you might actually do a little different
than and dig a little deeper into the
different aspects because this is all
the different columns we looked at but
we look at columns one and two for this
to make it easy
so let's go ahead and clear this data
out of here and let's bring up our plot
and we're going to do a scatter plot
here so plt scatter
and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this we're
going to take the x values
and we're only interested in
y of k means equals zero the first
cluster
okay
and then we're going to take value zero
for the x axis and then we're gonna do
the same thing here
we're only interested in
k means equals zero but we're going to
take the second column so we're looking
at the first two columns in our answer
or in the data
and then the guys in the back played
with this a little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
with as a size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots
we're going to use red for this one and
when they were looking at the data and
what came out it was definitely the
toyota on this we're just going to go
ahead and label it toyota again that's
something you really have to explore in
here as far as playing with those
numbers and see what looks good we'll go
ahead and hit enter in there and i'm
just going to paste in the next
two lines which is the next two cars
and this is our nissa and honda
and you'll see with our scatter plot
we're now looking at where y underscore
k means equals one
and we want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns zero and one
and each of these rows then corresponds
to nissan and honda
and i'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and finally let's take a look and put
the centroids on there
again we're going to do a scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our k-means the model we
created
dot cluster centers
and we're going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with zero and
one
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them it's always good to have some good
labels
centroids and then we do want to do a
title plt
title
and pop up there
plt title cause you always want to make
your graphs look pretty and we'll call
it clusters of car make
and one of the features of the
plot library is you can add a
legend it'll automatically bring in it
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
toyota nissan and honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's inline so if you're using a
different editor that's not the jupiter
notebook you'll get a pop-up of this
and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this we
have a clusters of honda and green
toyota and red
nissan and purple and you can see where
they put the centroids to separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other different data
on here as far because we only looked at
the first two columns this is just
column one and two or zero one as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have nice clusters of
car make and we were able to pull out
the data and you can see how just these
two columns
form very distinct clusters of data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different
almost going in reverse you start
looking at the data and pulling apart
the columns to find out
why is the first group set up the way it
is maybe you're doing loans and you want
to go why is this group not defaulting
on their loans and why is the last group
defaulting on their loans and why is the
middle group 50 percent defaulting on
their
bank loans and you start finding ways to
manipulate the data and pull out the
answers you want
so now that you've seen how to use
k-mean for clustering
let's move on to the next topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm is the
simplest classification algorithm used
for binary or multi-classification
problems and we can see we have our
little girl from canada who's into
horror books is back that's actually
really scary when you think about that
with those big eyes in the previous
tutorial we learned about linear
regression dependent and independent
variables so to brush up y equals mx
plus c
very basic algebraic function of
y and x the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict
the independent variables x1 all the way
up to xn are the features or attributes
we're going to use to predict the target
class we know what a linear regression
looks like but using the graph we cannot
divide the outcome into categories
it's really hard to categorize 1.5 3.6
9.8
for example a linear regression graph
can tell us that with increase in number
of hours studied the marks of a student
will increase but it will not tell us
whether the student will pass or not in
such cases where we need the output as
categorical value we will use logistic
regression and for that we're going to
use the sigmoid function so you can see
here we have our marks 0 to 100 number
of hours studied that's going to be what
they're comparing it to in this example
and we usually form a line that says y
equals mx plus c and when we use the
sigmoid function we have p equals 1 over
1 plus e to the minus y
it generates a sigmoid curve and so you
can see right here when you take the ln
which is the natural logarithm i always
thought it should be nl not ln that's
just the inverse of e your e to the
minus y and so we do this we get ln of p
over 1 minus p equals m times x plus c
that's the sigmoid curve function we're
looking for and we can zoom in on the
function and you'll see that the
function as it derives goes to 1 or to 0
depending on what your x value is and
the probability if it's greater than 0.5
the value is automatically rounded off
to 1 indicating that the student will
pass so if they're doing a certain
amount of studying they will probably
pass then you have a threshold value at
the 0.5 it automatically puts that right
in the middle usually and your
probability if it's less than 0.5 the
value rendered off to zero indicating
the student will fail so if they're not
studying very hard they're probably
going to fail this of course is ignoring
the outliers or that one student is just
a natural genius and doesn't need any
studying to memorize everything that's
not me unfortunately
i have to study hard to learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant or benign and this is
actually one of my favorite data sets to
play with because it has so many
features and when you look at them you
really are hard to understand you can't
just look at them and know the answer so
it gives you a chance to kind of dive
into what data looks like when you
aren't able to understand the specific
domain of the data but i also want you
to remind you that in the domain of
medicine if i told you that my
probability
was really good it classified things
that say 90 or 95
and i'm classifying whether you're going
to have a malignant or a b9 tumor i'm
guessing that you're going to go get it
tested anyways so you got to remember
the domain we're working with so why
would you want to do that if you know
you're just going to go get a biopsy
because you know it's that serious this
is like an all or nothing just
referencing the domain it's important it
might help the doctor know where to look
just by understanding what kind of tumor
it is so it might help them or aid them
and something they missed from before so
let's go ahead and dive into the code
and i'll come back to the domain part of
it in just a minute so use case and
we're going to do our normal imports
here where we're importing numpy pandas
seaborn the matplot library and we're
going to do matplot library inline since
i'm going to switch over to anaconda so
let's go ahead and flip over there and
get this started
so i've opened up a new window in my
anaconda jupiter notebook
and by the way jupiter notebook you
don't have to use anaconda for the
jupiter notebook i just love the
interface and all the tools and anaconda
brings so we got our import numpy as in
p for our numpy number array we have our
pandas pd we're going to bring in
seaborn to help us with our graphs as
sns
so many really nice tools in both
seaborne and matplot library and we'll
do our matplot library.piplot as plt and
then of course we want to let it know to
do it in line and let's go and just run
that so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data
not creative today
equals pd and this happens to be in a
csv file
so we'll use the pd.read underscore csv
and i happen to name the file i renamed
it
data4p2.csv you can of course write in
the comments below the youtube and
request for the dataset itself or go to
the simplylearn website and we'll be
happy to supply that for you
and let's just open up the data before
we go any further and let's just see
what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when i pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just a csv file
comma separated variables we have an id
so i guess the
categorize this for reference or what id
which test was done the diagnosis m for
malignant b for b9 so there's two
different options on there and that's
what we're going to try to predict is
the m and b and test it and then we have
like the radius
mean or average the texture average
perimeter mean area mean smoothness i
don't know about you but unless you're a
doctor in the field most of the stuff i
mean you can guess what concave means
just by the term concave but i really
wouldn't know what that means in the
measurements they're taking so they have
all kinds of stuff like how smooth it is
uh the symmetry and these are all float
values we just page through them real
quick and you'll see there's i believe
36 if i remember correctly in this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth
so back in our data and i put this in
the same folder as a code so i saved
this code in that folder obviously if
you have it in a different location you
want to put the full path in there and
we'll just do
pandas
first five lines of data with the data
dot head
when we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an id we have a diagnosis
if we go all the way across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
seaborn which we referenced as sns
makes it very easy to go in here and do
a joint plot you'll notice that very
similar to because it is sitting on top
of the
plot library so the joint plot does a
lot of work for us and we're just going
to look at the first two
columns that we're interested in the
radius mean and the texture mean we'll
just look at those two columns
and data equals data so that tells it
which two columns we're plotting and
then we're going to use the data that we
pulled in let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here
and there's all kinds of cool things on
this graph to look at i mean we have the
texture mean and the radius mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram they show
that for the radius mean whereas the
most commons radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is so
we're looking at the tech the
on each growth its average texture and
on each radius its average
radius on there gets a little confusing
because we're talking about the
individual objects average and then we
can also look over here and see the
histogram showing us the median or how
common each measurement is
and that's only two columns so let's dig
a little deeper into seaborn they also
have a heat map and if you're not
familiar with heat maps a heat map just
means it's in color that's all that
means heat map i guess the original ones
were plotting heat density on something
and so ever since then it's just called
a heat map
and we're going to take our data
and get our corresponding numbers to put
that into the heat map and that's simply
data dot c-o-r-r
for that that's a pandas expression
let's remember we're working in a pandas
data frame so that's one of the cool
tools in pandas for our data and this is
pull that information into a heat map
and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
id we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points
and if you look down the middle of this
chart diagonal going from the upper left
to bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're 100 percent or in
this case a perfect one in their
correspondence
and you'll see that when you look at say
area or right below it it has almost a
black on there when you compare it to
texture so these have almost no
corresponding data they don't really
form a linear graph or something that
you can look at and say how connected
they are they're very scattered data
this is really just a really nice graph
to get a quick look at your data doesn't
so much change what you do but it
changes verifying so when you get an
answer or something like that or you
start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're going to
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but it does show some really cool
information on here and we can see from
the id
there's no real one feature that just
says if you go across the top line that
lights up there's no one feature that
says hey if the area is a certain size
then it's going to be b9 or malignant it
says there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big hint in the data that
we're trying to id this whether it's
malignant or b9 that's a big hint to us
as data scientists to go okay
we can't solve this with any one feature
it's going to be something that includes
all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring the data let's explore one
more area and let's look at data dot is
null we want to check for null values in
our data if you remember from earlier in
this tutorial we did it a little
differently where we added stuff up and
summed them up you can actually with
pandas do it really quickly data dot is
null and summit and it's going to go
across all the columns so when i run
this
you're going to see all the columns come
up with no null data
so we've just just to re hash these last
few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seeing how they plot with the
seaborn with a joint plot which shows
both the histogram and the data plotted
on the xy coordinates
and obviously you can do that more in
detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the seaborne
heat map the sns
dot heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other and forms a
very nice combination or points of
scattering points and you can also see
areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says no values okay
so not a big deal if you miss it but
it's no fun having to go back when
you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you've got to go
remember where you were pulling the data
in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
x
and our y so we just put that down here
and we'll set the x equal to
and there's a lot of different options
here certainly we could do x equals all
the columns except for the first two
because if you remember the first two is
the id and the diagnosis
so that certainly would be an option
but we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus on the worst the worst
radius the worst texture parameter area
smoothness compactness and so on one of
the reasons to start dividing your data
up
when you're looking at this information
is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if i have two measurements
coming in to my model it might overweigh
them it might overpower the other
measurements because it's measuring it's
basically taking that information in
twice
that's a little bit past the scope of
this tutorial i want you to take away
from this though is that we are dividing
the data up into pieces and our team in
the back went ahead and said hey let's
just look at the worst so i'm going to
create a an array
and you'll see this array radius worst
texture worse perimeter worst we've just
taken the worst of the worst and i'm
just going to put that in my x so this x
is still a pandas data frame but it's
just those columns and our y if you
remember correctly is going to be oops
hold on one second it's not x it's data
there we go so x equals data and then
it's a list of the different columns the
worst of the worst and if we're going to
take that then we have to have our
answer for our y for the stuff we know
and if you remember correctly we're just
going to be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it b9 or
malignant
and since it's a single column we can
just do diagnosis oh i forgot to put the
brackets or the there we go okay so it's
just diagnosis on there and we can also
real quickly do like x dot head if you
want to see what that looks like
and y dot head
and run this
and you'll see
it only does the last one i forgot about
that if you don't do print you can see
that the the y dot head is just mmm
because the first ones are all malignant
and if i run this the x dot head is just
the first five values of radius worse
texture worse parameter worst area worst
and so on
i'll go ahead and take that out
so moving down
to the next step we've built our two
data sets our answer and then the
features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test your
model
so we do that by splitting the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import train test split so
we're going to split it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this i
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
which is past the scope of this and for
this particular example isn't necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the
sklearn
dot model selection we have train test
split you could write your own quick
code to do this we just randomly divide
the data up into two groups but they do
it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables
capital x train capital x test so we
have our training data we're going to
use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just imported
and we're going to do x and our y are
two different data that's going in for
our split
and then the guys in the back came up
and wanted us to go ahead and use a test
size equals 0.3 that's test underscore
size
random state it's always nice to kind of
switch your random state around but not
that important
what this means is that the test size is
we're going to take 30 percent of the
data and we're going to put that into
our test variables our y test and our x
test and we're going to do 70 into the x
train and the y train so we're going to
use 70 of the data to train our model
and 30 to test it
let's go ahead and run that and load
those up
so now we have all our stuff split up
and all our data ready to go and now we
get to the actual logistics part we're
actually going to do our create our
model so let's go ahead and bring that
in from sklearn we're going to bring in
our linear model and we're going to
import logistic regression that's the
actual model we're using and this we'll
call it log model
stereo model and let's just set this
equal to our logistic regression that we
just imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the
models in the sk learn we just need to
go ahead and fix it fit
do a fit on there and we use our x train
that we separated out with our y
train and let's go ahead and run this so
once we've run this we'll have a model
that fits this data that 70 percent of
our training data
and of course it prints this out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make but
for word though we're just going to let
all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example there's nothing in
here that really stands out as super
important until you start fine tuning it
but for what we're doing the basics will
work just fine and then let's we need to
go ahead and test out our model is it
working so let's create a variable y
predict and this is going to be equal to
our log model
and we want to do a predict again very
standard format for the sk learn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it and we're going to test why
predict against the y test so we want to
know what the model thinks it's going to
be that's what our y predict is and with
that we want the capital x x
test
so we have our train set and our test
set and now we're going to do our y
predict and let's go ahead and run that
and if we uh print
y
predict
let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it presents
and i prints a nice array of
b and m for b9 and malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so it does pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and is functional
was very easy to create you'll always
discover with our data science that as
you explore this
you spend a significant amount of time
prepping your data
and making sure your data coming in is
good
there's a saying
good data in good answers out bad data
in
bad answers out that's only half the
thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predictor log model.predict x test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrics we're going to import
classification report
and that just reports how good our model
is doing and then we're going to feed it
the model data let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual data so this is what
we actually know is true
and our prediction what our model
predicted for that data on the test side
and let's run that and see what that
does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have
a precision for b9 and malignant b and m
and we have a precision of 93 at 91 a
total of 92 so it's kind of the average
between these two 92
there's all kinds of different
information on here your f1 score
your recall your support coming through
on this
and for this i'll go ahead and just flip
back to our slides that they put
together for describing it and so here
we're going to look at the precision
using the classification report and you
see this is the same printout i had up
above some of the numbers might be
different because it does randomly pick
out which data we're using so this model
is able to predict the type of tumor
with 91 percent accuracy
so we look back here let's you'll see
where we have uh b9 and england it
actually is 92 coming up here but we're
looking about a 92 91 precision and
remember i reminded you about domains
and we're talking about the domain of a
medical domain with a very catastrophic
outcome you know at 91 or 92 percent
precision you're still going to go in
there and have somebody do a biopsy on
it very different than if you're
investing money and there's a 92 percent
chance you're going to earn 10 percent
and 8 chance you're going to lose 8
percent you're probably gonna bet the
money because at that odds it's pretty
good that you'll make some money and in
the long run you do that enough you
definitely will make money and also with
this domain i've actually seen them use
this to identify different forms of
cancer that's one of the things that
they're starting to use these models for
because then it helps the doctor know
what to investigate so that wraps up
this section we're finally we're going
to go in there and let's discuss the
answer to the quiz asked in machine
learning tutorial part one
can you tell what's happening in the
following cases grouping documents into
different categories based on the topic
and content of each document this is an
example of clustering where k-means
clustering can be used to group the
documents by topics using bag of words
approach so if you've gotten in there
that you're looking for clustering and
hopefully you had at least one or two
examples like k-means that are used for
clustering different things then give
yourself a two thumbs up
b identifying handwritten digits in
images correctly
this is an example of classification the
traditional approach to solving this
would be to extract digit dependent
features like curvature of different
digits etc and then use a classifier
like svm to distinguish between images
again if you got the fact that it's a
classification example give yourself a
thumb up and if you're able to go hey
let's use svm or another model for this
give yourself those two thumbs up on it
c behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed this
is an example of anomaly detection in
this case the algorithm learns what is
normal and what is not normal usually by
observing the logs of the website give
yourself a thumbs up if you got that one
and just for a bonus can you think of
another example of anomaly detection one
of the ones i use it for my own business
is detecting anomalies in stock markets
stock markets are very fickled and they
behave very radical so finding those
erratic areas and then finding ways to
track down why they're erratic was
something released in social media was
something released you can see where
knowing where that anomaly is can help
you to figure out what the answer is to
it in another area d predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience this is an example
of regression this problem can be
mathematically defined as a function
between independent years of experience
and dependent variables salary of an
individual and if you guess that this
was a regression model give yourself a
thumbs up and if you were able to
remember that it was between independent
and dependent variables and that terms
give yourself two thumbs up
summary so to wrap it up we went over
what is k means and we went through also
the chart of choosing your elbow method
and assigning a random centroid to the
clusters computing the distance and then
going in there and figuring out what the
minimum centroids is and computing the
distance and going through that loop
until it gets the perfect centroid and
we looked into the elbow method to
choose k based on running our clusters
across a number of variables and finding
the best location for that we did a nice
example of clustering cars with k means
even though we only looked at the first
two columns to make it simple and easy
to graph you can easily extrapolate that
and look at all the different columns
and see how they all fit together and we
looked at what is logistic regression we
discussed the sigmoid function what is
logistic regression and then we went
into an example of classifying tumors
with logistics
i hope you enjoyed part two of machine
learning thank you for joining us today
for more information visit
www.simplylearn.com
again my name is richard kirschner a
member of the simply learn team get
certified get ahead if you have any
questions or comments feel free to write
those down below the youtube video or
visit us at simplylearn.com we'll be
happy to supply you with the data sets
or other information as requested
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
today we're going to cover the k nearest
neighbors allowed to refer to as k n n
and k n is really a fundamental place to
start in the machine learning it's the
basis of a lot of other things and just
the logic behind it is easy to
understand and incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need k n
n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part
the use case predict whether a person
will have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there watching the black cat cross their
path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp brother claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has a smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and it
goes in the cat group because knn is
based on feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat he classifies a data point
based on how his neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
and so we're going to talk about it how
do we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k is a process called
parameter tuning and is important for
better accuracy so at k equals three we
can classify we have a question mark in
the middle as either a as a square or
not is it a square or is it in this case
a triangle and so if we set k equals to
three we're going to look at the three
nearest neighbors we're going to say
this is a square and if we put k equals
a seven we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around and you can see as the k changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get he's like oh my
gosh they choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using uh like in
this case squares and triangles if it's
even you want to make your k value odd
that helps it select better so in other
words you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what we're just voting normal
normal normal three votes for normal
this is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the knn
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
uh very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can then use a
simple pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see i have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and since we're
working on the n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and i'm
also going to go up here and click on
cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then i'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
i'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our trained test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between minus 1 and 1. and then
the actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so that we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there
we can also do a quick length of the
data set that is a simple python command
len for length we might even let's go
ahead and print that we'll go print and
if you do it on its own line link that
data set the jupyter notebook it'll
automatically print it but when you're
in most of your different setups you
want to do the print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals data set column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also one that's
that you look for your nan a lot of
different options in here but the n a n
in num p n a n is what that stands for
is none it doesn't exist so the first
thing we're doing here is we're
replacing the zero with a numpy none
there's no data there that's what that
says that's what this is saying right
here so put the 0 in and we're going to
place zeros with no data so if it's a 0
that means the person's well hopefully
not dead hope they just didn't get the
data the next thing we want to do is
we're going to create the mean which is
the integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the npn with the means why did we do
that we could have actually just taken
this step and gone right down here and
just replaced zero and skip anything
where except you could actually there's
a way to skip zeros and then just
replace all the zeros but in this case
we want to go ahead and do it this way
so you could see that we're switching
this to a non-existent value then we're
going to create the mean well this is
the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see you skipped a bunch
in the middle because that's what it
does if you have too many lines in
jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and go
on to the next in a data set let me go
and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we put it in
here is outcome well that's not part of
the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here 0 this is
actually 0 to 7 it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column 8 and you can do it
this way with this particular notation
and then if you remember we imported the
train test split that's part of the sk
learn right there and we simply put in
our x and our y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you see it i have to
look that up and then the test size test
size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scal the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to 6 we're going to set that
all so that all the data is between -1
and one that's what that standard scalar
does keeps it standardized and we only
want to fit the scalar with the training
set but we want to make sure the testing
set is the x test going in is also
transformed so it's processing it the
same so here we go with our standard
scalar we're going to call it sc
underscore x for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our x train
equals sc underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the x
train variable and then our x test we're
also going to transform it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to run this
if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns it shouldn't be zero and
we replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we scaled the
data so all of our data going in no no
we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11 remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are the diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ahead and run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is you
have the y predicted which would be your
title up here you could do let's just do
p-r-e-d
predict it across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is in 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the f1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our f1 score
the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives
where if we go ahead and just do the
accuracy account and that's what most
people think of is it looks at just how
many we got right out of how many we got
wrong so a lot of people when you're a
data scientist and you're talking to
other data scientists they're going to
ask you what the f1 score the f score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model the principal component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction
principle component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company bpex isomax and they have
the item the tire the axle an order id a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells we find out
that using correlation analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up why dimensionality
reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four what
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it principle component analysis
so what is it
principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result
we have the different colors all lined
up so what we're going to take a look at
is let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
uh so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data it's not
you really can't do it by what you think
is going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen uh in
the petals and they have width and they
have length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the width-to-length ratio we
can divide the width by the length and
you get a single number where you had
two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at uh same thing with like a bank loan
model we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the x y
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our ease we can consider that
we get two principal components namely
pc1 and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in
pc1 if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
pc2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective which would help
in understanding how pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the
ratio instead which is a single number
versus two separate numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense uh you're
not going to do 10 principal properties
with only three features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principal components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line when we
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2 and we want to make
sure that pc1 does not equal pc2 we
don't want to have the same two
principal points
when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers increase
this is important to understand
if you're going to create
uh one principle
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talked about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector is like a
translation for um
moving the data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever we're altering it and the igen
value is the final value that we
generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them lie within similar
boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean over
the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on and so if we do
a setup like this we should see all
those different features as the
different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i gene vectors
i gene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table they are responsible for the
generation of a new set of variables
from the old set of variables which
further lead to the construction of the
principal components
igen vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just change
transforming that data so we're going to
change
the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so when we have like multiple
variables how do we calculate that new
variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has igen
vectors of the components that we decide
to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at the back end of this
and we'll do this in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns are variables now for this
matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k-dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm it represents the maximum
variance direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set
thus a second principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example
i believe there's even like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our jupiter i'm in
chrome and we go ahead and create a new
python 3.
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing i like to do
whenever i'm looking at
any new setup
well you know what let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library
pandas our data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that
but i put it in there either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is
let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description um
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup
uh what's important is you start looking
at what the different attributes are
what they mean if you were in the
medical field you'd want to note all
these different things whether what
they're measuring where it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different
measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9
um so in other words is this
uh dangerous growth or is it something
we don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of
reading it's hard to get that just right
that's all you have to do
so let's go ahead and look at our data
uh our we're going to use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head
and you can see here we have the mean
radius the mean texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that most the data
that comes in half the time we don't
even know we're looking at
we're just handed a bunch of stuff as a
data scientist going what the heck is
this and so this is a good place to
start because this has a number of
different features in there we have no
idea what these feature means or where
they come from we want to just look at
the data and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
is difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization
it's already going to scale it when we
do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other preprocessing functions
that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
uh so the code for this
is
from sklearn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals two
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much and then you also might look at the
svd solver it's on auto right now but
you can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup we're
fitting the data we're taking a look at
it
we've already looked at our
minimum maximum we've already looked at
what's in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and uh
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
of one these are two different
perceptions we're using
and then
you'll see right here c for color cancer
equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
uh so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principle component second
principle component and we'll go ahead
and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something
in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps
and we're not going to have a clear
result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently versus going in
and saying just cutting into the can
into the cancer so the body absorbs it
and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here and that middle
line where the overlap is going to be
huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here
clearly by using these two components we
can easily separate these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one licks work represents or second
principle the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do look at the pca components this
is in our model we built we've trained
it we can run that and you can see
here's the actual components uh it's the
two components have each have their own
array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down i've already got it down here
we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame
and we do our pca components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and
and set it up for us we want and so
we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map of our data frame
composition and we'll use the plasma
coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom on the right
we have a scale so we can see we have
the dark colors all the way to the
really light colors which are
what's really shining there this is like
the primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map and the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how on the bottom of the map it is
um on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean what you
want to change to get a better result
regularization in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data
understanding linear regression
bias and variance
what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
science is overfitting and underfitting
what does that mean
and what is regularization and then
we'll do a quick hands-on demo to take a
look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data and we talk about what
is data fitting it's a process of
plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go in a little deeper on there
so we might have in this case just the
two dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1 000 kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship
very specifically linear means line
the line used to represent the
relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear relationship
linear regression
so let's start with how linear
regression works a linear regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line that now becomes
a plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to this linear kind of drawing a
line through your data and finding what
fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example uh
let's say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw l1 and l2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claim to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line l1
and each data point and add them all and
find the mean
distance and i want you to think about
that when we
square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line it's on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss and we have a
positive distance and a negative
distance and of course when we square it
it is neither it just becomes a positive
error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as mse
if i look in the code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse
i know that's a mean squared error
and we take all the dotted lines and we
calculate this error we add them all
together and then we average it or find
the means
and in this case
they ran a demo on this and it was uh
for our l1 line
now we find the loss function for line
l2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be 6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for l1 than l2 hence l1 is
the best fit line
this process describes a lot of machine
learning processes it was we're going to
keep guessing and get as close as we can
to find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite to
calculate this and figure out which
one's the best and the mean square error
is one of the better fits to doing for
doing this and most commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance
very important terms to know in machine
learning and with linear regression
so bias
bias occurs when an algorithm has
limited flexibility to learn from data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is very specific
and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and over simplify the
model therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and uh with bias if you over simplify it
so much you're going to miss
your
local
if if you have like a really
good fit you're going to miss it you're
you're going to just kind of
guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to be
with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data
and i want you to think about this
when we're talking about a bias
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of
getting an average we're not really
fitting it close
with variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants
suddenly a
truck has to have certain features and
it might have to be red
because you had so many red pictures so
if it has if it's an 18 wheeler it has
to be red if it's blue then it has to be
a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something and it cannot get the right
answer unless it gets a very specific
data
and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models
and you programmed it you got to look
for
how i trained it what is coming out and
if it's not if it's not looking good on
either bias or if it's not looking good
on the training
or on the test data
then your bias then you're biasing your
data
if it really looks good on the training
data then that's going to be your
variance you've over fitted the data
and those are very important things to
know when you are building your models
in regression of any kind or any kind of
setup for predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall on
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting
when we talk about overfitting it's a
scenario where the machine learning
model tries to learn from the details
along with the noise and the data tries
to fit each data point on the curve
uh you can see that
um
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever is fitted
every point on the data stream there's
no average there's no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because uh if the wind blows a certain
way
in the efficiency of your car maybe you
have a headwind so your car might alter
how efficient it is as it goes and so
there's going to be this variance on
here and this says no you can't have any
variance with you know the this is it's
going to be exactly this it can't be any
you can't be the same speed or the same
car and have a slightly different
efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
uh so you'll get like a really high
error on here
and so
reasons for overfitting
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data and it's so important it's so
important that if you have if you have
some kind of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data maybe they use in
medical different measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine b
that's testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance
again wind is a good example i was
talking about that with the car
you may have a hundred tests but because
the wind's blowing it's all over the
place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem you only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex
this comes up a lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked
and so you have to go back back break it
up and find out actually what correlates
and what doesn't
so
what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models
can either learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from
[Music]
uh the mod the most common is the
driving cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have
five people from india and 10 people
from
africa and 20 people from the u.s you
created a bias
because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs a slight
shift to it for other reasons
so what is a good fit
a linear curve that best fits the data
is neither overfitting or underfitting
models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting lines
going up and down every point is trying
to be include gluted underfitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that
error coming through regularization is
taking the guesswork out you're looking
at this graph and you're going oh which
one is that really over fit or is that
under fit that's pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
underfitting
so what that means
in this case we're going to go ahead and
take a look at a couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn module you could bring in the
ridge module and you can bring in the
lasso module
so when we talk about
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either square it or we absolute value
it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our
in this case the lambda is going to be
the penalty for the errors we've thrown
in a greek character for you just to
confuse everybody
and w is the slope of the curve of the
line
so uh we're going to look at this and
we're going to draw a line this is going
to be like a linear regression model so
if you had in sk learned you could
import just a standard linear regression
model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data but you don't want to get
into the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero uh considering the two
points on the line we'll go and do
lambda equals one we'll set our w is
going to be one point
then the cost function equals 0 plus 1
times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so
really don't get caught up too much in
the math on this other than
understanding that this is something
that's very easy for a computer to
calculate and if you ever see the loss
plus the plus the lambda times w the sum
of w squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through of the two
points we end up at the point
0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso mars
regression model for fitting especially
dealing with a lot of like stock markets
daily
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better
fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model
we're squaring the value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
and here is our
lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and w equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot
the ridge
and this is important this is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out
uh ridge regularization is useful when
we have many variables with relatively
smaller data samples
the model does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent overfitting
the lasser regularization model is
preferred when we are fitting a linear
model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as you measure
the different leaf pieces
you might be doing the measurements on
the cancer project
which has 36 different variables
so as we get down to the iris with four
variables
lasso lar will probably uh work pretty
good where you might use the ridge
regularization with more model with if
you have something significant larger
and it encourages the coefficients of
the variables to go towards zero because
of the shape of the constraint which is
an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and do a demo and lasso and ridge
regression so let's take a look and see
what that looks like in our code and
bring up our jupiter notebook
we'll start with our imports pandas is
pd import numpy is np import matplot
library as plt
um sklearn we're going to import our
data sets it's kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together
we have our sklearn model selection
we're going to import our train test
split for splitting our data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up
and then load our data set we're just
talking about that
you could just
have imported the load boston and boston
data set in there instead of loading all
the data sets
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and
see what we got here
let me just go ahead and pop that down
there and
go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
boston
data we're going to look we put it into
our pandas data frame
the boston data set and then the boston
columns so we want to see what's going
on with them
we have our target
we have the house price
etc and so our x equals boston um
eye location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want eye location if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do we print
the boston
panda's head we can see here all of our
different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x is everything
except for the last column
where y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then y is all the rows
but just the last column so y is our
house price and the x is the
crimson industry chas knox and all these
other different
statistics they've collected for house
sales in boston
there we go oops control
ah
so we'll go ahead and split our data uh
x train and our x
test y train y test equals the train
test split which we imported
and we have our boston you could have
easily used the x and y on here as
opposed to boston
eye location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 of the data and put it
in as a test
uh and then we'll go ahead and run this
i need an extra drink there
uh
so we have our train and test and then
of course the print the train data shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data print out the
shape
make sure everything looks correct uh so
that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by one
379 by 13 they should match
and if they're if the the data sets are
not quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors i
don't know how many times i've gone
through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird has
happened when i'm cleaning the data
this is pretty straightforward and
simple because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
and we'll call this l r e g l reg linear
regression and we're going to go ahead
and fit that linear regression model to
x train and y train
then we'll generate the prediction on
the test set uh so here's our l reg y
predict
with our x test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse i told you you'll see mse used
a lot
um people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common
and we get our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see these
kinds of numbers coming up
but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo uh
and then we're gonna go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at and you can see
here
we plot the coefficient scores on here
and we
the guys in the back did a great job
putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here
uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient um
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that flags you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score so now we want to take these and
and
bring them down as much as we can
and for that we're going to work with
the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going we're going to
import our ridge model
the rid regression from the sklearn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge
r equals alpha equals one and i
mentioned that earlier
when i work with the ridge model
you'll see alpha equals one if you set
alpha equal to zero that's a standard
linear regression model so you have
alpha equals one two three four and you
usually use one two or three four and a
standard integer on there and we'll go
ahead and fit the ridge model on there
with our x train and our y train data
generate a prediction for that for our x
test and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this should all
look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the
ridge coefficients for our data and see
what that looks like
now
if i jump up and down between these two
you'll get a headache
[Laughter]
you'll still see the knox value let's
just look at the knocks because that was
the biggest value is a minus 9 here and
if we go back up here the nox value is a
minus 18. so right off the bat i'm
seeing a huge change
in the biggest coefficient there
uh so if we're going to do that nice
setup we want to go ahead and just print
it and see what that looks like
here we go and we've set up our plot
subplots and again the team put together
some nice colors so it makes it look
good
and we're doing an x bar based on the
columns
and our
l regress coefficients color equals
color x spine bottom and so forth
so just put together a nice little graph
and you're starting to see
one this when you compare this if you
put on the same graph as this one up
here this is up here minus 18.
this is at minus 9
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
the same thing with these values here
they might look the same but they're
actually all
almost half the value on here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look
very similar as far as what we worked on
before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it
and again let's go up to uh knox
look where nox is it's all the way down
to zero
and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient it's minus 0.8 and really
here's our 22.73
let me go up here
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number
16.69
and so we look at this uh if i was
running this and doing a working on a
project with this i would look at these
numbers i start with the 16.69
come down here and compare it to
16.78
six nine is better than seven eight uh
so from the very beginning we might
start looking at this first model for
overall
predicting
but there's other factors involved uh we
might know that uh the knox value is
central and the other ones aren't quite
as good and so we might start looking at
just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have
a certain meaning to us and so forth and
so you can look at all those different
items in there again but the bottom
dollar is our first model did better
than our other two models our mean
square error on the test set
continues to
come down on this we're going to cover
reinforcement learning today and what's
in it for you
we'll start with why reinforcement
learning we'll look at what is
reinforcement learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement
we'll cover important terms specific to
reinforcement learning
we'll talk about markov's decision
process and we'll take a look at a
reinforcement learning example but we'll
teach a tic-tac-toe how to play
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us further the data provided might
not be reliable learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if i'm taking one
step forward and left
what happens if i pick up a 50 pound
object how does that change how a robot
would walk these things are very
difficult to program because there's no
actual information on it until it's
actually tried out learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular problem
and we'll see here learned how to walk
this is going to slow the growth that
technology is capable of machines need
to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain
a real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore and
play with it most of the models the
non-reinforcement models in computer
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well there's a couple of them that
can be used or integrated see how it
goes
is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains a model
to return an optimum solution for a
problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important is we're
looking for unique solutions
we want the best solution but you can't
find it unless you try it so we're
looking at
our different
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks
there's all kinds of things in between
decision trees
the data provided is labeled data with
output values specified
and this is important because we talk
about supervised learning you already
know the answer for all this information
you already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock you can already have like the
graph of what the next day looks like so
you have an answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and unsupervised
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with and you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning is part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems unlabeled data is
used
no supervision solves problems by
understanding patterns and discovering
output
so you can look at this and you can
think
some of these things go with each other
they belong together so it's looking for
what connects in different ways and
there's a lot of different algorithms
that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how it
can pick out say
the area of a donut
one model will see the area of the donut
and the other one will divide it into
three sections based on its location
versus what's next to it so there's a
lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market uh in machine learning
or growing market it's very it's very
infant stage
as far as how it works and what it's
going to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems
no predefined data is used no
supervision
follows trail and error problem solving
approach
so again we have a random at first you
start with a random i try this
it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do and you get your reward back and then
it looks at that and says well let's try
something else and it starts to play
with these different things finding the
best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years
so these are really good to know we have
the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual
entity that has however you're doing it
whether using a neural network or a
cue table or whatever combination
thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment
the training situation that the model
must optimize to is called its
environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get a chest full
of gyms or whatever and that's the
output
and then you have your action this is
all possible steps that can be taken by
the model and it picks one action and
you can see here it's picked three
different routes to get to the chest of
diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this uh if you're
playing like a video game
this is the screen you're looking at so
when you go back here
the environment is a whole game board so
if you're playing one of those mobius
games
you might have the whole game board
going on uh but then you have your
current position where are you on that
game board what's around that what's
around you
if you were talking about a robot
the environment might be moving around
the yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model and then
the reward to help the model move in the
right direction it is rewarded points
are given to it to appraise some kind of
action
so yeah you did good or didn't do as
good trying to maximize the reward and
have the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
state
this is part of the model what what is
your action that you're you're going to
take what's the policy you're using to
have an output from your agent
one of the reasons they separate uh
policy as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction um
of a different options
and then the policy well how am i going
to pick the best based on those
predictions i'm going to guess at
different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works
let's go and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train
so the dog would be like the agent so
you have your your puppy or whatever
and then your environment is going to be
the whole house or whatever it is where
you're training them
and then you have an action we want to
teach the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuit so we
can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering incentives such as a
dog biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself
uh so you have you know so we start off
with fetching it goes oh i get a biscuit
for that it tries something else you get
a handshake or begging or something like
that and it goes oh this is also reward
based and so it kind of explores things
to find out what will bring his biscuit
and that's very much like how a
reinforced model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explorers environment
this quality of model is called
exploration
so there's a little randomness going on
in exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
solutions and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different uh
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state or agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything um that you really when
you're actually writing the program your
environment is going to put out a reward
in state that goes into the agent
uh the agent then looks at this state or
it looks at the reward usually um first
and it says okay i got rewarded for
whatever i just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and it looks at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from
policy the policy comes in
and then we have a reward the policy is
that part that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey
what's a good action that will probably
be similar to what i did or
sometimes are completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today
and so a lot of them actually have
templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
you can see your environment
sends it says hey this is the agent did
this if you're a character in the game
this happened and it shoots out a reward
in a state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says i'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was
and then it has a new state and a new
reward that goes back to the agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node a and d
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node
a to b
is an action reward is the cost of each
path and policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go uh to b
or a can go to c right off the bat or
can go right to d and if explored all
three of these you would find that a
going to d was a zero reward
a going to c and d would generate a
different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here
and so when we start looking at this
diagram
you start to realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work uh or
a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems
and we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic-tac-toe game
but you can see here
once it's gone through these and it's
explored it's going to find the a c d
is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
reinforcement learning
demo uh in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you'll be playing this
game against the machine learning model
and we'll go ahead and we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools let's go through
anaconda which will open up a jupiter
notebook seems like a lot of steps but
it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupiter
notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a webpage and i've gone in here
and created a new
python folder in this case i've already
done it and enabled it to change the
name to tic-tac-toe and then for this
example we're going to go ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle
numpy of course is our number array and
then pickle is just a nice way sometimes
for
storing uh different information
different states that we're going to go
through on here
and so
we're going to create a class called
state we're going to start with that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class state
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it
we have our board
it's a tic tac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board we
have player one player two
uh is end we're going to create a board
hash
we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just going to store some
information in there symbol player
equals one
there's a few things going on as far as
the initialization
uh then something simple we're just
going to get the hash
of the board you get the information
from the board on there which is columns
and rows we want to know when a winner
occurs so if you get three in a row
that's what this whole section here is
for
let me go ahead and
scroll up a little bit
and you can get a copy of this code if
you send a note over to simply learn
we'll send you over
this particular file and you can play
with it yourself and see how it's put
together
i don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this because this is just some
real general python coding
but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row same thing
with columns
uh diagonal so you gotta check the
diagonal that's what all this stuff does
here so it just goes through the
different areas actually let me go ahead
and put
there we go
um and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
minus three just says did somebody win
or is it a tie
so you gotta add up all the numbers on
there anyway just in case they're all
filled up
and next we also need to know available
positions um these are ones that don't
no one's ever used before this way when
you try something or the computer tries
something uh it's not going to give it
an illegal move that's what the
available positions is doing
then we want to update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there
you we push
pick the row and column in there
and again
i mean this is a lot of code
so really it's kind of a thing you'd
want to go through and play with a
little bit and just read through it get
a copy of it a great way to understand
how this works
and here is a given reward
so we're going to give a reward result
equal self winner
this is one of the hearts of what's
going on here
is we have a result itself.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one here's
our feedback
if it doesn't equal one then it gets a
zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case
if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a
three by three board
imagine if you're playing a video game
certainly you only have so many actions
but your environment is huge you have a
lot going on in the environment and
suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
it's going to have to change a little
bit it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup and there's
all kinds of advanced ways to do that as
far as weighing you add weights to it
and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward in this
case you get the reward at the end of
the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this this is an important thing
to note but there's different ways to
add up those rewards it might have like
if you take a certain path
the first reward
is going to be weighed a little bit less
than the last reward because the last
reward is actually winning the game or
scoring or whatever it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated in some of the more advanced
setups
in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you
feed the rewards back in
then we have a board reset that's pretty
straightforward it just goes back and
resets the board to the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to do it by trial and error
so you have to keep resetting it and
then of course there's the play we want
to go ahead and play rounds equals 100
depends on what you want to do on here
you can set this
different you can obviously set that to
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here
that we have player one and player two
this is this is the computer playing
itself uh one of the more powerful ways
to learn to play a game
or even learn something that isn't a
game is to have two of these models that
are basically trying to beat each other
and so they always they keep finding
explore new things this one works for
this one so this one tries new things it
beats this we've seen this in
chess i think with some big one where
they had the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning uh it was one of
the ways they trained one of the top
computer chess playing algorithms
so this is just what this is it's going
to choose an action it's going to try
something and the more i try stuff
the more we're going to record the hash
we actually have a board hash where they
self get the hash
set up on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win
one of them wins it gets the reward
then we go back and reset and try again
and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is we're going to
play with a human so we'll get a chance
to come in here and see what that looks
like
when you put your own information in
and then it just comes in here and does
the same thing it did above it gives it
a reward for its things
or sees if it wins or ties
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board
so it's going to print the board out
each time
really
as an integration is not that exciting
what's exciting
in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up the
reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different
setup
and the other one is when it's playing
it's got to take an action
and so
what it chooses for an action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is
in
today's technology is figuring this out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
and we want to go ahead and create our
agent in this case our player so each
one is let me go and grab that
until we look at a class player um
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state
that it can look at and reward
so we want to take a look at this we
have name
self-state this is class player and when
you say class player we're not talking
about a human player we're talking about
just
the computer players
and this is kind of interesting so
remember i told you depending on what
you're doing there's going to be a decay
gamma
explore rate
these are what i'm talking about is how
do we train it
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one let's see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it
the 10 is going to count more than the
first step
uh and here's our we're going to
get the board information coming in and
then choose an action this was the
second part that i was talking about
that was so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np random
uniform so it's picking out a random
number
take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
and so choosing the action
this one you can see we're just doing
random states
choice length of positions action
position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board uh for p in positions
it's actually storing the different
boards each time you go through
so it has a record of what it did so it
can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash date
what's the last date append it to the
to our states on here
here's our feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none
what is the reward and here is that
formula remember i was telling you about
up here
that was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward
this is where as it goes through each
step
this and this is really important this
is this is kind of the heart of this of
what i was talking about earlier uh you
have step one
and this might have a reward of two you
have step two i should probably should
have done abc this has a step three
uh step four
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of ten
so reward a 10
we're going to add that but we're not
adding
let's say this one right here
let's say this reward here right before
10 was
let's say it's also 10 it just makes the
math easy
so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10 in whatever
it is but it's time it's 0.9
so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do 9 that's a
0.9
times
10.
and so this formula
as far as the decay times the reward
minus the cell state value
uh it basically adds in it says here's
one or here's two i'm sorry i should
have done this abc would have been
easier
so the first move goes in here and it
puts two in here
then we have our self
set up on here you can see how this gets
pretty complicated in the math but this
is really the key is how do we train
our states and we want the the final
state the win to get the most points if
you win you get most points
and the first step gets the least amount
of points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now i was need
to sum up my rewards and i want to sum
them up going in reverse and i want to
find the answer in reverse kind of an
interesting
play on the mind when you're trying to
figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here uh save the
policy
load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on let's go
ahead and load that up
and then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that
you choose an action row and column
here's your action
uh if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
uh you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward
again this is because it's a human
at the end of the game bat propagate and
update state values
this part isn't being done because
it's not programming uh
the model the model is getting its own
rewards
so we've gone ahead and loaded this in
here
so here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1
p2 player 2
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has p1 p2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50 000 rounds
now we can probably do a lot less than
this and it's not going to get the full
results in fact you know what uh let's
go ahead and just do five
just to play with it because i want to
show you something here
oops
somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go
i must have forgot to run this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
uh so now i've only set this up
with
let's see where we go in here i've only
set this up to train
five times
and the reason i did that is we're going
to
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're going to come in here and
we're going to do player 1 is going to
be the computer experience rate 0 load
policy 1 human player human and we're
going to go ahead and play this i
remember i only went through it
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an x
there and i'm going to go ahead and do
row zero column one
you can see this is very uh basic on
here
and
so i put in my zero and then i'm going
to go zero block it zero zero
and you can see right here it let me win
uh just like that i was able to win 0
and
human wins
so i only trained it five times we're
going to run this again
and this time
instead of five let's do five thousand
or fifty thousand i think that's what
the guys in the back had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it
on this
i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker
you could build a quick cue table with
almost all the different options on
there
and
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker
we're just using this as an example
so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning
setup and you actually try actions on
the learning setup until you get what
you think is going to be the best action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes i mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a
minute or two to go ahead and run
now to train it
we went ahead and let it run and it took
a while this this took
i got a pretty powerful processor and it
took
about five minutes plus to run it
and we'll go ahead and
run our player setup on here oops
brought in the last
whoops i brought in the last round so
give me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner i'm going to go
ahead and go 1-1 which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you ever played tic-tac-toe you know the
computer has me but we'll go ahead and
play it out
row zero
column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm going to go ahead and go row zero
one
two
no zero one there we go and column zero
that's where i want it
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom uh so you can see here
we've got a didn't catch the win on this
it said tie um kind of funny that didn't
catch the win on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this
lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two in fact i would even go as far as
to say it is the most important
machine learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language
if you're translating a language or
something from one language to the other
so much of it is lost if you don't know
the context it's in what the
environments it's in and so being able
to attach environment and context and
all those things together is going to
require reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with run it you can test it out
you can do
you know test it for different uh values
you can switch from p1 computer
where we loaded the policy one to load
the policy two and just see how it
varies there's all kinds of things you
can do on there so what is q learning q
learning is reinforcement learning
policy which will fill the next best
action given a current state it chooses
this action at random and aims to
maximize the reward
and so you can see here's our standard
reinforcement learning graph
by now if you're doing any reinforcement
learning
you should
be familiar with this where you have
your agent your agent takes an action
the action affects the environment
and then the environment sends back the
reward or the feedback and the state
it's the new state the agent's in where
is it at on the chessboard where is it
at in the video game
if your robots out there picking trash
up off the side of the road where is it
at on the road
consider an ad recommendation system
usually when you look up a product
online
you get ads which will suggest the same
product over and over again
using q learning
we can make an ad recommendation system
which will suggest related products to
our previous purchase
the reward will be if user clicks on the
suggested product
and again you can see
you might have a lot of products on your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
hundred people clicking on ads
and you click on one of the ads it might
go in there and say okay this person
clicked on this ad
what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing
so let's go ahead and look at some
important terms we talk about q learning
we have states the state s represents
the current position of an agent in an
environment
the action the action a is the step
taken by the agent when it is particular
state
rewards for every action the agent will
get a positive or negative reward
and again
when we talk about states we're usually
not with when you're using a q table
you're not usually talking about float
variables you're talking about true
false
and we'll take a closer look at that in
a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating state and can't take a new
action
uh this might be if you're playing a
video game your character stepped in and
is now dead or whatever
q values used to determine how good an
action a taken at a particular state s
is q a of s
and temporal difference a formula used
to find the q value by using the value
of the current state and action and
previous state in action
and various i mean there's bellman's
equation which basically is the equation
that
kind of covers what we just looked at in
all those different terms the bellman
equation is used to determine the values
of a particular state and deduce how
good it is to be in take that state the
optimal st the optimal state will give
us the highest optimal value
factor influencing q values the current
state and action that's your sa so your
current state and your action
uh then you have your previous date in
action which is your s
i guess prime i'm not sure how they
reference that s prime a prime so this
is what happened before
then you have a reward for action so you
have your r reward
and you have your maximum expected
future reward
and you can see there's also a learning
rate put in there and a discount rate
so we're looking at these just like any
other model we don't want to have an
absolute
final value on here we don't want it to
if you do absolute values instead of
taking smaller steps you don't really
have that approach to
the solution you just have a jump
and then pretty soon if you jump one
solution out that's what's going to be
the new solution whichever one jumps up
really high first
kind of ruining the whole idea of doing
a random selection i'll go into the
random selection just a second steps in
q learning
step one create an initial q table with
all values initialized to zero
again we're looking at
zero one
so are you you know here's our action we
start we're an idle we took a wrong
action we took a correct action and int
and then we have our actions fetching
sitting and running
of course we're just using the dog
example and choose an action and perform
it update values in the table and of
course when we're choosing an action
we're going to kind of do something
random and just randomly pick one so you
start out and you sit and you have then
then depending on that
action you took you can now update the
value for sitting after you start from
start to sitting get the value of the
reward and calculate the value the value
q value using the bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to sitting
and we attach all those rewards we
continue the same until the table is
filled with or an episode ends
and you and my membership is going to
come back to the random side of this and
there's a few different formulas i use
for the random
setup to pick it i usually look whatever
q model i'm using do their standard one
because someone's usually gone in and
done the math
for the optimal
spread
but you can look at this if i have
running has a reward of 10 sitting as a
reward is seven fetching has a reward of
five um just kind of without doing like
a a means to you know using the bell
curve for the means value and like i
said there's some math you can put in
there to pick so that you're more like
so that running has even a higher chance
but even if you were just going to do an
average on this
you could do an average a random number
by adding them all together
so you get 10 plus 7 plus 5 is
22 you could do 0 to 22
or 0 to 21 but 1 to 22
one to five would be fetching uh and so
forth you know the last 10.
so you can just look at this as what
percentage are you going to go for that
particular option
and then that gets your random setup in
there and then as you slowly increment
these up
uh you see that uh
if you're idle
where's one here we go sitting at the
end
if you're at the end of wherever you're
at sitting gets a reward of one
where's a good one on here oh wrong
action running for a wrong action gets
almost no reward
so that becomes very very less likely to
happen but it still might happen it
still might have a percentage of coming
up
and that's where the random programming
and q learning comes in the below table
gives us an idea of how many times an
action has been taken and how positively
correct action or negatively wrong
action it is going to affect the next
state
so let's go ahead and dive in and pull
up a little piece of code and see what
this looks like
in python
in this demo we'll use q learning to
find the shortest path between two given
points
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
if you've seen my videos before
i like to do it in the
anaconda jupiter notebook
setup just because it's really easy to
see and it's a nice demo uh and so
here's my anaconda this one i'm actually
using a python36 environment that i set
up in here
and we'll go ahead and launch the
jupiter notebook on this
and once we're in our jupiter notebook
uh which has the kernel loaded with
python3 we'll go ahead and create a new
python3
folder in here
and we'll call this uh q
learning
and to start this demo
let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported
and like a lot of these uh model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the end
uh and we'll we'll take a look at that
as we come into it so we go ahead and
start with our location to state
so we have
l1 l2 these are our nine locations one
to nine
and then of course the state is going to
be zero one two three four it's just a
mapping of our location to a integer on
there and then we have our actions our
actions are simply uh moving from
um one location
to another so i can go to i can go to
location zero i can go to location one
two three four five six seven eight uh
so these are my actions i can choose
these are the locations of our state
and if you remember earlier i mentioned
that the limitation is that you you
don't want to put in
a continually growing table because you
can actually create a dynamic cue table
where you continually add in new values
as they arise
because
if you have float values this just
becomes infinite and then you're
remembering your computer's gone or you
know does it's not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the q uh
learning setup
but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems
and so you might look at
uh well i do
i've been doing some work in stock
and one of the questions that comes out
is to buy or sell the stock
and the state coming in
might be
you might take a concrete way called
buckets
where anything that you predict is going
to return more than a certain amount of
money
the error for that stock that you've had
in the past you put those in buckets and
suddenly you start putting creating
these buckets you realize you do have a
limited amount of information coming in
you no longer have a float number you
now have bucket one two three and four
and then you can take those buckets
put them through a q learning table
and come up with the best action which
stock should i buy it's like gambling
stock is pretty much gambling if you're
doing day trading you're not doing long
term
investments and so you can start looking
at it like that a lot of the
current fees say that the best
algorithms used for day traders redoing
it on your own
is really to ask the question do i want
to trade the stock yes or no and now you
have it in a q learning table and now
you can take it to that next level and
you can see where that can be a really
powerful tool at the end of doing a
basic linear regression model or
something
what is the best investment and you
start getting the best reward on there
and the so if we're going to have
rewards these rewards we just create
it says if basically if you're
this should match our q table because
it's going to be
you have your state and you have your
action across the top if you remember
from the dog
and so we have whatever state we're in
going down and then the next action and
what the reward is for it
and of course if you were actually doing
a
something more connected your reward
would be based on
the actual environment it's in
and then we want to go ahead and create
a state to location
so we can map the indexes
so just like we defined our rewards uh
we're going to go and do state to
location
and you can see here it's a dictionary
set up for location state and location
to state with items
and
we also need to
define what we want for learning rates
uh you remember
we had our two different rates
as far as like learning from the past
and learning from the current so we'll
go ahead and set those to 0.75 and the
alpha set to 0.9 and we'll see that when
we do the formula
and of course any of this code send a
note to our simply learn team they'll
get you a copy of this code
on here let's go ahead and pull
there we go
on the next two sections
since we're going to keep it short and
sweet
here we go so let's go ahead and create
our agent um so our agent
is going to have our initialization
where we send it all the information uh
we'll define ourself gamma equals gamma
we could have just set the gamma rate
down here instead of submitting it
it's kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
on our self alpha
then we have our location state we'll
set that in here
we have our choice of actions
we're going to go ahead and just embed
the rewards right into the agent
so obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else
instead of from
self-generated and then a self state to
location equals our state to location
dictionary
and we go ahead and create a q learning
table and i went ahead and just set the
q learning table up to
zero to zero what what what the setup is
location to state how many of them are
there
and this just creates an array of zero
to zero set up on there
and then the big part is the training we
have our rewards new equals a copy of
self.rewards
ending state
equals the self-location state in
location so this is whatever we end up
at rewards new equals ending state plus
ending state equals 999. just kind of
goes
to a dead end
and
we start going through iterations
and we'll go ahead um let's do this
uh so this we're going to come back and
we're going to call call it on here let
me just erase that
switch it to an arrow
there we go
so what we're doing is we're going to
send in here to train it we're going to
say hey
i want to iterate through this a
thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be
instead of iterating you might have your
external environment and they're going
back and forth and you iterate through
outside of here
but just for ease of use our agent is
going to come in here and iterate
through this
sometimes i'll put this iteration in
here
and i'll have it call the environment
and say hey this is what i did what's
the next state and the environment does
its thing right in here as i iterate
through it
and then we want to go ahead and pick a
random state to start with
that's what's going on here you have to
start somewhere
and then you have your playable actions
we're going to start with just an empty
thing for playable actions and we'll
fill that up
so that's what choices i have
and so we're going to iterate through
the rewards matrix to get the states
directly reachable from the randomly
chosen current state assign those states
to a list named playable actions
and so you can see here we have a range
nine i usually use length of whatever
i'm looking at which is our locations
or states as they are
we have a reward so we want to look at
the current the rewards uh the new
reward
is our
is in our chart here of rewards
underscore new uh current state
plus j
j being what is the next date we want to
try
and so we go ahead and do our playable
actions and we append j
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better
reward and then of course we go ahead
and choose our next state
so we have our random choice playable
actions
and if you remember
i mentioned on this let me just go ahead
and let's do a free form
when we were talking about the next
state
this right here just does a random
selection
instead of a random
you might do something where
whatever the best selection is
which might be option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops
and we start looking at these averages
and these spreads
or we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those
so those are some of the options we have
in here we just go with a random choice
that's usually where you start play with
it
and then we have our
reward section down here
and so we want to go ahead and find well
in this case the temporal difference
uh so you have your rewards new
plus the self gamma and this is the
formula we were looking at
this is bellman's equation here
so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that
and we can add it all together
this is of course our
maximum expected future setup in here
so this is all of our our bellman's
equation that we're looking at here
and then we come up in here and we
update our q table that's all this is on
this one
and that's right here we have
self-cue current state next date and we
add in our alpha because we don't want
to we don't want to train all of it at
once in case there's slight differences
coming in there we want to slowly
approach the answer
and then we have our route equals the
start location
and next location equals start location
so we're just incrementing we took a
step forward
and then finally
remember i was telling you how we're
going to do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just
generates a simple path
we're going to go ahead and and get the
optimal route we want to find the best
route in here
and so we've created a definition for
the optimal route down here
scroll down for that
and we get the optimal route we go ahead
and put the information in including the
queue table self
start location in location next location
route queue and it says while next
location is not equal to in location so
while we can still go
our start location equals self location
to state start location so we already
have our best value for the start
location
the next state looks at the q table and
says hey what's uh the next one with the
best value and then the next location we
go ahead and pull that in and we just
append it that's what's going on down
here
and then our start location equals the
next location and we just go through all
the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this
and now that we have our q table our
q agent loaded
we're going to go ahead and take our q
agent
load them up with our alpha gamma that
we set up above
along with the location step action
reward state to location
and
uh our goal is to
plot a course between l9 and l1
and we're going to go through a hundred
a thousand iterations on here and so
when i run that it runs pretty quick
uh why is this so fast um
if you've been running neural networks
and you've been doing all these other
models you sit here and wait a long time
well we're very small amount of data
these are all integers these aren't
float values there's not a the math is
not heavy on the on the processing end
and this is where q tables are so
powerful
if you have a small amount of
information coming in
you very quickly uh get an answer off of
this even though we went through it a
thousand times to train it and you'll
see here we have l nine eight five two
and one and that's based on our reward
table we had set up on there and this is
the shortest path going between these
different uh setups in here
and if you remember on our reward table
you can see that if you start here you
can go to here there's places you can't
go that's how this reward table was set
up so i can only go to certain places
so kind of a little maze set up in there
and you can play with it this is really
fun
setup to play with
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like i was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup and model predictions where you
put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action
long as you can take that course into
action and
reduce it down to a yes no
or if you're using text
you can use a one hot encoder which word
is next there's all kinds of things you
can do with a cue table
depending on just how much information
you're putting in there
so that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point a to point b and what
available actions there are hello and
welcome to this tutorial on deep
learning my name is mohan and in the
next about one one and a half hours i
will take you through what is deep
learning and
into tensorflow environment to show you
an example of deep learning now there
are several applications of deep
learning really very interesting and
innovative applications and one of them
is identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
claimed it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from paris
because it is able to recognize the
eiffel tower so the way it works
internally if we have to look a little
bit under the heart as these images are
nothing but this is digital information
in the form of pixels so each image
could be a certain size it can be 256 by
256 pixel kind of a resolution and then
each pixel is either having a certain
grade of color and all that is fed into
the neural network and it then gets
trained in and it's able to based on
these pixels pixel information it is
able to get trained and able to
recognize the features and extract the
features and thereby it is able to
identify these images and the location
of these images and then when you feed a
new image it kind of based on the
training it will be able to figure out
where this image is from so that's the
way a little bit under the hood how it
works so what are we going to do in this
tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural networks so
we will see what is neural network what
is a perceptron and how to implement
logic gates like and or nor and so on
using perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural networks
works so how do we do the training of
and at the end we will end up with a
small demo code
which will take you through in
tensorflow now in order to implement
deep learning code there are multiple
libraries or development environments
that are available and tensorflow is one
of them so the focus at the end of this
would be on how to use tensorflow to
write a piece of code using python as a
programming language and we will take up
an example which is a very common one
which is like the hello world of deep
learning the handwriting number
recognition which is a mnist commonly
known as mnist database so we will take
a look at mnist database and how we can
train a neural network to recognize
handwritten numbers so that's what you
will see
in this particular
video so let's get started what is deep
learning deep learning is like a subset
of what is known as a high level concept
called artificial intelligence you must
be already familiar must have heard
about this term artificial intelligence
so artificial intelligence is like the
high level concept if you will and in
order to implement artificial
intelligence
applications we use what is known as
machine learning and within machine
learning a subset of machine learning is
deep learning machine learning is a
little bit more generic concept and deep
learning is one type of machine learning
if you will and we will see a little
later in maybe the following slides a
little bit more in detail how deep
learning is different from traditional
machine learning but to start with we
can mention here that deep learning uses
one of the differentiators between deep
learning and traditional machine
learning is that deep learning uses
neural networks and we will talk about
what are neural networks and how we can
implement neural networks and so on and
so forth as a part of this tutorial so a
little deeper into deep learning deep
learning primarily involves working with
complicated unstructured data compared
to traditional machine learning with
where we normally use
structured data in deep learning the
data would be primarily images or voice
or maybe text files so
and it is large amount of data as well
and deep learning can handle complex
operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature
extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as i mentioned one of
the secret
sources of deep learning is neural
networks let's see what neural networks
is neural networks is based on our
biological
neurons the whole concept of deep
learning and artificial intelligence is
based on human brain and human brain
consists of billions of tiny stuff
called neurons and this is how a
biological
neuron looks and this is how an
artificial neuron looks so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has billions of
biological neurons and we are trying to
simulate the human brain using
artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what exactly
weights in biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic
units is a perceptron so what is a
perceptron a perceptron can be
considered as one of the fundamental
units of neural networks it can consist
at least one neuron but sometimes it can
be more than one neuron but you can
create a perceptron with a single neuron
and it can be used to perform certain
functions it can be used as a basic
binary classifier it can be trained to
do some basic binary classification and
this is how a basic perceptron looks
like and this is nothing but a neuron
you have inputs x 1 x 2 x 2 x n and
there is a summation function and then
there is what is known as an activation
function and based on this input what is
known as the weighted sum the activation
function either gets gives an output
like a zero or a one so we say the
neuron is either activated or not so
that's the way it works so you get the
inputs these inputs are each of the
inputs are multiplied by a weight and
there is a bias that gets added and that
whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjusts the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works is
somewhat like this so you have all these
inputs like x1 to xn and each of these
inputs is multiplied by a weight and
then that sum this is the formula of the
equation so that sum w i x i
sigma of that which is a sum of all
these product of x and w is added up and
then a bias is added to that the bias is
not dependent on the input but or the
input values but the bias is common for
one neuron however the bias value keeps
changing during the training process
once the training is completed the
values of these weights w1 w2 and so on
and the value of the bias gets fixed so
that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this w i x i
summation plus b
is passed through activation function
and then the neuron gets either fired or
not and based on that there will be an
output that output is compared with the
actual or expected value which is also
known as labeled information so this is
the process of supervised learning so
the output is already known and
that is compared and thereby we know if
there is an error or not and if there is
an error the error is fed back and the
weights and biases are updated
accordingly till the error is reduced to
the minimum so this iterative process
is
known as perceptron learning or
perceptron learning rule and this error
needs to be minimized so till the error
is minimized this iteratively the
weights and biases keep changing and
that is what is the training process so
the whole idea is to update the weights
and the bias of the perceptron till the
error is minimized the error need not be
zero the error may not ever reach zero
but the idea is to keep changing these
weights and bias so that the error is
minimum the minimum possible that it can
have so this whole process is an
iterative process and this is the
iteration continues till either the
error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
within these given conditions now in
1943 two scientists warren mcculloch and
walter pitts came up with an experiment
where they were able to implement the
logical functions like and or and nor
using neurons and that was a significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical gates which could take two
inputs like a and b
and then
give a corresponding result so for
example in case of an and gate a
and b and then the output is a b in case
of an or gate it is a plus b and so on
and so forth and they were able to do
this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these gates
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for xor and we will
see why that is in a little bit so this
is how an and gate works the inputs a
and b the output should be fired or the
neuron should be fired only when both
the inputs are one so if you have zero
zero the output should be zero for 0 1
it is again 0 1 0 again 0 and 1 1 the
output should be
1. so how do we implement this with a
neuron so it was found that by changing
the values of weights it is possible to
achieve this
logic so for example if we have equal
weights like 0.7 0.7 and then if we take
the sum of the weighted products so for
example 0.7 into 0 and then 0.7 into 0
will give you 0 and so on and so forth
and in the last case when both the
inputs are 1 you get a value which is
greater than 1 which is the threshold so
only in this case the neuron gets
activated and the output is there is an
output in all the other cases there is
no output because the threshold value is
one so this is implementation of an and
gate using a single perceptron or a
single neuron similarly an or gate in
order to implement an or gate in case of
an or gate the output will be one if
either of these inputs is one so for
example zero one will result in one or
other in all the cases it is one except
for zero zero so how do we implement
this using a perceptron once again if
you have a perceptron with weights for
example 1.2 now if you see here if in
the first case when both are 0 the
output is 0 in the second case when it
is 0 and 1 1.2 into 0 is 0 and then 1.2
into 1 is 1. and in the second case
similarly the output is 1.2 in this last
case when both the inputs are 1 the
output is 2.4 so during the cleaning
process these weights will keep changing
and then at one point where the weights
are equal to w1 is equal to 1.2 and w2
is equal to 1.2 the system learns that
it gives the correct output so that is
implementation of or gate using a single
neuron or a single layer perceptron now
xor gate this was one of the challenging
ones they tried to implement an xor gate
with a single level perceptron but it
was not possible and therefore in order
to implement an xr so this was like a
roadblock in the progress of
neural network however subsequently they
realized that this can be implemented an
xor gate can be implemented using
a multi-level perceptron or mlp so in
this case there are two layers instead
of a single layer and this is how you
can implement an xor gate so you will
see that x1 and x2 are the inputs and
there is a hidden layer and that's why
it is denoted as h3nh4 and then you take
the output of that and feed it to the
output at o5 and provide a threshold
here so we will see here that this is
the numerical calculation so the weights
are in this case for x1 it is 20 and
minus 20 and once again 20 and minus 20.
so these inputs are fed into h3 and h4
so you'll see here for h3 the
input is 0 1 1 1 and for h4 it is 1 0 1
1 and if you now look at the output
final output where the threshold is
taken as 1 if we use a sigmoid with the
threshold one you will see that in these
two cases it is zero and in the last two
cases it is one so this is a
implementation of xor in case of x or
only when one of the inputs is one you
will get an output so that is what we
are seeing here if we have either both
the inputs are one or both the inputs
are zero then the output should be zero
so that is what is an exclusive or gate
so it is exclusive because only one of
the inputs should be one and then only
you will get an output of one which is
satisfied by this condition so this is a
special implementation xor gate is a
special implementation of perceptron now
that we got a good idea about perceptron
let's take a look at what is the neural
network so we have seen what is a
perceptron we have seen what is a neuron
so we will see what exactly is a neural
network so neural network is nothing but
a network of these neurons and they are
different types of neural networks there
are about five of them these are
artificial neural network convolutional
neural network then recursive neural
network or recurrent neural network deep
neural network and deep belief network
so and each of these types of neural
networks have a special you know they
can
solve special kind of problems for
example convolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas rnn are very good for speech
recognition and also text analysis and
so on so each type has some special
characteristics and they can they're
good at performing certain special kind
of tasks what are some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphago
which is a game created by a startup
called deepmind which got acquired by
google and alphago is an ai which
defeated the human world champion lee
sedol in this game of go so gaming is an
area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks a special type
called generative adversarial networks
which can be used for synthesizing
either images or music or text and so on
and they can be used to compose music so
the neural network can be trained to
compose a certain kind of music and
autonomous cars you must be familiar
with google google's self-driving car
and today a lot of automotive companies
are investing in this space and deep
learning is a core component of this
autonomous cars the cars are trained to
recognize for example the road the
lane markings on the road
signals any objects that are in front
any obstruction and so on and so forth
so all this involves deep learning so
that's another major application and
robots we have seen several robots
including sofia you may be familiar with
sophia who was given a citizenship by
saudi arabia and there are several such
robots which are very human like and the
underlying technology in many of these
robots is deep learning medical
diagnostics and health care is another
major area where deep learning is being
used and within healthcare diagnostics
again there are multiple areas where
deep learning and image recognition
image processing can be used for example
for cancer detection as you may be aware
if cancer is detected early on it can be
cured and one of the challenges is in
the availability of specialists who can
diagnose cancer using these diagnostic
images and various scans and and so on
and so forth so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the lord on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologists
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are claimed to be performing better than
human beings in this space can be
lung cancer it could be breast cancer
and so on and so forth so health care is
a major area where deep learning is
being applied let's take a look at the
inner working of a neural network so how
does an artificial neural network let's
say identify can we train a neural
network to identify the shapes like
squares and circles and triangles when
these images are fed so this is how it
works any image is nothing but it is a
digital information of the pixels so in
this particular case let's say this is
an image of 28 by 28 pixel and this is
an image of a square there's a certain
way in which the pixels are lit up and
so these pixels have a certain value
maybe from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that
it is
black or it is dark and 256 indicates it
is completely it is white or lit up so
that is like an indication or a measure
of the how the pixels are lit up and so
this is an image is let's say consisting
of information of
784 pixels so all the information what
is inside this image can be kind of
compressed into this 784 pixels the way
each of these pixels is lit up provides
information about what exactly is the
image so
we can train neural networks to use that
information and identify the images so
let's take a look how this works so each
neuron the value if it is close to 1
that means it is white whereas if it is
close to 0 that means it is black now
this is a an animation of how the
salting works so these pixels one of the
ways of doing it is we can flatten
this image and take this complete 784
pixels and feed that as input to our
neural network the neural network can
consist of probably several layers there
can be a few hidden layers and then
there is an input layer and an output
layer now the input layer takes the 784
pixels as input the values of each of
these pixels and then you get an output
which can be
of three types or three classes one can
be a square a circle or a triangle now
during the training process there will
be initially obviously you feed this
image and it will probably say it's a
circle or it will say it's a triangle so
as a part of the training process
we then
send that error back and the weights and
the biases of these neurons are adjusted
till it correctly identifies that this
is a square that is the whole training
mechanism that happens out here
now let's take a look at a circle same
way
so you feed these 784 pixels there is a
certain pattern in which the pixels are
lit up
and the neural network is trained to
identify that pattern
and during the training process once
again it would probably initially
identify it incorrectly saying this is a
square or a triangle and then that error
is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct
so that is the training process so now
we will take a look at
same way a triangle
so now if you feed another image which
is consisting of triangles so this is
the training process now we have trained
our neural network to classify these
images into
a triangle or a circle and a square so
now this neural network can
identify these three types of objects
now if you feed another image and it
will be able to identify whether it's a
square or a triangle or a circle now
what is important to be observed is that
when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that
the image or the the triangle is exactly
in this position now the neural network
actually
identifies the patterns so even if the
triangle is let's say positioned here
not exactly in the middle but maybe at
the corner or in the side it would still
identify that it is a triangle and that
is the whole idea behind
pattern recognition so how does this
training process work this is a quick
view of how the training process works
so we have seen that a neuron consists
of inputs it receives inputs and then
there is a weighted sum which is nothing
but this x i wi summation of that plus
the
bias and this is then fed to the
activation function and that in turn
gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights w1 w2 up to wn keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values it
could be 0.5 0.25 0.35 and so on it
could be positive or it could be
negative and the value that is coming
here is the pixel value as we have seen
it can be anything between 0 to 1 you
can scale it between 0 to 1 or 0 to 256
whichever way 0 being black and 256
being white and then all the other
colors in between so that is the input
so these are numerical values this
multiplication or the product w i x i is
a numerical value and the bias is also a
numerical value we need to keep in mind
that the bias is fixed for a neuron it
doesn't change with the inputs whereas
the weights are one per input so that is
one important point to be noted so but
the bias also keeps changing initially
it will again have a random value but as
a part of the training process the
weights the values of the weights w1 w2
wn and
the value of b
will change and ultimately once the
training process is complete these
values are fixed for this particular
neuron w1 w2 up to wn and plus the value
of the b is also fixed for this
particular neuron and in this way there
will be multiple neurons and each there
may be multiple levels of neurons here
and that's the way the training process
works so this is another example of
multi-layer so there are two hidden
layers in between and then you have the
input layer values coming from the input
layer then it goes through multiple
layers hidden layers and then there is
an output layer and as you can see there
are weights and biases for each of these
neurons in each layer and all of them
gets keeps changing during the training
process and at the end of the training
process all these weights have a certain
value and that is a trained model and
those values will be fixed once the
training is completed all right then
there is something known as activation
function neural networks consists of one
of the components in neural networks is
activation function and every neuron has
an activation function and there are
different types of activation functions
that are used it could be a relu it
could be sigmoid and so on and so forth
and the activation function is what
decides whether a neuron should be fired
or not so whether the output should be 0
or 1 is decided by the activation
function and the activation function in
turn takes the input which is the
weighted sum remember we talked about w
i x i plus b that weighted sum is fed as
an input to the activation function and
then the output can be either a zero or
a one and there are different types of
activation functions which are covered
in an earlier video you might want to
watch all right so as a part of the
training process
we feed the inputs the label data or the
training data and then it gives an
output which is the predicted output by
the network which we indicate as y hat
and then there is a labeled data because
we for supervised learning we already
know what should be the output so that
is the actual output and in the initial
process before the training is complete
obviously there will be error so that is
measured by what is known as a cost
function so the difference between the
predicted output and the actual output
is the error and
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so
and then
all the errors are added which can
sometimes be called as sum of squares
sum of square errors or sse and that is
then fed as a feedback in what is known
as backward propagation or back
propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function
is
minimum now there is a optimization
technique which is used here called
gradient descent optimization and this
algorithm
works in a way that the error which is
the cost function
needs to be minimized so there's a lot
of mathematics that goes behind this for
example they find the local minima the
global minima using the differentiation
and so on and so forth but the idea is
this so as a training process as the as
a part of training the whole idea is to
bring down the error which is like let's
say this is the function
the cost function
at certain levels it is very high the
cost value of the cost function the
output of the cost function is very high
so
the weights have to be adjusted in such
a way and also the bias of course that
the cost function is minimized so there
is this optimization technique called
gradient descent that is used and this
is known as the learning rate now
gradient descent
you need to specify what should be the
learning rate and the learning rate
should be optimal because if you have a
very high learning rate then the
optimization will not converge because
at some point it will cross over to the
side on the other hand if you have very
low learning rate then it might take
forever to convert so you need to come
up with the optimum value of the
learning rate and once that is done
using the gradient descent optimization
the error function
is reduced and that's like the end of
the training process all right so this
is another view of gradient descent so
this is how it looks this is your cost
function the output of the cost function
and that has to be minimized using
gradient descent algorithm and these are
like the parameters and weight could be
one of them so initially we start with
certain random values so cost will be
high and then the weights keep changing
and in such a way that the cost function
needs to come down and at some point it
may reach the minimum value and then it
may increase so that is where the
gradient descent algorithm decides that
okay it has reached a minimum value and
it will kind of try to stay here this is
known as the global minima now sometimes
these curves may not be just for
explanation purpose this has been drawn
in a nice way but sometimes these curves
can be pretty erratic there can be some
local minima here and then there is a
peak and then and so on so the whole
idea of gradient descent optimization is
to identify the global minima and to
find the weights and the bias at that
particular point so that's what is
gradient descent and then this is
another example so you can have these
multiple local minima so as you can see
at this point when it is coming down it
may appear like this is a minimum value
but then it is not this is actually the
global minimum value and the gradient is
an algorithm will make an effort to
reach this level and not get stuck at
this point so the algorithm is already
there and it knows how to identify this
global minimum and that's what it does
during the training process now in order
to implement deep learning there are
multiple platforms and languages that
are available but the most common
platform nowadays is tensorflow and so
that's the reason we have uh this
tutorial we've created this tutorial for
tensorflow so we will take you through a
quick demo of how to write a tensorflow
code using python and tensorflow is
an open source platform created by
google so let's just take a look at the
details of tensorflow and so this is a a
library a python library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like java
and r and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so
it is a library for developing
deep learning applications especially
using neural networks and it consists of
primarily two parts if you will so one
is the tensors and then the other is the
graphs or the flow that's the way the
name that's the reason for this kind of
a name called tensorflow so what are
tensor sensors are like
multi-dimensional
arrays if you will that's one way of
looking at it so
usually you have a one dimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a one dimensional
array something like this which means
this like a set of numbers so that is a
one dimension array then you can have a
two dimensional array which is like a
matrix
and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three dimensional
array but tensorflow can handle many
more dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional
arrays that is the strength of
tensorflow and which makes computation
deep learning computation much faster
and that's the reason why tensorflow is
used for developing deep learning
applications so tensorflow is a deep
learning tool and this is the way it
works so the data basically flows in the
form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually
execute that particular graph in the
form of what is known as a session we
will see this in the tensorflow code as
we move forward so all the data is
managed or manipulated in tensors and
then the processing happens using these
graphs there are certain terms called
like for example ranks of a tensor the
rank of a tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just a one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one dimensional
vector in which case the rank is
supposed to be one and then you can have
a two-dimensional vector typically like
a matrix then in that case we say the
rank is two and then if it is a
three-dimensional array then rank is
three and so on so it can have more than
three as well so it is possible that you
can store multi-dimensional arrays in
the form of tensors so what are some of
the properties of tensorflow i think
today it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning platform or library
it is open source
it's developed by google developed and
maintained by google but it is open
source one of the most important things
about tensorflow is that it can run
on cpus as well as gpus
gpu is a graphical processing unit just
like cpu central processing unit now in
earlier days gpu was used for primarily
for
graphics and that's how the name has
come and one of the reasons is that it
cannot perform generic activities very
efficiently like cpu
but it can perform
iterative actions or computations
extremely fast and much faster than a
cpu so they are really good for
computational activities and in deep
learning there is a lot of iterative
computation that happens so in the form
of matrix multiplication and so on so
gpus are very well suited for this kind
of computation and tensorflow supports
both gpu as well as cpu and there's a
certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is
just a suggestion but if you are already
familiar with how tensorflow works then
probably yeah you can go straight into
the neural networks part so in this
tutorial we will take the use case of
recognizing handwritten digits this is
like a hello world
of deep learning and this is a nice
little mnist database is a nice little
database that has images of handwritten
digits nicely formatted because very
often in deep learning and neural
networks we end up spending a lot of
time in preparing the data for training
and with mnist database we can avoid
that you already have the data in the
right format which can be directly used
for training and mnist also offers a
bunch of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them
are for training then you have test just
like in any machine learning process and
then you have validation and all of them
are labeled so you have the images and
their label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are hand
written images collected from a lot of
individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have handwritten these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mnis
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and
the data is basically these images are
stored in the form of the pixel
information as we have seen in one of
the previous slides all the images are
nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler
neural network configurations called
softmax and for simplicity what we will
do is
we will flatten
these pixels so instead of taking them
in a two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are
pixels so pixel number one starts here
it goes all the way up to 28 then 29
starts here and goes up to 56 and so on
and the pixel number 784 is here so we
take all these pixels flatten them out
and feed them like one single line into
our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a softmax layer what it does is
once it is trained it will be able to
identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is trained
properly and
if you feed
a number 9 like this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine let's
say this has been trained and now if
you're feeding a number nine this will
get
activated now let's say you fade one to
the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed two this neuron
will get activated and so on i hope you
get the idea so this is one type of a
neural network or an activation function
known as soft max layer so that's what
we will be using here this is one of the
simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so
this is how the code would look we will
go into our lab environment in the cloud
and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks
and let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupiter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and
once you do this tf is tensorflow is
available as an object in the name of tf
and then you can run its methods and
accesses its attributes and so on and so
forth and mnist database is actually an
integral part of tensorflow and that's
again another reason why we as a first
step we always use this example mnist
database example so you just simply
import mnist database as well using this
line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just
use a pen to show what exactly it is so
when you do this one hot true what
happens is each label is stored in the
form of an array of
10 digits and let's say the number is
8 okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position 0 this is
at position 1 position 2 and so on and
so forth let's say this is position 7
then this is position 8 that will be 1
because our input is 8 and again
position 9 will be 0. okay so one hot
encoding this one hot encoding true will
kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of 1 and that
indicates so based on which
digit is one we know what is the label
so in this case the eighth position is
one therefore we know this sample data
the value is eight similarly if you have
a two here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as zero the zeroth position the first
position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can
check how the data is looking by
displaying the the data and as i
mentioned earlier this is pretty much in
the form of digital form like numbers so
all these are like pixel values so you
will not really see an image in this
format but there is a way to
visualize that image i will show you in
a bit and
this tells you how many images are there
in each set so the training there are 55
000 images in training and in the test
set there are 10 000 and then validation
there are 5000 so all together there are
70 000
images all right so let's
move on and we can
view the actual
image by uh using the matplotlib library
and this is how you can view this is the
code for viewing the images and you can
view them in color or you can view them
in grayscale so the c map is what tells
in what way we want to view it and what
are the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is 1 because
this is a scaled value so 1 means it is
white and 0 means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a
matrix
of
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784 matrix because there
are 10 neurons
and similarly there are biases now
remember i mentioned
bias is only one per neuron so it is not
one per input unlike the weights so
therefore there are only 10 biases
because there are only 10 neurons in
this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensorflow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication tf you
remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x with w
right this is what we were doing x w
plus b you're just adding b and this is
in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf
dot nn soft max cross entropy with
logits is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides
earlier and for that you need to specify
the learning rate you remember we saw
that there was a slide somewhat like
this and then you define what should be
the learning rate how fast you need to
come down that is the learning rate and
this again needs to be tested and tried
and to find out the optimum level of
this learning rate it shouldn't be very
high in which case it will not converge
or shouldn't be very low because it will
in that case it will take very long so
you define the optimizer and then you
call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kickstart the training process
and so far we've been creating the graph
and in order to actually execute that
graph we create what is known as a
session and then we run that session and
once the training is completed we
specify how many times how many
iterations we want it to run so for
example in this case we are saying
thousand steps so that is a exit
strategy in a way so you specify the
exit condition so training will run for
thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
google cloud amazon or cloud labs any of
these you can
use and
run and try the code okay so it has got
started
we will login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial
code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and
so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through
in the slides as well now you will see
the actual code in action so the first
thing we need to do is import tensorflow
and then we will import the data and we
need to adjust the data in such a way
that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
training images there are
55 000 then there are test images 10 000
and then validation images 5 000. now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just uh
one image and just see what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is
blank so that's why you will mostly see
zeros either it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between 0 and 1 okay so
this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called
i am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately you will be
able to see the different images now i
can change the values in this position
so which image we are looking at right
so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
5 000
right so
5000 has 3
similarly you can just say 5 what is in
5 as 8
what is in 50
again 8 so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how i'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with jupiter notebooks shift
enter is how you
execute each cell individual cell and if
you want to execute the entire program
you can go here and say run all
so that is how
this code gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10 actual values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned
one for each neuron so there will be 10
biases they are stored in a variable by
the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value
so this is another placeholder we had x
as one placeholder and white underscore
true as a second placeholder and this
will have values in the form of uh 10
digit 10 digit arrays
and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so up to here remember what we
have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to
view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who
let's say have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating
the variables and feeding the variables
and
rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have created the variables
how to load the data loaded the data
viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution in
tensorflow so the first step for
doing any execution in tensorflow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a node for initializing
so this is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a width loop so you have a with
tf.session
as says and with a
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf dot session as says you say says dot
run init now says dot run will execute
a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf.session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are calling that
says and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w
is a variable and b is a variable so any
variables that we created you have to
run this code you have to run the
initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then
we within this with block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for
thousand steps and perform
the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of
performing deep learning training you
always do in batches so we have maybe 50
000 images but you always do it in
batches of 100 or maybe
500 depending on the size of your
system and so on and so forth so in this
case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next patch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of 100 images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously they
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get updated
till it reaches thousand iterations in
this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize
these handwritten images obviously it
will not be 100 accurate okay so once
that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then
test the accuracy of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand the various
methods of tensorflow and so on but it
is basically comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf.equal right and how
many of them are correct and so on and
so forth and based on that the accuracy
is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy and that is what we are trying
to see how accurate the model is in
predicting these numbers or these digits
okay so let us run this this entire
thing is in one cell so we will have to
just run it in one shot it may take a
little while let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
okay now which is pretty good for such a
short exercise within such a short time
we got 90 percent accuracy however in
real life this is probably not
sufficient so there are other ways in to
increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 percent hello and welcome to
the tensorflow object detection api
tutorial in this video i will walk you
through the tensorflow code to perform
object detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically you're
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image io datetime and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and a
few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again it could go away all right and
then here onwards we do the model
preparation now what we're going to do
is we're going to use an existing neural
network model so we are not going to
chain a new one because that really will
take a long time and it needs a lot of
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there are already
models that have been trained and in
this case it is the ssd with mobile net
that's the model that we are going to
use and this model is trained to detect
objects and it is readily available as
open source so we can actually use this
and if you want to use other models
there are a few more models available so
you can click on this
link here and
let me just take you there there are a
few more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
the you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
used for doing object detection in
images so this is where the actual
detection starts so here this is the
path for where the images are stored so
this is here once again we are reusing
the code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the images were stored and this is
the extension and this was done for
about two or three images so we will
continue to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
like car so let me just show you so this
is in this object detection folder i
have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and um you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video go back to my
file manager so this was the original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
percent let us allow it to go a little
further it detects something on top what
is that truck okay so i think because of
the board on top it somehow thinks there
is a truck let's play it some more and
see if it detects anything else so this
is again a car looks like so let us yeah
so this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and
our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and
even when the cat moves a little bit in
the other direction it will continue to
detect and show that it is a cat okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our network detects this cat close this
here we go and i'll go back to my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r glasses come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but
it is trying to detect something i think
it is saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and
let's wait for some time and see if it
continues to detect it when the cat
turns around and moves as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
okay so close this so that's pretty much
it thank you very much for watching this
video and you have a great day and in
case you have any questions please put
them below the video here and we will be
more than happy to get back to you and
make sure you put your email id so that
we can contact you in case you have any
questions thank you once again bye-bye
today we're going to be covering the
convolutional neural network tutorial
do you know how deep learning recognizes
the objects in an image and really this
particular neural network is how image
recognition works it's very central one
of the biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those is going
to light up and say oh it's a bird we're
going to go into depth we're going to
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image don't worry we're
going to get into the details so we have
our input layer accepts the pixels of
the image as input in the form of arrays
and you can see up here where they've
actually labeled each block of the bird
in different arrays so we'll dive into
deep as to how that looks like and how
those matrixes are set up your hidden
layer carry out feature extraction by
performing certain calculations and
manipulation so this is the part that
kind of reorganizes that picture
multiple ways until we get some data
that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution layer rel u is how that is
pronounced when that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used
pooling layer also uses multiple filters
to detect edges corners eyes feathers
beak etc and just like the term says
pooling is pulling information together
and we'll look into that a lot closer
here so if you're if it's a little
confusing now we'll dig in deep and try
to get you squared away with that and
then finally there is a fully connected
layer that identifies the object in the
image so we have these different layers
coming through in the hidden layers and
they come into the final area and that's
where we have a one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird what's in it for you we're
going to cover an introduction to the
cnn what is convolution neural network
how cnn recognizes images we're going to
dig deeper into that and really look at
the individual layers in the
convolutional neural network and finally
we do a use case implementation using
the cnn we'll begin our introduction to
the cnn by introducing the pioneer of
convolutional neural network jan le
he was the director of facebook ai
research group built the first
convolutional neural network called
lynnette in 1988 so these have been
around for a while and have had a chance
to mature over the years it was used for
character recognition tasks like reading
zip code digits imagine processing mail
and automating that process
cnn is a feed forward neural network
that is generally used to analyze visual
images by producing data with a
grid-like topology a cnn is also known
as a convent and very key to this is we
are looking at images that was what this
was designed for and you'll see the
different layers as we dig in near some
of the other some of them are actually
now used since we're using uh tensorflow
and cross in our code later on you'll
see that some of those layers appear in
a lot of your other neural network
frameworks but in this case this is very
central to processing images and doing
so in a variety that captures multiple
images and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers are two varieties orchid
and a rose i think the orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful of a couple rose
bushes in my yard uh they go into the
input layer that data is then sent to
all the different nodes in the next
layer one of the hidden layers based on
its different weights and its setup it
then comes out and gives those a new
value those values then are multiplied
by their weights and go to the next
hidden layer and so on and then you have
the output layer and one of those nodes
comes out and says it's an orchid and
the other one comes out and says it's a
rose depending on how it was well it was
trained what separates the cnn or the
convolutional neural network from other
neural networks is a convolutional
operation forms the basis of any
convolutional neural network in a cnn
every image image is represented in the
form of arrays of pixel values so here
we have a real image of the digit eight
that then gets put onto
its pixel values represented in the form
of an array in this case you have a two
dimensional array and then you can see
in the final in form we transform the
digit eight into its representational
form of pixels of zeros and one where
the ones represent in this case the
black part of the eight and the zeros
represent the white background to
understand the convolution neural
network or how that convolutional
operation works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes in this
case we're going to simplify it and
we're going to take two matrices a and b
of one dimension now kind of separate
this from your thinking as we learned
that you want to focus just on the
matrix aspect of this and then we'll
bring that back together and see what
that looks like when we put the pieces
for the convolutional operation here
we've set up two arrays we have uh in
this case are a single dimension matrix
and we have a equals five three seven
five nine seven and we have b equals one
two three so in the convolution as it
comes in there's gonna look at these two
and we're going to start by doing
multiplying them a times b and so we
multiply the arrays element wise and we
get 5 6 6
where 5 is the 5 times 1 6 is 3 times
two and then the other six is two times
three and since the two arrays aren't
the same size they're not the same setup
we're gonna just truncate the first one
and we're gonna look at the second array
multiplied just by the first three
elements of the first array now that's
going to be a little confusing remember
a computer gets to repeat these
processes hundreds of times so we're not
going to just forget those other numbers
later on we'll see we'll bring those
back in and then we have the sum of the
product in this case 5 plus 6 plus 6
equals 17. so in our a times b
our very first digit in that matrix of a
times b is 17. and if you remember i
said we're not going to forget the other
digits so we now have 3 2 5 we move one
set over and we take 3 2 5 and we
multiply that times b and you'll see
that 3 times 1 is 3 2 times 2 is 4 and
so on and so on we sum it up so now we
have the second digit of our a times b
product in the matrix and we continue on
with that same thing so on and so on so
then we would go from three seven five
to seven five nine to five nine seven
this short matrix that we have for a
we've now covered all the different
entities in a that match three different
levels of b now in a little bit we're
going to cover where we use this math at
this multiplying of matrixes and how
that works but it's important to
understand that we're going through the
matrix and multiplying the different
parts to it to match the smaller matrix
with the larger matrix i know a lot of
people get lost at is you know what's
going on here with these matrixes oh
scary math not really that scary when
you break it down we're looking at a
section of a and we're comparing it to b
so when you break that down your mind
like that you realize okay so i'm i'm
just taking these two matrixes and
comparing them and i'm bringing the
value down into one matrix a times b
we're reducing that information in a way
that will help the computer see
different aspects let's go ahead and
flip over again back to our images
here we are back to our images talking
about going to the most basic
two-dimensional image you can get to
consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the backslash the above image is
processed and you can see there for the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so we click the forward slash
button that flips uh very basic we have
four pixels going in can't get any more
basic than that here we have a little
bit more complicated picture we take a
real image of a smiley face
then we represent that in the form of
black and white pixels so if this was an
image in the computer it's black and
white and like we saw before we convert
this into the zeros and one so where the
other one would have just been a matrix
of just four dots now we have a
significantly larger image coming in so
don't worry we're going to bring this
all together here in just a little bit
layers in convolutional neural network
we're looking at this we have our
convolution layer and that really is the
central aspect of processing images in
the convolutional neural network that's
why we have it and then that's going to
be feeding in and you have your relu
layer which is you know as we talked
about the rectified linear unit we'll
talk about that a little bit later the
relu isn't how it act is how that layer
is activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that a
lot of other neural networks when you're
using it just by itself it's for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the relu layer works great you
have your pooling layer that's where
you're pulling the data together pooling
is a neural network term it's very
commonly used i like to use the term
reduce so if you're coming from the map
and reduce side you'll see that we're
mapping all this data through all these
networks and then we're going to reduce
it we're going to pull it together and
then finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output is going
to come out so we have started to look
at matrixes we've started to look at the
convolutional layer where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're going to focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only 0 and 1. now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels so we're
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter
is going to be derived
later on we build the filters when we
program or train our model so you don't
need to worry what the filter actually
is but you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have mini
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two dimensional matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here one times one one
times zero one times one we multiply
those all together then sum them and we
end up with the convolved feature of
four we're going to take that and
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
patterns so we're just going to slide
this so we're going to predict the first
one and slide it over one notch predict
the second one and so on and so on all
the way through until we have a new
matrix and this matrix which is the same
size as the filter has reduced the image
and whatever filter whatever that's
filtering out is going to be looking at
just those features reduced down to a
smaller matrix so once the feature maps
are extracted the next step is to move
them to the relu layer so the relu layer
the next step first is going to perform
an element-wise operation so each of
those maps coming in if there's negative
pixels so it says all the negative
pixels to zero
and you can see this nice graph where it
just zeros out the negatives and then
you have a value that goes from zero up
to whatever value is coming out of the
matrix this introduces non-linearity to
the network so up until now we have a we
say linearity we're talking about the
fact that the feature has a value so
it's a linear feature this feature um
came up and has let's say the feature is
the edge of the beak you know it's like
or the backslash that we saw he'll look
at that and say okay this feature has a
value from negative 10 to 10 in this
case if it was one it'd say yeah this
might be a beak it might not might be an
edge right there a minus five means no
we're not even going to look at it to
zero and so we end up with an output and
the output takes all these features all
these filtered features remember we're
not just running one filter on this
we're running a number of filters on
this image and so we end up with a
rectified feature map that is looking at
just the features coming through and how
they weigh in from our filters so here
we have an input of a looks like a
toucan bird
very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
relu layers for locating features and
you can see up here is turn it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
skip by two or three or four pixels to
speed up the process that's one of the
ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image you have multiple filters have
been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new matrix one more aspect to
note about the relu layer is we're not
just having one value coming in
so not only do we have multiple features
going through but we're generating
multiple relu layers for locating the
features that's very important to note
you know so we have a quite a bundle we
have multiple filters multiple rail u
which brings us to the next step
forward propagation now we're going to
look at the pooling layer the rectified
feature map now goes through a pooling
layer pooling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map that's
all we're trying to do we're trying to
take a huge amount of information and
reduce it down to a single answer this
is a specific kind of bird this is an
iris this is a rose so you have a
rectified feature map and you see here
we have our rectified feature map coming
in
we set the max pooling with a two by two
filters and a stride of two and if you
remember correctly i talked about not
going one pixel at a time uh well that's
where the stride comes in we end up with
a two by two pooled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a st we skip a few there we go by
two we skip every other pixel and we
just do every other one and this reduces
our rectified feature map which is you
can see over here 16 by 16 to a 4x4 so
we're continually trying to filter and
reduce our data so that we can get to
something we can manage and over here
you see that we have the max three four
one and two and in the max pooling we're
looking for the max value a little bit
different than what we were looking at
before so coming from the rectified
feature we're now finding the max value
and then we're pulling those features
together so instead of think of this as
image of the map think of this as how
valuable is a feature in that area how
much of a feature value do we have we
just want to find the best or the
maximum feature for that area they might
have that one piece of the filter of the
beak said oh i see a one in this beak in
this image and then it skips over and
says i see a three in this image and
says oh this one is rated as a four we
don't want to sum it together because
then you know you might have like five
ones and it'll say ah five but you might
have uh four zeros and one ten and that
ten says well this is definitely a beak
where the ones will say probably not a
beak a little strange analogy since
we're looking at a bird but you can see
how that pulled feature map comes down
and we're just looking for the max value
in each one of those matrixes pooling
layer uses different filters to identify
different parts of the image like edges
corners body feathers eyes beak etc i
know i focus mainly on the beak but
obviously each feature could be each a
different part of the bird coming in so
let's take a look at what that looks
like structure of a convolution neural
network so far this is where we're at
right now we have our input image coming
in and then we use our filters and
there's multiple filters on there that
are being developed to kind of twist and
change that data and so we multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a two by two we multiply it
by each piece of the image and if we
step two then it's every other piece of
the image that generates multiple
convolution layers so we have a number
of convolution layers we have
set up in there just looking at that
data we then take those convolution
layers we run them through the relu
setup and then once we've done through
the release setup and we have multiple
values going on multiple layers that are
relu then we're going to take those
multiple layers and we're going to be
pooling them so now we have the pooling
layers or multiple poolings going on up
until this point we're dealing with
sometimes multiple dimensions you can
have three dimensions some strange data
setups that aren't doing images but
looking at other things they can have
four five six seven dimensions uh so
right now we're looking at 2d image
dimensions coming in into the pooling
layer so the next step is we want to
reduce those dimensions or flatten them
so flattening flattening is a process of
converting all of the resultant
two-dimensional arrays from pooled
feature map into a single long
continuous linear vector so over here
you see where we have a pooled feature
map maybe that's the bird wing and it
has values 6847 and we want to just
flatten this out and turn it into 6847
or a single linear vector and we find
out that not only do we do each of the
pooled feature maps we do all of them
into one long linear vector so now we've
gone through our convolutional neural
network part and we have the input layer
into the next setup all we've done is
taken all those different pooling layers
and we flatten them out and combine them
into a single linear vector going in so
after we've done the flattening we have
just a quick recap because we've covered
so much so it's important to go back and
take a look at each of the steps we've
gone through the structure of the
network so far we have our convolution
where we twist it and we filter it and
multiply the matrixes we end up with our
convolutional layer which uses the rel u
to figure out the values going out into
the pooling as you have numerous
convolution layers that then create
numerous pooling layers pulling that
data together which is the max value
which one we want to send forward we
want to send the best value and then
we're going to take all of that from
each of the pooling layers and we're
going to flatten it and we're going to
combine them into a single input going
into the final layer once you get to
that step you might be looking at that
going boy that looks like the normal
intuit to most neural network and you're
correct it is so once we have the
flattened matrix from the pooling layer
that becomes our input so the pulling
layer is fed as an input to the fully
connected layer to classify the image
and so you can see as our flattened
matrix comes in in this case we have the
pixels from the flattened matrix fed as
an input back to our toucan or whatever
that kind of bird that is i need one of
these to identify what kind of bird that
is it comes into our ford propagation
network
and that will then have the different
weights coming down across and then
finally it selects that that's a bird
and that it's not a dog or a cat in this
case
even though it's not labeled the final
layer there in red is our output layer
our final output layer that says bird
cat or dog so quick recap of everything
we've covered so far we have our input
image which is twisted and multiplied
the filters are multiplied times the
matrix the two matrixes multiplied all
the filters to create our convolution
layer our convolution layers there's
multiple layers in there because it's
all building multiple layers off the
different filters then goes through the
relu as this activation and that creates
our pooling and so once we get into the
pooling layer we then and the pooling
look for who's the best what's the max
value coming in from our convolution and
we take that layer and we flatten it and
then it goes into a fully connected
layer our fully connected neural network
and then to the output and here we can
see the entire process how the cnn
recognizes a bird this is kind of nice
because it's showing the little pixels
and where they're going you can see the
filter is generating this convolution
network and that filter shows up in the
bottom part of the convolution network
and then based on that it uses the relu
for the pooling the pooling then find
out which one's the best and so on all
the way to the fully connected layer at
the end or the classification in the
output layer so that'd be a
classification neural network at the end
so we covered a lot of theory up till
now and you can imagine each one of
these steps has to be broken down in
code so putting that together can be a
little complicated not that each step of
the process is overly complicated but
because we have so many steps we have
one two three four five different steps
going on here with sub steps in there
we're going to break that down and walk
through that in code so in our use case
implementation using the cnn we'll be
using the cfar10 dataset from canadian
institute for advanced research for
classifying images across 10 categories
unfortunately they don't let me know
whether it's going to be a toucan or
some other kind of bird but we do get to
find out whether it can categorize
between a ship a frog deer bird airplane
automobile cat dog horse truck so that's
a lot of fun and if you're looking
anything in the news at all of our
automated cars and everything else you
can see where this kind of processing is
so important in today's world and very
cutting edge as far as what's coming out
in the commercial deployment i mean this
is really cool stuff we're starting to
see this just about everywhere in
industry so great time to be playing
with this and figuring it all out let's
go ahead and dive into the code and see
what that looks like when we're actually
writing our script
before we go on let's do uh one more
quick look at what we have here let's
just take a look at data batch one keys
and remember jupiter notebook i can get
by with not doing the print statement if
i put a variable down there it'll just
display the variable and you can see in
our data batch one for the keys since
this is a dictionary we have the batch
one label data and file names so you can
actually see how it's broken up in our
data set so for the next step or step
four as we're calling it uh we want to
display the images using matte plot
library there's many ways to display the
images you can even well there's other
ways to drill into it but matplot
library is really good for this and
we'll also look at our first reshape uh
setup or shaping the data so you can
have a little glimpse into what that
means uh so we're going to start by
importing our map plot and of course
since i am doing jupiter notebook i need
to do the matplot inline command so it
shows up on my page
so here we go we're going to import
matplot library.pipelot as plt and if
you remember matplot library the pie
plot is like a canvas that we paint
stuff onto and there's my percentage
sign matplot library inline so it's
going to show up in my notebook and then
of course we're going to import numpy as
np for our numbers python array setup
and let's go ahead and set
x equals to data batch 1. so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data we need to go
a little bit of reshaping so in here we
have to go ahead and reshape the data we
have 10 000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to i had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32 by 32
picture and let me do this let me go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here uh so
we have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
i don't know why the data is
particularly like this it probably has
to do with how they originally encoded
it but most pictures put the three
afterward so what we're doing here is
we're going to take
the shape we're going to take the data
which is just a long stream of
information and we're going to break it
up into 10 000 pieces and those 10 000
pieces then are broken into three pieces
each and those three pieces then are 32
by 32. you can look at this like an
old-fashioned projector where they have
the red screen or the red projector the
blue projector and the green projector
and they add them all together and each
one of those is a 32 by 32 bit so that's
probably how this was originally
formatted was in that kind of ideal
things have changed so we're going to
transpose it and we're going to take the
three which was here and we're going to
put it at the end so the first part is
reshaping the data from a single line of
bit data or whatever format it is into
10 000 by 3 by 32 by 32 and then we're
going to transpose the color factor to
the last place so it's the image then
the 32 by 32 in the middle that's this
part right here and then finally we're
going to take this uh which is three
bits of data and put it at the end so
it's more like we do process images now
and then as type this is really
important that we're going to use an
integer eight you can come in here and
you'll see a lot of these they'll try to
do this with a float or float 64. what
you got to remember though is a float
uses a lot of memory so once you switch
this into uh something that's not
integer eight which just goes up to 128
you are just going to the the amount of
ram let's just put that in here is going
to go way up the amount of ram that it
loads so you want to go ahead and use
this you can try the other ones and see
what happens if you have a lot of ram on
your computer but for this exercise this
will work just fine and let's go ahead
and take that and run this so now our x
variable is all loaded and it has all
the images in it from the batch one data
batch one and just to show we were
talking about with the as type on there
if we go ahead and take x0 and just look
for its max value let me go ahead and
run that
uh you'll see it doesn't oops i said 128
it's 255. uh you'll see it doesn't go
over 255 because it's basically an ascii
character is what we're keeping that
down to we're keeping those values down
so they're only 255 0 to 255 versus a
float value which would bring this up um
exponentially in size and since we're
using the matplot library we can do
oops that's not what i wanted since
we're using the map plot library we can
take our canvas and just do a plt dot im
for image show and let's just take a
look at what x0 looks like and it comes
in i'm not sure what that is but you can
see it's a very low grade image
broken down to the minimal pixels on
there and if we did the same thing oh
let's do uh let's see what one looks
like hopefully it's a little easier to
see run on there not enter let's hit the
run on that
and we can see this is probably a semi
truck that's a good guess on there and i
can just go back up here instead of
typing the same line in over and over
we'll look at three
that looks like a dump truck unloading
uh and so on you can do any of the ten
thousand images we can just jump to 55
looks like some kind of animal looking
at us there probably a dog and just for
fun let's do just one more uh
run on there and we can see a nice car
for our image number four so you can see
we pace through all the different images
it's very easy to look at them and
they've been reshaped to fit our view in
what the
matplot library uses for its format so
the next step is we're going to start
creating some helper functions we'll
start by a one hot encoder to help us
more processing the data remember that
your labels they can't just be words
they have to switch it and we use the
one hot encoder to do that and then
we'll also create a class
cfar helper so it's going to have an
init and a setup for the images and then
finally we'll go ahead and run that code
so you can see what that looks like and
then we get into the fun part where
we're actually going to start creating
our model our actual neural network
model so let's start by creating our one
hot encoder we're going to create our
own here uh and it's going to be an out
and we'll have our vector coming in and
our values equal 10. what this means is
that we have the 10 values the 10
possible labels and remember we don't
look at the labels as a number because a
car isn't one more than a horse i'd be
just kind of bizarre to have horse
equals zero car equals one plane equals
two cat equals three so a cat plus a car
equals what uh so instead we create a
numpy array of zeros and there's going
to be 10 values so we have a 10
different values in there so you have
0 or 1. 1 means it's a cat 0 means it's
not a cat
in the next line it might be that 1
means it's a car 0 means it's not a car
so instead of having one output with a
value of 0 to 10 you have 10 outputs
with the values of 0 to 1. that's what
the one hot encoder is doing here and
we're going to utilize this in code in
just a minute so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next helpers we have a few
of these helper functions we're going to
build and when you're working with a
very complicated python project dividing
it up into separate definitions and
classes is very important otherwise it
just becomes really ungainly to work
with so let's go ahead and put in our
next helper which is a class and this is
a lot in this class so we'll break it
down here and let's just start uh oops
we can put a space right in there there
we go that was a little bit more
readable at a second space so we're
going to create our class the cipher
helper and we'll start by initializing
it now there's a lot going on in here so
let's start with the uh init part uh
self dot i equals zero that'll come in a
little bit we'll come back to that in
the lower part we want to initialize our
training batches so when we went through
this there was like a meta batch we
don't need the meta batch but we do need
the data batch one two three four five
and we do not want the testing batch in
here this is just the self all train
batches so we're going to come make an
array of all those different images and
then of course we left the test batch
out so we have our self.test batch
we're going to initialize the training
images and the training labels and also
the test images and the test labels so
these are just this is just to
initialize these variables in here then
we create another definition down here
and this is going to set up the images
let's just take a look and see what's
going on in there now we could have all
just put this as part of the
init part
since this is all just helper stuff but
breaking it up again makes it easier to
read it also makes it easier when we
start executing the different pieces to
see what's going on so that way we have
a nice print statement to say hey we're
now running this and this is what's
going on in here we're going to set up
the self training images at this point
and that's going to go to a numpy array
v stack and in there we're going to load
up
in this case the data for d itself all
train batches again that points right up
to here so we're going to go through
each one of these uh files or each one
of these data sets because they're not a
file anymore we've brought them in data
batch one points to the actual data and
so our self-training images is going to
stack them all into our into a numpy
array and then it's always nice to get
the training length and that's just a
total number of uh self-training images
in there and then we're going to take
the self training images let me switch
marker colors because i am getting a
little too much on the markers up here
oops there we go bring down our marker
change
so we can see it a little better and at
this point this should look familiar
where did we see this well when we
wanted to
look at this above and we want to look
at the images in the matplot library we
had to reshape it so we're doing the
same thing here we're taking our self
training images and based on the
training length total number of images
because we stacked them all together so
now it's just one large file of images
we're going to take and look at it as
our our three video cameras that are
each displaying a 32 by 32 we're going
to switch that around so that now we
have each of our images that stays the
same place and then we have our 32 by 32
and then by our three our last are three
different values for the color and of
course we want to go ahead and they run
this where we say divide by 255 that was
from earlier it just brings all the data
into 0 to 1. that's what this is doing
so we're turning this into a 0 to 1
array which is all the pictures 32 by 32
by three and then we're going to take
the self training labels and we're going
to pump those through our one hot
encoder we just made and we're going to
stack them together and
again we're converting this into an
array that goes from uh instead of
having horse equals one dog equals two
and then horse plus dog would equal
three which would be cat
now it's going to be you know an array
of ten where each one is zero to one
then we want to go ahead and set up our
test images and labels and uh when we're
doing this you're going to see it's the
same thing we just did with the rest of
them we just changed colors right here
this is no different than what we're
doing up here with our training set
we're going to stack the different
images we're going to get the length of
them so we know how many images are in
there you certainly could add them by
hand but it's nice to let the computer
do it especially if it ever changes on
the other end and you're using other
data and again we reshape them and
transpose them and we also do the one
hot encoder same thing we just did on
our training images so now our test
images are in the same format so now we
have a definition which sets up all our
images in there and then the next step
is to go ahead and batch them or next
batch and let's do another breakout here
for batches because this is really
important to understand tends to throw
me for a little loop when i'm working
with tensorflow or keras or a lot of
these we have our data coming in if you
remember we had like 10 000 photos let
me just put 10 000 down here we don't
want to run all 10 000 at once so we
want to break this up into batch sizes
and you also remember that we had the
number of photos in this case length of
test or whatever number is in there we
also have 32 by 32
by 3. so when we're looking at the batch
size we want to change this from 10 000
to
a batch of in this case i think we're
going to do batches of a hundred so we
want to look at just 100 the first
hundred of the photos and if you
remember we set self i
equal to
zero uh so what we're looking at here is
we're going to create x we're going to
get the next batch from the very
initialize we've already initialized it
for 0. so we're going to look at x from
0 to batch size which we've set to 100
so just the first 100 images and then
we're going to reshape that into
and this is important to let the data
know that we're looking at 100 by 32 by
32 by 3. now we've already formatted it
to the 32 by 32 by 3. this just sets
everything up correctly so that x has
the data in there in the correct order
in the correct shape and then the y just
like the x uh is our labels so our
training labels again they go from zero
to batch size in this case they do sell
five plus batch size because the cell
phi is going to keep changing and then
finally we increment the self i because
we have zero so we so the next time we
call it we're going to get the next
batch size and so basically we have x
and y x being the photograph data coming
in and y being the label and that of
course is labeled through one hot
encoder so if you remember correctly if
it was say horse is equal to zero it
would be um one for the zero position
since this is the horse and then
everything else would be zero in here
let me just put lines through there
there we go there's our array
hard to see that array so let's go ahead
and take that and uh we're going to
finish loading it since this is our
class and now we're armed with all this
um
our setup over here let's go ahead and
load that up and so we're going to
create a variable ch with the cfar
helper in it and then we're going to do
ch dot setup images
now we could have just put all the setup
images under the init but by breaking
this up into two parts it makes it much
more readable and also if you're doing
other work there's reasons to do that as
far as the setup let's go ahead and run
that and you can see where it says uh
setting up training images and labels
setting up test images and that's one of
the reasons we broke it up is so that if
you're testing this out you can actually
have print statements in there telling
you what's going on which is really nice
uh they did a good job with this setup i
like the way that it was broken up in
the back and then one quick note you
want to remember that batch to set up
the next batch as we have to run
batch equals ch next batch of 100
because we're going to use the 100 size
but we'll come back to that we're going
to use that just remember that that's
part of our code we're going to be using
in a minute from the definition we just
made so now we're ready to create our
model first thing we want to do is we
want to import our tensorflow as tf i'll
just go ahead and run that so it's
loaded up and you can see we got a
warning here
that's because they're making some
changes it's always growing and they're
going to be depreciating one of the
values from float 64 to float type or is
treated as an np float 64. uh nothing to
really worry about this doesn't even
affect what we're working on because
we've set all of our stuff to a 255
value or zero to one and do keep in mind
that 0 to 1 value that we converted the
255 is still a float value but it'll
easily work with either the numpy float
64 or the numpy d type float it doesn't
matter which one it goes through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensorflow uh
we'll go ahead and just increase the
size in there just a moment so you can
get a better view of the um what we're
typing in uh we're going to set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
going to set x equals tf placeholder tf
float 32 we just talked about the float
64 versus the numpy float we're actually
just going to keep this at float32 more
than a significant number of decimals
for what we're working with and since
it's a placeholder we're going to set
the shape equal to and we've set it
equal to none
because at this point we're just holding
the place on there we'll be setting up
as we run the batches that's what the
first value is and then 32 by 32 by 3
that's what we've reshaped our data to
fit in and then we have our y true
equals placeholder tf float 32 and the
shape equals none comma 10. 10 is the 10
different labels we have so it's an
array of 10. and then let's create one
more placeholder we'll call this uh hold
prob or hold probability and we're going
to use this we don't have to have a
shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call drop out
if you remember from our theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a placeholder for that
also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensorflow when you use keras it does
some of this automatically but we're in
tensorflow direct cross sits on
tensorflow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each layer has
to have a bias going in we're going to
go ahead and work on our conversional 2d
our max pool so we have our pooling
layer our convolutional layer and then
our normal full layer so we're going to
go ahead and put those all into
definitions and let's see what that
looks like in code and you can also grab
some of these helper functions from the
mnist the uh nist setup let me just put
that in there if you're under the
tensorflow so a lot of these already in
there but we're gonna go ahead and do
our own and we're gonna create our init
weights and one of the reasons we're
doing this is so that you can actually
start thinking about what's going on in
the back end so even though there's ways
to do this with an automation sometimes
these have to be tweaked and you have to
put in your own setup in here now we're
not going to be doing that we're just
going to recreate them for our code and
let's take a look at this we have our
weights and so what comes in is going to
be the shape and what comes out is going
to be
random numbers so we're going to go
ahead and just admit some random numbers
based on the shape with a standard
deviation of 0.1 kind of a fun way to do
that and then the tf variable
init random distribution so we're just
creating a random distribution on there
that's all that is for the weights now
you might change that you might have a
higher standard deviation in some cases
you actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant
in this case we're using 0.1 a lot of
times the bias is just put in as one and
then you have your weights to add on to
that but we're going to set this as 0.1
so we want to return a convolutional 2d
in this case a neural network this is uh
would be a layer on here what's going on
with the con 2d is we're taking our data
coming in
we're going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as 32
by
3 and we want to change this so that
it's just this is three dimensions and
it's going to reformat this as just two
dimensions so it's going to take this
number here and combine it with the 32
by 32 so this is a very important layer
here because it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down i'm just going to jump down one
here it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
preformatting and the setup and then you
have your actual convolution layer that
goes through on there and you can see
here we have init weights by the shape a
knit bias shape of three because we have
the three different here's our three
again and then we return the tfnn relu
with the convention 2d so this
convolutional has this feeding into it
right there it's using that as part of
it and of course the input is the x y
plus b the bias so that's quite a
mouthful but these two are the are the
keys here to creating the convolutional
layers there the convolutional 2d coming
in and then the convolutional layer
which then steps through and creates all
those filters we saw then of course we
have our pooling uh so after each time
we run it through the convectional layer
we want to pull the data if you remember
correctly on the on the pool side and
let me just get rid of all my marks it's
getting a little crazy there and in fact
let's go ahead and jump back to that
slide let's just take a look at that
slide over here uh so we have our image
coming in we create our convolutional
layer with all the filters remember the
filters go um you know the filter is
coming in here and it looks at these
four boxes and then if it's a step let's
say step two it then goes to these four
boxes and then the next step and so on
uh so we have our convolutional layer
that we generate or convolutional layers
they use the uh relu function there's
other functions out there for this
though the relu is the
most the one that works the best at
least so far i'm sure that will change
then we have our pooling now if you
remember correctly the pooling was max
uh so if we had the filter coming in and
they did the multiplication on there and
we have a one and maybe a two here and
another one here and a three here three
is the max and so out of all of these
you then create an array that would be
three and if the max is over here two or
whatever it is that's what goes into the
pooling of what's going on in our
pooling uh so again we're reducing that
data down reducing it down as small as
we can and then finally we're going to
flatten it out into a single array and
that goes into our fully connected layer
and you can see that here in the code
right here we're going to create our
normal full layer um so at some point
we're going to take from our pooling
layer this will go into some kind of
flattening process and then that will be
fed into the full the different layers
going in down here and so we have our
input size you'll see our input layer
get shape which is just going to get the
shape for whatever's coming in uh and
then input size initial weights is also
based on the input layer coming in and
the input size down here is based on the
input layer shape so we're just going to
already use the shape and already have
our size coming in and of course you
have to make sure you knit the bias
always put your bias on there and we'll
do that based on the size so this will
return
tf.matimol
input layer w plus b this is just a
normal full layer that's what this means
right down here that's what we're going
to return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and create the layers
let's see what that looks like
now that we've done all the heavy
lifting and everything uh we get to do
all the easy part let's go ahead and
create our layers we'll create a
convolution layer one and two two
different convolutional layers and then
we'll take that and we'll flatten that
out and create a reshape pooling in
there for our reshape and then we'll
have our full uh layer at the end so
let's start by creating our first
convolutional layer then we come in here
and let me just run that real quick and
i want you to notice on here the 3
and the 32 this is important because
coming into this convolutional layer we
have three different channels and 32
pixels each so that has to be in there
the 4 and 4 you can play with this is
your filter size so if you remember you
have a filter and you have your image
and the filter slowly steps over and
filters out this image depending on what
your step is for this particular setup 4
4 is just fine that should work pretty
good for what we're doing for the size
of the image and then of course at the
end once you have your convolutional
layer set up you also need to pull it
and you'll see that the pooling is
automatically set up so that it would
see the different shape based on what's
coming in so here we have max toolbar
2x2 and we put in the convolutional one
that we just created the convolutional
layer we just created goes right back
into it and that right up here as you
can see is the x that's coming in from
here so it knows to look at the first
model and set the the data accordingly
set that up so matches and we went ahead
and ran this already i think i read let
me go and run it again and if we're
going to do one layer let's go ahead and
do a second layer down here and it's uh
we'll call it convo 2.
it's also a convolutional layer on this
and you'll see that we're feeding
convolutional 1 in the pooling so it
goes from convolutional one into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional two into convolutional to
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer uh let's go ahead and we'll do uh
since we have 64 coming out of here and
we have a four by four going in let's do
eight by eight by 64. so let's do
4096. this is going to be the flat layer
so that's how many bits are coming
through on the flat layer and we'll
reshape this so we'll reshape our
convo 2 pooling and that will feed into
here the combo 2 pulling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's 4096 in size that's what that
means there we'll go ahead and run this
so we've now created this variable the
convo 2 flat and then we have our first
full layer this is the final
neural network where the flat layer
going in and we're going to again use
the relu for our setup on there on a
neural network for evaluation and you'll
notice that we're going to create our
first full layer our normal full layer
that's our definition so we created that
that's creating the normal full layer
and our input for the data comes right
here from the this goes right into it uh
the convo to flat so this tells it how
big the data is and we're going to have
it come out it's going to have 10 24
that's how big the layer is coming out
we'll go ahead and run this so now we
have our full layer one and with the
full layer one we want to also define
the full one dropout to go with that so
our full layer one comes in uh keep
probability equals whole probability
remember we created that earlier and the
full layer one is what's coming into it
and this is going backwards and training
the data we're not training every weight
we're only training a percentage of them
each time which helps get rid of the
bias so let me go ahead and run that and
finally we'll go ahead and create a y
predict which is going to equal the
normal full 1 dropout and 10 because we
have 10 labels in there now in this
neural network we could have added
additional layers that would be another
option to play with you can also play
with instead of 10 24 you can use other
numbers for the way that sets up and
what's coming out going into the next
one we're only going to do just the one
layer and the one layer drop out and you
can see if we did another layer it'd be
really easy just to feed in the full one
dropout into full layer two and then
full layer two dropout would have full
layer two feed into it and then you'd
switch that here for the y prediction
for right now this is great this
particular data set is tried and true
and we know that this will work on it
and if we just type in y predict and we
run that
we'll see that this is a tensor object
shape question mark 10 d type 32 a quick
way to double check what we're working
on so now we've got all of our we've
done a setup all the way to the y
predict which we just did we want to go
ahead and apply the loss function and
make sure that's set up in there create
the optimizer and then
trainer optimizer and create a variable
to initialize all the global tf
variables so before we dive in to the
loss function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehab over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups
we pointed out up here we can change the
4 4 and use different numbers there they
change your outcome so depending on what
numbers you use here will have a huge
impact on how well your model fits and
that's the same here of the 1024 also
this is also another number that if you
continue to raise that number you'll get
possibly a better fit you might overfit
and if you lower that number you'll use
less resources and generally you want to
use this in
the exponential growth an exponential
being 2 4 8 16 and in this case the next
one down would be 512. you can use any
number there but those would be the
ideal numbers uh when you look at this
data so the next step in all this is we
need to also create a way of tracking
how good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it
we're going to feed it our labels and we
have our true labels and our prediction
labels so coming in here is where the
two different variables we're sending in
or the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy
in information theory the cross entropy
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful uh really
we're just looking at the amount of
error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these um are
incorrect so how much of it matches and
we're going to look at that we're just
going to look at the average that's what
the mean the reduced to the mean means
here so we're looking at the average
error on this and so the next step is
we're going to take the error we want to
know our cross entropy or our loss
function how much loss we have that's
going to be part of how we train the
model so when you know what the loss is
and we're training it we feed that back
into the back propagation setup and so
we want to go ahead and optimize that
here's our optimizer we're going to
create the optimizer using an atom
optimizer remember there's a lot of
different ways of optimizing the data
atoms the most popular used
so our optimizer is going to equal the
tf train atom optimizer if you don't
remember what the learning rate is let
me just pop this back into here here's
our learning rate when you have your
weights you have all your weights and
your different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out
and it has all its weights and then the
error is being prop sent back through in
reverse on our neural network so we take
this error we adjust these weights based
on the different formulas in this case
the atom formula is what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by .001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our delta
w is only 0.001 of the actual delta w of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training
variable or function and this is going
to equal our optimizer minimize cross
entropy and we make sure we go ahead and
run this
so it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
more
variable in here and we're going to
create a variable to initialize all the
global tf variables and when we look at
this
the tf global variable initializer this
is a tensorflow
object it goes through there and it
looks at all our different setup that we
have going under our tensor flow and
then initializes those variables
so it's kind of like a magic wand
because it's all hidden in the back end
of tensorflow all you need to know about
this is that you have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation
and you have to run that once you have
your setup going so we'll go ahead and
run this piece of code and then we're
going to go ahead and train our data so
let me run this let's load it up there
and so now we're going to go ahead and
run the model by creating a graph
session graph session is a tensorflow
term so you'll see that coming up it's
one of the things that throws me because
i always think of graphics and spark and
graph as just general graphing uh but
they talk about a graph session so we're
going to go ahead and run the model and
let's go ahead and walk through this uh
what's going on here and let's paste
this data in here and here we go so
we're going to start off with it with a
tf session as cess so that's our actual
tf session we've created uh so we're
right here with the tf
session our session we're creating we're
going to run tf global variable
initializer so right off the bat we're
initializing our variables here and then
we have for i in range 500. so what's
going on here remember 500 we're going
to break the date up and we're going to
batch it in at 500 points each we've
created our session run so we're going
to do with tf session as session right
here we've created our variable session
uh and then we're going to run we're
going to go ahead and initialize it so
we have our tf global variables
initializer that we created
that initializes our session in here the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to go for i in range of 500 batch
equals ch.nextbatch
so if you remember correctly this is
loading up
100 pictures at a time and
this is going to loop through that 500
times so we are literally doing uh what
is that 500 times 100 is
50 000. so that's 50 000 pictures we're
going to process right there and the
first process is we're going to do a
session run we're going to take our
train we created our train variable or
optimizer in there we're going to feed
it the dictionary we had our feed
dictionary that we created and we have x
equals batch 0 coming in y true batch 1
hold the probability 0.5 and then just
so that we can keep track of what's
going on we're going to every 100 steps
we're going to run a print so currently
on step format
accuracy is
and we're going to look at matches
equals tf.equal tf argument y prediction
1 tf.arg max y true comma 1. so we're
going to look at this as how many
matches it has and here our acc
all we're doing here is we're going to
take the matches how many matches they
have it creates it generates a chart
we're going to convert that to float
that's what the tfcast does and then we
just want to know the average we just
want to the average of the accuracy and
then we'll go ahead and print that out
print session run accuracy feed
dictionary so it takes all this and it
prints out our accuracy on there so
let's go ahead and take this oops
screen's there let's go ahead and take
this and let's run it and this is going
to take a little bit to run uh so let's
see what happens on my old laptop and
we'll see here that we have our current
uh we're currently on step zero it takes
a little bit to get through the accuracy
and this will take just a moment to run
we can see that on our step zero it has
an accuracy of 0.1 or 0.1028
and as it's running we'll go ahead you
don't need to watch it run all the way
but this accuracy is going to change a
little bit up and down so we've actually
lost some accuracy during our step two
but we'll see how that comes out let's
come back after we run it all the way
through and see how the different steps
come out it's actually reading that
backwards uh the way this works is the
closer we get to one the more accuracy
we have so you can see here we've gone
from a point one to a point three nine
um and we'll go ahead and pause this and
come back and see what happens when
we're done with the full run all right
now that we've
prepared the meal got it in the oven and
pulled out my finished dish here if
you've ever watched any of the old
cooking shows let's discuss a little bit
about this accuracy going on here and
how do you interpret that we've done a
couple things first we've defined
accuracy
the reason i got it backwards before is
you have
loss or accuracy and with loss you'll
get a graph that looks like this it goes
oops that's an s by the way there we go
you get a graph that curves down like
this and with accuracy you get a graph
that curves up this is how good it's
doing now in this case uh one is
supposed to be really good accuracy that
means it gets close to one but it never
crosses one so if you have an accuracy
of one that is phenomenal in fact that's
pretty much
you know unheard of and the same thing
with loss if you have a loss of zero
that's also unheard of the zero's
actually on this this axis right here as
we go in there so how do we interpret
that because you know if i was looking
at this and i go oh 0.51 that's uh 51
you're doing 50 50. no this is not
percentage let me just put that in there
it is not percentage uh this is log
rhythmic what that means is that 0.2 is
twice as good as 0.1 and when we see 0.4
that's twice as good as 0.2 real way to
convert this into a percentage you
really can't say this is is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage uh we might look
at this as uh 50
we're just guessing equals 0.1 and if 50
roughly equals 0.1 that's we started up
here at the top remember at the top here
here's our 0.1028 the accuracy of 50
then 75 percent is about 0.2 and so on
and so on don't quote those numbers
because that doesn't work that way they
say that if you have
0.95 five that's pretty much saying a
hundred percent and if you have uh
anywhere between you'd have to go look
this up let me go and remove all my
drawings there uh so the magic number is
0.5 we really want to be over a 0.5 in
this whole thing and we have uh both
0.504 remember this is accuracy if we
were looking at loss then we would be
looking the other way but 0.05 you know
instead of how high it is we want how
low it is uh but with accuracy being
over 0.5 is pretty valid that means this
is pretty solid and if you get to a 0.95
then it's a direct correlation that's
what we're looking for here in these
numbers you can see we finished with
this model at
0.5135 so still good um and if we look
at uh when they ran this in the other
end remember there's a lot of randomness
that goes into it when we see the
weights uh they got
.5251 so a little better than ours but
that's fine you'll find your own uh
comes up a little bit better or worse
depending on just that randomness and so
we've gone through the whole model we've
created we've trained the model and
we've also gone through on every 100th
run to test the model to see how
accurate it is welcome to the rnn
tutorial that's the recurrent neural
network so we talk about a feed forward
neural network in a feed forward neural
network information flows only in the
forward direction from the input nodes
through the hidden layers if any into
the output nodes there are no cycles or
loops in the network and so you can see
here we have our input layer i was
talking about how it just goes straight
forward into the hidden layers so each
one of those connects and then connects
to the next hidden layer connects to the
output layer and of course we have a
nice simplified version where it has a
predicted output the refer to the input
is x a lot of times and the output as y
decisions are based on current input no
memory about the past no future scope
why recurrent neural network issues in
feed forward neural network so one of
the biggest issues is because it doesn't
have a scope of memory or time a
feed-forward neural network doesn't know
how to handle sequential data it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever i put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feed forward doesn't look at any of that
it just looks at this is what's coming
in and it cannot memorize previous
inputs so it doesn't have that list of
inputs coming in solution to feed
forward neural network you'll see here
where it says recurrent neural network
and we have our x on the bottom going to
h going to y that's your feed forward
but right in the middle it has a value c
so there's a whole another process so
it's memorizing what's going on in the
hidden layers and the hidden layers as
they produce data feed into the next one
so your hidden layer might have an
output that goes off to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades in fluctuations by the
second
it's like three terabytes a day of data
so we're going to look at one stock just
analyzing one stock is really tricky in
here we'll give you a little jump on
that so that's exciting but don't expect
to get rich off of it immediately
another application of the rnn is
natural language processing text mining
and sentiment analysis can be carried
out using rnn for natural language
processing and you can see right here
the term natural language processing
when you stream those three words
together is very different than ice if i
said processing language natural leap so
the time series is very important when
we're analyzing sentiments it can change
the whole value of a sentence just by
switching the words around or if you're
just counting the words you may get one
sentiment where if you actually look at
the order they're in you get a
completely different sentiment when it
rains look for rainbows when it's dark
look for stars both of these are
positive sentiments and they're based
upon the order of which the sentence is
going in machine translation given an
input in one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess that's denoted by
the flags i have a flag i own it no um
but they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down it'll make more
sense and usually we have our
propagation forward neural network with
the input layers the hidden layers the
output layer with the recurrent neural
network we turn that on its side so here
it is and now our x comes up from the
bottom into the hidden layers into y and
they usually draw very simplified x to h
with c as a loop a to y where a b and c
are the perimeters a lot of times you'll
see this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the c goes in and then the x
goes in so the x is going upward bound
and c is going to the right a is going
out and c is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn
cn and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on h t minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h of t
minus 1 that's the last h output and x
of t going in so it's the last output of
h combined with the new input of x where
h t is the new state fc is a function
with the parameters c that's a common
way of denoting it
h t minus 1 is the old state coming out
and then x of t is an input vector at
time of step t
well we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a
one-to-one single output
one-to-one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural network used
for regular machine learning problems
why because vanilla is usually
considered kind of a just a real basic
flavor but because it's very basic a lot
of times they'll call it the vanilla
neural network which is not the common
term but it is you know kind of a slang
term people will know what you're
talking about usually if you say that
then we run one to many so you have a
single input and you might have a
multiple outputs in this case uh image
captioning as we looked at earlier where
we have not just looking at it as a dog
but a dog catching a ball in the air and
then you have mini to one network takes
in a sequence of inputs examples
sentiment analysis where a given
sentence can be classified as expressing
positive or negative sentiments and we
looked at that as we were discussing if
it rains look for a rainbow so positive
sentiment where rain might be a negative
sentiment if you're just adding up the
words in there and then the course if
you're going to do a one-to-one mini to
one one to many there's many to many
networks takes in a sequence of inputs
and generates a sequence of outputs
example machine translation so we have a
lengthy sentence coming in english and
then going out in all the different
languages you know just a wonderful tool
very complicated set of computations if
you're a translator you realize just how
difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called the vanishing gradient
problem while training an rnn your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as vanishing gradient and you'll
see here they have a nice
image loss of information through time
so if you're pushing not enough
information forward that information is
lost and then when you go to train it
you start losing the third word in the
sentence or something like that or
doesn't quite follow the full logic of
what you're working on
exploding gradient problem oh this is
one that runs into everybody when you're
working with this particular neural
network when the slope tends to grow
exponentially instead of decaying this
problem is called exploding gradient
issues in gradient problem long training
time poor performance bad accuracy and
i'll add one more in there uh your
computer if you're on a lower end
computer testing out a model will lock
up and give you the memory error
explaining gradient problem consider the
following two examples to understand
what should be the next word in the
sequence
the person who took my bike and blank a
thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the rnn must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief as singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the rnn must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the air to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation function so we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's
setup is what they call long-term
dependencies suppose we try to predict
the last word in the text the clouds are
in the and you probably said sky here we
do not need any further context it's
pretty clear that the last word is going
to be sky suppose we try to predict the
last word in the text i have been
staying in spain for the last 10 years i
can speak fluent maybe you said
portuguese or french no he probably said
spanish the word we predict will depend
on the previous few words in context
here we need the context of spain to
predict the last word in the text it's
possible that the gap between the
relevant information and the point where
it is needed to become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer lstms's
also have a chain-like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior ls
tmss also have a chain like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs get in here i
want you to note that you have x a t
minus one coming in you have x a t
coming in and you have x a t plus one
and you have h of t minus one and h of t
coming in and h of t plus one going out
and of course on the other side is the
output a
in the middle we have our tangent h but
it occurs in two different places so not
only when we're computing the x of t
plus one are we getting the tangent h
from x to t but we're also getting that
value coming in from the x a t minus one
so the short of it is as you look at
these layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address a
problem of complicated long sequential
information coming in like we were just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long short term
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing sensing in the lstms that we
look at the first one is we want to
forget irrelevant parts of the previous
state you know a lot of times like you
know is as in a unless we're trying to
look at whether it's a plural noun or
not they don't really play a huge part
in the language so we want to get rid of
them then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like
so step one decides how much of the past
it should remember first step in the
lstm is to decide which information to
be omitted in from the cell in that
particular time step it is decided by
the sigmoid function it looks at the
previous state h to t minus 1 and the
current input x of t and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus one and
then x a t plus of course you have a
bias in there with any of our neural
networks so we have a bias function so f
of t equals forget gate decides which
information to delete that is not
important from the previous time step
considering an stm is fed with the
following inputs from the previous and
present time step alice is good in
physics john on the other hand is good
in chemistry so previous output john
plays football well he told me yesterday
over the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
at this the first step is the forget
gate realizes there might be a change in
context after encounting the first full
stop compares with the current input
sentence of x a t so we're looking at
that full stop and then compares it with
the input of the new sentence the next
sentence talks about john so the
information on alice is deleted okay
that's important to know so we have this
input coming in and if we're going to
continue on with john then that's going
to be the primary information we're
looking at the position of the subject
is vacated and is assigned to john and
so in this one we've seen that we've
weeded out a whole bunch of information
and we're only passing information on
john since that's now the new topic so
step two is then to decide how much
should this unit add to the current
state in the second layer there are two
parts one is a sigmoid function and the
other is the tangent h in the sigmoid
function it decides which values to let
through zero or one tangent h function
gives a weightage to the values which
are passed deciding their level of
importance minus one to one and you can
see the two formulas that come up the i
of t equals the sigmoid of the weight of
i h to t minus 1 x of t plus the bias of
i and the c of t equals the tangent of h
of the weight of c of h of t minus 1 x
of t plus the bias of c so our i of t
equals the input gate determines which
information to let through based on its
significance in the current time step if
this seems a little complicated don't
worry because a lot of the programming
is already done when we get to the case
study understanding though that this is
part of the program is important when
you're trying to figure out these what
to set your settings at you should also
note when you're looking at this it
should have some semblance to your
forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a
weight plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint as i step out
of my suit again consider the current
input at x of t john plays football well
he told me yesterday over the phone that
he had served as a captain of his
college football team that's our input
input gate analysis the important
information john plays football and he
was a captain of his college team is
important he told me over the phone
yesterday is less important hence it is
forgotten this process of adding some
new information can be done via the
input gate now this example is as a
human form and we'll look at training
this stuff in just a minute
but as a human being if i wanted to get
this information from a conversation
maybe it's a google voice listening in
on you or something like that um how do
we weed out the information that he was
talking to me on the phone yesterday
well i don't want to memorize that he
talked to me on the phone yesterday or
maybe that is important but in this case
it's not i want to know that he was the
captain of the football team i want to
know that he served i want to know that
john plays football and he was the
captain of the college football team
those are the two things that i want to
take away as a human being again we
measure a lot of this from the human
viewpoint and that's also how we try to
train them so we can understand these
neural networks finally we get to step
three decides what part of the current
cell state makes it to the output the
third step is to decide what will be our
output first we run a sigmoid layer
which decides what parts of the cell
state make it to the output then we put
the cell state through the tangent h to
push the values to be between -1 and 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate so when we talk about the
output of t we set that equal to the
sigmoid of the weight of zero of the h
of t minus one and back one step in time
by the x of t plus of course the bias
the h of t equals the outer t times the
tangent of the tangent h of c of t so
our o t equals the output gate allows
the passed in information to impact the
output in the current time step let's
consider the example to predicting the
next word in the sentence john played
tremendously well against the opponent
and one for his team for his
contributions brave blank was awarded
player of the match there could be a lot
of choices for the empty space current
input brave is an adjective adjectives
describe a noun john could be the best
output after brave thumbs up for john
awarded player of the match and if you
were to pull just the nouns out of the
sentence team doesn't look right because
that's not really the subject we're
talking about contributions you know
brave contributions or brave team brave
player brave match
so you look at this and you can start to
train this these this neural network so
starts looking at and goes oh no john is
what we're talking about so brave is an
adjective
john's going to be the best output and
we give john a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part a
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016.
we're going to try to predict the stock
prices of 2017.
and this will be a narrow set of data
we're not going to do the whole stock
market it turns out that the new york
stock exchange generates roughly three
terabytes of data per day that's all the
different trades up and down of all the
different stocks going on in each
individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but you at
least you can give an eye you can give a
step forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm let's
dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start to look very familiar because it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just reminder we're going to be
using anaconda the jupiter notebook so
here i have my anaconda navigator when
we go under environments i've actually
set up a cross python 36 i'm in python36
and nice thing about anaconda especially
the newer version i remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python in different
environments anaconda now has a nice
interface
and i have this installed both on a
ubuntu linux machine and on windows so
it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you're going to
start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupiter
notebook
have set up a lot of stuff so that we're
ready to go kind of like martha
stewart's in the old cooking show so we
want to make sure we have all our tools
for you so you're not waiting for them
to load and if we go up here to where it
says new you can see where you can
create a new python 3. that's what we
did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and i'm actually renamed this if you
go under file you can rename it we've
i'm calling it rnn stock and let's just
take a look and start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine let's start putting
that code in there and seeing what those
imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as np that's
uh the number python which is your numpy
array and the matplot library because
we're going to do some plotting at the
end
and our pandas for our data set our
pandas as pd and when i hit run it
really doesn't do anything except for
load those modules just a quick note let
me just do a quick draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
in fact depending on what your system is
since we're using keras i put an overlap
here uh but you'll find that almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason i
overlapped this with uh cross let me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in uh is because cross has
like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple steps a lot of
times that are in the keras setup we'll
take a look at that to see what comes up
in our code as we go through and look at
stock and the last part is to evaluate
and if you're working with
shareholders or
classroom whatever it is you're working
with the evaluate is the next biggest
piece
so the actual code here crosses a little
bit more but when you're working with
some of the other packages you might
have like three lines that might be it
all your stuff is in your pre-processing
and your data since cross has is is
cutting edge and you load the individual
layers you'll see that there's a few
more lines here and crosses a little bit
more robust and then you spend a lot of
times like i said with the evaluate you
want to have something you present to
everybody else and say hey this is what
i did this is what it looks like so
let's go through those steps this is
like a kind of just general overview and
let's just take a look and see what the
next set of code looks like and in here
we have a data set train and it's going
to be read using the pd or pandas dot
read csv and it's a google stock price
train dot csv and so under this we have
training set equals data set train dot i
location and we've kind of sorted out
part of that so what's going on here
let's just take a look at let's look at
the actual file and see what's going on
there now if we look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take
20 percent of the data out so we can
test it and then we train the rest of it
that's what we use to create our neural
network that way we can find out how
good it is uh but let's go ahead and
just take a look and see what that looks
like as far as the file itself and i
went ahead and just opened this up in a
basic word pad and text editor just so
we can take a look at it certainly you
can open up an excel or any other kind
of spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we call it the google stock price
and this specifically is google this is
the google stock values from as you can
see here we started off at 1 3 2012.
so when we look at this first setup up
here
we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original frame
let me just go back there
they had it set to home ubuntu downloads
google stock price train i went ahead
and changed that because we're in the
same file where i'm running the code so
i've saved this particular python code
and i don't need to go through any
special paths or have the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using
our data set
and we're now in pandas
so pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do i
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we saw we start with zero which is the
date
and we're going to be looking at open
and high which would be one and two
we'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns
but for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again i said the first half is
very boring whenever we hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it and we want to
do what they call feature scaling and in
here we're going to pull it up from the
sk learn or the sk kit pre-processing
import min max scaler and when you look
at this you got to remember that biases
in our data we want to get rid of that
so if you have something that's like a
really high value let's just draw a
quick graph
and i have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value one stock has a
value of a hundred and another stock has
a value of five
you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min
and then everything else goes and then
we change this so we just squish it down
i like the word squish so it's between 1
and 0. so 100 equals 1 or 1 equals 100
and 0 equals 5. and you can just
multiply it's usually just a simple
multiplication we're using
multiplication so it's going to be minus
5 and then 100 divided or 95 divided by
1. so or whatever value is is divided by
95.
and once we've actually created our
scale we've telling is going to be from
0 to 1 we want to take our training set
and we're going to create a training set
scaled and we're going to use our scalar
sc we're going to fit we're going to fit
and transform the training set
so we can now use the sc this this
particular object we'll use it later on
our testing set because remember we have
to also scale that when we go to test
our model and see how it works and we'll
go ahead and click on the run again it's
not going to have any output yet because
we're just setting up all the variables
right so we pasted the data in here and
we're going to create the data structure
with the 60 time steps and output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
and we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there there's
nothing below the 60. so if we're going
to use 60 time steps we have to start at
point 60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1 and then as
i is equal to 60 this value is going to
be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is
0 to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61
2 to 62 and so on and so on and if you
remember i said 0 to 60 that's incorrect
because it does not count remember it
starts at 0 so this is a count of 60 so
it's actually 59. important to remember
that as we're looking at this and then
the second part of this that we're
looking at so if you remember correctly
here we go we go from uh 0 to 59 of i
and then we have a comma a 0 right here
and so finally we're just going to look
at the open value now i know we did put
it in there for one to two
if you remember quickly it doesn't count
the second one so it's just the open
value we're looking at just open
and then finally we have y train dot
append training set i to 0 and if you
remember correctly i 2 or i comma 0. if
you remember correctly this is 0 to 59
so there's 60 values in it so we do i
down here this is number 60. so we're
going to do this is we're creating an
array and we have 0
to 59
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a
0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58. that's where this value here comes
in that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has uh which is filled
with arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded
one array which is just the value and
what we're looking at you want to think
about this as a time sequence
here's my open open open open open open
what's the next one in the series so
we're looking at the google stock and
each time it opens we want to know what
the next one 0 through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61 2 through 62 what's
62 and so on and so on going up and then
once we've loaded those in our for loop
we go ahead and take x train and y train
equals
np.arrayxtrain.npray train we're just
converting this back into a numpy array
that way we can use all the cool tools
that we get with numpy array including
reshaping so if we take a look and see
what's going on here we're going to take
our x train
we're going to reshape it
wow what the heck does reshape mean uh
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly um so many numbers by
60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get um x train dot shape
of one gets the other shape and we're
just making sure the data is formatted
correctly and so you use this to pull
the fact that it's 60 by um
in this case where's that value 60 pi
1199 1258 minus 60 11.99 and we're
making sure that that is shaped
correctly so the data is grouped into
11.99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the in layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more
and then you get the leaf np dot reshape
comes from and using the existing shapes
to form it we'll go ahead and run this
piece of code again there's no real
output and then we'll import our
different cross modules that we need so
from cross models we're going to import
the sequential model dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dents our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
dropout and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment but you do
need the with the lstm you do need the
dropout and then the final layer will be
the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and they'll bring port our modules
and you'll see we get an error on here
and if you read it closer it's not
actually an error it's a warning what
does this warning mean these things come
up all the time when you're working with
such cutting edge modules are complete
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the h5py
module which is part of cross is going
to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5 pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
dropout regularization and right there
should be the q dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and add this in i'll
go ahead and run this and we had three
of them so let me go ahead and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put
two more in i mean i said one more in
but it's actually two more in and then
let's add one more after that and as you
can see each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50. the units is the positive integer
and it's the dimensionality of the
output space this is what's going out
into the next layer so we might have 60
coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at x train shape so input shape equals
the x train shape of one comma one makes
it really easy you don't have to
remember all the numbers that put in 60
or whatever else is in there you just
let it tell the regressor what model to
use and so we follow our stm with a
dropout layer now understanding the
dropout layer is kind of exciting
because one of the things that happens
is we can over train our network that
means that our neural network will
memorize such specific data that it has
trouble predicting anything that's not
in that specific realm to fix for that
each time we run through the training
mode we're going to take point two or
twenty percent of our neurons and just
turn them off so we're only gonna train
on the other ones and it's gonna be
random that way each time we pass
through this we don't over train these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20.
and finally they see a big difference as
we go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
the shapes already the output units is
50 here this item the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says so 50 is coming out from our last
layer that's coming up you know goes
into the regressor and of course we have
our dropout and that's what's coming
into this one and so on and so on and so
the next three layers we don't have to
let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had lstm
dropout and dents dense just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know i want to know the answer
at this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we brought
in our different modules we formatted
the data for training it we set it up
you know we have our y x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers where we know so far that we're
going to put in there we've reshaped
that we've come in and built our cross
we've imported our different layers and
we have in here if you look we have what
five total layers now cross is a little
different than a lot of other systems
because a lot of other systems put this
all in one line and do it automatic but
they don't give you the options of how
those layers interface and they don't
give you the options of how the data
comes in cross is cutting edge for this
reason so even though there's a lot of
extra steps in building the model this
has a huge impact on the output and what
we can do with this these new models
from cross so we brought in our dents we
have our full model put together a
regressor so we need to go ahead and
compile it and then we're going to go
ahead and fit the data we're going to
compile the pieces so they all come
together and then we're going to run our
training data on there and actually
recreate our regressor so it's ready to
be used so let's go ahead and compile
that and i go ahead and run that and if
you've been looking at any of our other
tutorials on neural networks you'll see
we're going to use the optimizer atom
atom is optimized for big data there's a
couple other optimizers out there beyond
the scope of this tutorial but certainly
atom will work pretty good for this and
loss equals mean squared value so when
we're training it this is what we want
to base the loss on how bad is our error
we're going to use the mean squared
value for our error and the atom
optimizer for its differential equations
you don't have to know the math behind
them but certainly it helps to know what
they're doing and where they fit into
the bigger models and then finally we're
going to do our fit fitting the rn into
the training set we have the
regressor.fit xtrain y train epochs and
batch size so we know where this is this
is our data coming in for the x train
our y train is the answer we're looking
for of our data our sequential input
epics is how many times we're going to
go over the whole data set we created a
whole data set of x trains so this is
each each of those rows which includes a
time sequence of 60. and bad size
another one of those things where cross
really shines is if you were pulling
this save from a large file instead of
trying to load it all into ram it can
now pick smaller batches up and load
those indirectly we're not worried about
pulling them off a file today because
this isn't big enough to cause a
computer too much of a problem to run
not too straining on the resources but
as we run this you can imagine what
happened if i was doing a lot more than
just one column in one set of stock in
this case google stock imagine if i was
doing this across all the stocks and i
had instead of just the open i had open
close high low and you can actually find
yourself with about 13 different
variables times 60 because there's a
time sequence suddenly you find yourself
with a gig of memory you're loading into
your ram which will just completely you
know if it's just if you're not on
multiple computers or cluster you can
start running into resource problems but
for this we don't have to worry about
that so let's go ahead and run this and
this will actually take a little bit on
my computer because it's an older laptop
and give it a second to kick in there
there we go all right so we have epic so
this is going to tell me it's running
the first run through all the data and
as it's going through it's batching them
in 32 pieces so 32 lines each time and
there's 1198 i think i said 11.99
earlier but it's 11.98 i was off by one
and each one of these is 13 seconds so
you can imagine this is roughly 20 to 30
minutes run time on this computer like i
said it's an older laptop running at 0.9
gigahertz on a dual processor and that's
fine what we'll do is i'll go ahead and
stop go get a drink of coffee and come
back and let's see what happens at the
end and where this takes us and like any
good cooking show
i've kind of gotten my latte i also have
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you can scroll through you can see
we've run it through 100 steps or 100
epics so the question is what does all
this mean one of the first things you'll
notice is that our loss can is over here
it kind of stopped at 0.0014 but you can
see it kind of goes down until we hit
about .014 three times in a row so we
guessed our epic pretty close since our
losses remain the same on there so to
find out we're looking at we're going to
go ahead and load up our test data the
test data that we didn't process yet and
a real stock price data set test eye
location this is the same thing we did
when we prepped the data in the first
place so let's go ahead and go through
this code and we can see we've labeled
it part three making the predictions and
visualizing the results so the first
thing that we need to do is go ahead and
read the data in from our test csv you
see i've changed the path on it for my
computer and then we'll call it the real
stock price and again we're doing just
the one column here and the values from
ilocation so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this should all look
familiar because this is the same thing
we did before we're going to take our
data set total we're going to do a
little panda concat from the datastate
train now remember the end of the data
set train is part of the data going in
let's just visualize that just a little
bit here's our train data let me just
put tr for train and it went up to this
value here but each one of these values
generated a bunch of columns it was 60
across and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and this value here equals this one and
so we need these top 60 to go into our
new data so to find out what we're
looking at we're going to go ahead and
load up our test data the test data that
we didn't process yet and a real stock
price data set test eye location this is
the same thing we did when we prep the
data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test csv you see i've changed
the path on it for my computer and then
we'll call it the real stock price and
again we're doing just the one column
here and the values from i location so
it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open stock open let's go ahead and run
that so that's loaded in there and then
let's go ahead and create we have our
inputs we're going to create inputs here
and this should all look familiar
because this is the same thing we did
before we're going to take our data set
total we're going to do a little panda
concat from the data state train now
remember the end of the data set train
is part of the data going in let's just
visualize that just a little bit here's
our train data let me just put tr for
train and it went up to this value here
but each one of these values generated a
bunch of columns it was 60 across and
this value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and so we
need these top 60 to go into our new
data because that's part of the next
data or it's actually the top 59. so
that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test.test location so
we're just looking at that first column
the open price and then our data set
total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take our data set train for the open and
our data set test open and this is one
way you can reference these columns
we've referenced them a couple different
ways we've referenced them up here with
the one two but we know it's labeled as
a panda set as open so pandas is great
that way lots of versatility there and
we'll go ahead and go back up here and
run this there we go and you'll notice
this is the same as what we did before
we have our open data set where pended
our two different or concatenated our
two data sets together we have our
inputs equals data set total length data
set total minus length data set minus
test minus 60 values so we're going to
run this over all of them and you'll see
why this works because normally when
you're running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that we didn't train
it with to see how well it graphs and we
have our inputs equals inputs dot
reshapes or reshaping like we did before
we're transforming our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between 0
and 1 and finally we want to go ahead
and take our x test and we're going to
create that x test and for i in range 60
to 80. so here's our x test and we're
appending our inputs i to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and i comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the first column
which is our open column and once again
we take our x test we convert it to a
numpy array we do the same reshape we
did before and then we get down to the
final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor dot predicts x test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want to take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put them
between zero and one well that's not
going to mean very much to me to look at
a float number between 0 1 i want the
dollar amount so i want to know what the
cash value is and we'll go ahead and run
this and you'll see it runs much quicker
than the training that's what's so
wonderful about these neural networks
once you put them together it takes just
a second to run the same neural network
that took us what a half hour to train
ahead and plot the data we're going to
plot what we think it's going to be and
we're going to plot it against the real
data what the google stock actually did
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that in code and let's uh pull this code
up so we have our plt that's our oh if
you remember from the very beginning let
me just go back up to the top we have
our matplot library.pi plot as plt
that's where that comes in and we come
down here we're going to plot let me get
my drawing thing out again we're going
to go ahead and plt is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always threw me when i'm doing
graphs in python because i always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real google stock
price and then we're gonna do our
predicted stock and we're gonna do it in
blue and it's gonna be labeled predicted
and we'll give it a title cause it's
always nice to give a title to your uh
graph especially if you're gonna present
this to somebody you know to your
shareholders in the office and the x
label is going to be time because it's a
time series and we didn't actually put
the actual date and times on here but
that's fine we just know they're
incremented by time and then of course
the y label is the actual stock price
plt.legend tells us to build the legend
on here so that the color red and real
google stock price show up on there and
then the plot shows us that actual graph
so let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our legend i
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and
plotted the x since we know what the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know that it's only the last
piece of data that we're looking at so
last piece of data which in somewhere
probably around here on the graph i
think it's like about twenty percent of
the data probably less than that we have
the google price and the google price
has this little up jump and then down
and you'll see that the actual google
instead of uh a turn down here just
didn't go up as high and didn't go
down so our prediction has the same
pattern but the overall value is pretty
far off as far as um stock but then
again we're only looking at one column
we're only looking at the open price
we're not looking at how many volumes
were traded like i was pointing out
earlier we talk about stock just right
off the bat there's six columns there's
open high low close volume then there's
weather i mean volume shares then
there's the adjusted open adjusted high
adjusted low adjusted close they have a
special formula to predict exactly what
it would really be worth based on the
value of the stock and then from there
there's all kinds of other stuff you can
put in here so we're only looking at one
small aspect the opening price of the
stock and as you can see here we did a
pretty good job this curve follows the
curve pretty well it has like a little
jumps on it bins they don't quite match
up so this bin here does not quite match
up with that bin there but it's pretty
darn close we have the basic shape of it
and the prediction isn't too far off and
you can imagine that as we add more data
in and look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if i was running it across all
those different variables it might take
a little bit longer to train the data
not so good for doing a quick tutorial
like this so we're going to dive right
into what is cross we'll also go all the
way through this into a couple of
tutorials because that's where you
really learn a lot is when you roll up
your sleeves so we talk about what is
cross cross is a high level deep
learning api written in python for easy
implement implementation of neural
networks it uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
etc is back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different
neural networks
is really powerful it's really powerful
to
have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a backend for fast
computation
while providing a user friendly and easy
to learn front-end
and you can see here we have the cross
api specifications and under that you'd
have like tf cross for tensorflow thano
cross and so on and then you have your
tensorflow workflow that this is all
sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it
so the working principle of cross
uh the working principle of keras is
cross uses computational graphs to
express and evaluate mathematical
expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators
where we have like the percentage or in
this case in python that's usually your
left your remainder or multiplication
you might have the operator of x to the
power of 0.3 and it uses useful for
calculating derivatives by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without really having not banging your
head and having to hand write everything
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
and for solving complex problems specify
input and outputs and make sure all
nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look across models across model we
have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer and it's useful for
simple classifier decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is
we have a layer that's dense your layer
one
as an activation now they're using the
relu in this particular example and then
you have your name layer one layer dense
relu name layer two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model and
this is really where things are at this
is new make sure you update your cross
or you'll find yourself running this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on
you have two different inputs
and one way you could think of this is
maybe one of those is a small image and
one of those is a full sized image
and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into one note because it's
looking for one thing
and then only into one note for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup we have multiple information
coming in but the information is very
different even though it overlaps and
you don't want to send it through the
same neural network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the data and
how you fork the models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in
we have our image inputs which is a 32
by 32 by three or three channels or four
if you're having an alpha channel uh you
have your dense your layers dense is 64
activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
uh so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at cross
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks
but it's always good to get on the same
page and for those people who don't
fully understand neural networks to dive
into them a little bit or do a quick
overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models
they're kind of uh when you first start
using them they're like a black box you
put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was and you have to pre-process
that data because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with keras the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with covid
uh what's going to happen on there and
we're going to go ahead and do an
example of that in our
live hands on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands-on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and
open that up and open up a jupyter
notebook for doing the python code in
now if you're not familiar with those
you can use pretty much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and showing people especially
shareholders it really helps because
it's a nice visual so let me go and flip
over to our anacon and the anaconda has
a lot of cool two tools they just added
data lore and ibm watson studio cloud
into the anaconda framework
but we'll be in the jupiter lab or
jupiter notebook i'm going to do a
jupiter notebook for this because i use
the lab for like large projects with
multiple pieces because it has multiple
tabs where the notebook will work fine
for what we're doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how jupiter helps our
jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new python 3 and it creates an
untitled python we'll go ahead and give
this a title and we'll just call this a
cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
i mentioned sklearn or your site kit if
you're installing sklearn the sklearn
stuff it's a
scikit you want to look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 of participants are under 65
experienced no side effects well 95 of
participants over 65
experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more complicated
information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup
uh so we want to do for i and range and
we want to go ahead and create if you
look here we have random integers
trading the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if i mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from simplylearn they'll send you a copy
of this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples of pin
[Music]
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on that had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on
a standard distribution error
and so what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it since that was the baseline
i was looking for in this we're just
doing
generating random data for our setup on
here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do train
samples
and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that
um let's see 50 up here one thousand
yeah so there's one thousand here one
thousand numbers we generated and we
could also if we wanted to find that out
we could do a quick uh print the length
of it
and
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
and let's change this to
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
wanna go ahead and take our train labels
and we'll convert it into a numpy array
and the same thing with our samples and
let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle
this is just a neat feature you can do
in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
uh so we have our so it just randomizes
it that's all that's doing
um we've already randomized it so it's
kind of an overkill it's not really
necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow and you
want to randomize it just to make sure
that that you know the input doesn't
follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
then we go ahead and scale the uh scaled
train samples so we're gonna go ahead
and fit and transform the data uh so
it's nice and scaled
and that is the age uh so you can see up
here we have 49 85 41. we're just moving
that so it's going to be between zero
and one and so this is true with any of
your neural networks
you really want to convert the data
to zero and one otherwise you create a
bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in jupiter notebook is that if you have
a variable you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line
it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here and so it's
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195
0.791 so everything's between 0 and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print ups halfway through you never
know what's going to go on there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data sent to
me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
uh
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defactos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
so when you see the tensorflow setup
it it's got like a huge following there
are some other setups like
the scikit under the sk learn has their
own little neural network but the
tensorflow is the most robust one out
there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
uh and then we have the rest of this is
all cross here from number two down
uh
we're gonna import from tensorflow the
cross connection
and then you have your tensorflow cross
models import sequential it's a specific
kind of model we'll look at that in just
a second if you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
and then we have from tensorflow cross
layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom um
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize uh your data when you first
do it atoms as good as any atom is
usually there's a number of optimizer
out there there's about there's a couple
main ones but atom is usually assigned
to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day you know
at the end of the story how good does
your model do and we'll go ahead and
load all that and then comes the fun
part
i actually like to spend hours messing
with these things
and
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when i say spend hours on four
lines of code uh what we have here i'm
going to explain that in just a second
we have a model and it's a sequential
model if you remember correctly we
mentioned the sequential up here
where it goes from one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be your
input
it's going to be what they call dense
which is
usually just dense and then you have
your input and your activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape what's the activation
and this is where it gets interesting
because we have in here
uh relu
on two of these and softmax activation
on one of these there are so many
different options
for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just
almost like you're playing with it like
an artist you start getting a fill for
like a
inverse tangent activation or the 10h
activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing word documents and
you're tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
you'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting um
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
rayleigh it lets me do this
rayleigh there we go relu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero and then it goes up
and then you might have what they call
lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with softmax it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like is you build
your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting
design setup oops i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept of build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do
uh
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out the quality
of your setup on there and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go it was right above me there we go
we start doing your cross entropy and
stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run
it you can then test your model out and
say hey it's either this model works
better than this model and this is why
and then you can start swapping in these
models and so when i say spend a huge
amount of time on pre-processing data is
probably 80 percent of your programming
time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
uh here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read
so once we have our model built the next
thing we're going to want to do is we're
going to go ahead and train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here
this a lot of times it's just paired
with the model because it's so
straightforward
it's nice to
print out the model setup so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of um
the setup is your learning rate uh so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate is set
to 0.00
set to 0.01
depending on what you're doing
this learning rate
can over fit and underfit
so you'd want to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and under fitting that
are really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy so this
is going to tell kuros how far to go
until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
uh batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and
put a verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
um here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss let's
see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss uh so it's looking at
the sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much
how much does the
error go down
is the best way to look at that and you
can see here the lower the number the
better it just keeps going down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to one
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance
you can have 100 accuracy and your model
doesn't work because it's over fitted
again you won't look up overfitting and
under fitting models
and we went ahead and went through uh 30
epics it's always fun to kind of watch
your code going
um to be honest i
usually uh
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i'd like to just not see that
and you can repress those of course in
your code
repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here and this is just what we did
above there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the the data is going to
be across the same thing but this should
just be just transformed down here
instead of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data
on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
um you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict
and we're going to do here's our x scale
data batch size 10 verbose
and now we have our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do a
oh we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
what is what we think it's going to be
but what we think is going to they're
going to have
symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really want a
yes no answer
so we'll go ahead and just round off the
predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max for prediction so it
just goes to 0 1
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrix is for accuracy check
um
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the scikit
the sk learn metrics
site kit being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice matte plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it cm
for confusion matrix y true equals test
labels why predict rounded predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there
but we do have here is we're going to do
a plot confusion matrix there's our cm
our classes normalize false title
confusion matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh to the
nearest c map titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders
you don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the
definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195
had side effects 200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted the 10 of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is
uh divide these both by by two and you
get five out of a hundred uh you can do
the same kind of math up here
not as quick on the flags it's 15 and
195 not an easily rounded number but you
can see here where they have 15 people
who predicted to have no
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a
i spent a lot of time on some of the
parts but you can see here is really
simple
we did the random generation of data but
when we actually built the model coming
up here
here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we can get a lot more complicated
let me flip back on over here because
we're going to do another uh demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with keras after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it
learn on training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
uh and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
and put that information in here and it
goes through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications
as well as correct classifications to
get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout of our
confusion matrix
with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative
and so the blue ones
we want those to be the biggest numbers
because those are the better side and
then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now
saving and loading models with cross
we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you're going to say oh that was a
lot of complication before well if you
broke it down we randomized some data we
created the
cross setup we compiled it we trained it
we predicted and we ran our matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a lot a little bit more fun is we're
going to do a face mask detection with
cross so we're going to build a cross
model to check if a person is wearing a
mask or not in real time and this might
be important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own and this is just such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here
so before i dive into the mass detection
talk about being in the current with
covid and seeing if people are wearing
masks
this particular example i had to go
ahead and update to a python 3.8 version
it might run in a 3.7 i'm not sure i
haven't i kind of skipped three seven
and installed three eight
uh so i'll be running in a three python
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the
they call functional
layers with that's where they split if
you remember correctly from back
let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes
multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
um end-to-end development of a product
here uh of course this is a very
simplified version and it'd be a lot
more to it you'd also have to do like
recognizing whether it's someone's face
or not all kinds of other things go into
this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code and we'll open up a new python
three oops python three
it's working on it there we go
and then we want to go ahead and train
our mask we'll just call this train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's it's uh
save mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them
so we have in here
alt d there we go
have something to draw with a little bit
here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images are like a
square grid and then each value in there
has three values for the three different
colors
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of
working with that so you don't have to
do all the heavy listening and figuring
out what's going to go on
uh and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them uh dropout's a cool thing
worth looking up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow
uh it'll auto drop out certain nodes
that way you'll get a better
the notes just kind of die and they find
that they actually create more of a bias
and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a one
dimensional array instead of a two by
two by three
uh dense input we did that in the other
one so that should look a little
familiar
oops there we go our input our model
again these are things we had on the
last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing the data
in
more pre-processing with image to array
loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you you're
not doing a lot of pre-processing you're
letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category 0 1 doesn't really
mean anything it's like true false
label binarizer the same thing uh we're
changing our labels around and then
there's our train test split
classification report
our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit set up in tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in
this software especially the second
piece when we reload up the data and
hook it up to a video camera we're going
to do that on this round
but this is part of the opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
and resize them and then the matplot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epics to train for and the batch size
and if you remember correctly we talked
about the learning rate
to the negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor
with 16 dedicated threads only one
thread is running on this no matter what
so it doesn't matter
so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with the data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and then you have pictures with mass
they're just images of people with mass
on their face
uh and then we have the opposite let me
go back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh setup on there so
they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options and we're just going to
load into that we're going to append the
image itself and the labels so we'll
just create a huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point
thankfully i have a
gig hard drive or
ram
even that
you could do with a lot less of that
probably under 16 or even eight gigs
would easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert
the size of the image so it resizes all
the images that way our data is all
identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go
just so we can see where the other side
looks like we now have one that means
they have a mask one zero one zero so on
uh one being they have a mask and zero
no mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
zero one
so zero
is uh do they have a mask on zero do
they not have a mask on
one so this is the same as what we saw
up here without mask one equals
um the second value is without mass so
with mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
uh
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual
linear value or regression values
they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our train x test x train y test y
train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20 of
it for testing and the rest for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean well if i rotate
the data around and i zoom in i zoom out
i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as they do all these different
things to the data it
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples i have
so if i have all these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool thing and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
uh so that you can better train your
model and so we go and run this and then
we're gonna load
and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
i haven't run it myself because the guys
in the back did this
we take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net v2
and this we this is a big thing right
here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row
so we want to make sure that that is not
the case
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the
size of the pictures and the weights for
input shape
so they'll switch things to defaults to
saying hey we're going to auto shape
some of this stuff for you you should be
aware that with this kind of imaging
we're already augmenting it by moving it
around and flipping it and doing all
kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flatten
so we're flattening the data
uh so this is all
processing and flattening the images and
the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dense just
what you think about and then the head
model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a drop out
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from performing so it's
really a cool feature in here they
discovered this a while back
we have another dense mode this time
we're using soft max activation
lots of different activation options
here soft is a real popular one for a
lot of things
and so was the relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas
and why what their different uses are
and how they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them uh just because they're
some of the basic setups it's a good
place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i
i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and
specifically in stock data i wanted to
iterate through the first set of 30 data
before it does anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics
and we go ahead and compile our loss is
going to be the binary cross entropy
which we'll have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model
so train the head of the network print
info training head run
now i skipped a little time because
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're well it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so
anytime the train x and trading y go in
there's some randomness going on there
and it's jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
uh of course we're batch sizing it so
it's going through whatever we set for
the batch values how many we process at
a time and then we have the steps per
epic
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
and this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is
our
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your
testing
you know you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
uh has a bias and it's overfitted so
that's what this is really about right
here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at 2 because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x
to see what it thinks are going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either 0 or 1 it's a
0 1 0 1 so you have two outputs not
wearing wearing a mask not wearing a
mask and so we need to go ahead and take
that argument at the end and change
those predictions to a
zero or one coming out
and then
to finish that off we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot we want to
show a nicely formatted classification
report so we can see what that looks
like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97 with a mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mass 97 percent
um so that's pretty high
set up on there you know you three
people are going to sneak into the store
who
are without a mask and
thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store
um so there you have it and of course
one of the other cool things about this
is if someone's walking in to the store
and you take multiple pictures of them
um
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool i love doing this stuff uh so we're
gonna go ahead and take our model and
we're gonna save it
so model save massdetector.model we're
going to give it a name
we're going to save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
saved the model they upload the model
now they can
use it for whatever and then if i get
more information
and we start working with that at some
point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
uh here we have a nice graph you can see
the training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the
psy kit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence is our
loss and our accuracy come together and
also up here and this is why i'd run it
more than just two epochs as you can see
they still haven't converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new
python3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
uh we have our
mobilenet v2 import pre-processing input
so we're still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load model that's
where most of stuff is going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little opencv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is part of
the opencv or cv2 setup
uh and then we have of course time and
just our operating system so those are
the things we're going to go ahead and
set up on here and then we're going to
create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
so we're going to detect and predict the
mask we have frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have our frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know what we're going to be
processing through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
uh so these is this is what's going on
here this is that model we just created
we're going to send that in there and
i'll show you in a second where that is
but it's going to be under face net
and then we go ahead and initialize our
list of faces their corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mask network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
what happens if you have a crowd of
faces
so we're looping through the detections
and the shapes going through here
and probability associated with the
detection here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said it remember zero to one so
0.5 would be our minimum confidence
probably is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open cv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simplylearn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
so we create a box around what's going
to what we hope is going to be the face
extract the face roi convert it from bgr
to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times
i've forgotten to check the order colors
when working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red uh and we're gonna
go ahead and resize it process it frame
it uh face frame
setup again the face the cbt color we're
gonna convert it
we're gonna resize it
image to array pre-process the input
uh pin the face locate face start x dot
y and x
boy that was just a huge amount and i
skipped over a ton of it but the bottom
line is we're building a box around the
face and that box because the open cv
does a decent job of finding the face
and that box is going to go in there and
see hey does this person have a mask on
it
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32
so these different images where we're
guessing where the face is are then
going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously you're going to put
it in a different
path depending on where you have it or
however you want to do it and how you
saved it on the last one where we
trained it
and then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals cb2.dnn.readnet
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling on all the different pieces
we need for our model
and then the next part
is we're going to create open up our
video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
the video setup
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
so we're going to go ahead and open up
our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're
done and this is where we get some real
like kind of live action stuff which is
fun this is what i like working about
with images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like right
there in front of you it's visual and
you can see what's going on
so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
uh that means it's grabbing my main
camera i have hooked up um
and then you know starting video you're
gonna print it out here's our video
source equals zero start
loop over the frames from the video
stream
oops a little redundancy there um let me
close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
from our visual stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we returned from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame we're sending
it the face net and the mast net so
we're sending all the different pieces
that say this is what's going through on
here
and then it returns our location and
predictions and then for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
in predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask l0 225 and you know it's
going to make a lot more sense when i
hit the run button here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cv2 i am
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until
we hit the stop button pretty much
so are you ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our
our model we've loaded it up into our
distributed uh code here we've got it
hooked into our camera and we're going
to go ahead and run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky headset on
uh
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you can start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you have this really neat uh setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or a public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see that the model
works we actually have this working
model that hooks into
the video camera
which is just pretty cool and a lot of
fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic uh
demo up above for just pulling in across
and then we went into a cross model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application
and we're going to take a look at image
classification using cross and the basic
setup and we'll actually look at two
different demos on here
what's in it for you today
what is image classification
intel image classification data
creating neural networks with keras and
the vgg16 model
what is image classification
the process of image classification
refers to assigning classes to an entire
image images can be classified based on
different categories like weather
it is a night time or daytime shot what
the image represents etc you can see
here we have mountains looking for
mountains why should we doing some
pictures of scenery and stuff like that
in deep learning we perform image
classification by using neural networks
to extract features from images and
classifies them based on these features
and you can see here where it says like
what computer sees and it says oh yeah
we see mostly forests maybe a little bit
of mountains because the way the image
is
and this is really where
one of the areas that neural networks
really shines
if you try to run this stuff through
more like a linear regression model
you'll still get results but the results
kind of miss a lot of things as the
neural networks get better and better at
what they do with different tools we
have out there
so intel image classification data
the data being used is the intel image
classification data set which consists
of images of six types of land areas
and so we have forest building glaciers
and mountains sea and street
and you can see here there's a couple of
the images out of there as a setup in
the
intel image classification data that
they use
and then we're going to go into creating
a neural networks with keras
the convolutional neural network that we
are creating from scratch looks
as shown below
you'll see here we have our input layer
um
they haven't listed max pooling so you
have
as you're coming in with the input layer
and this the input layer is actually
before this but the first layer that
it's going to go into is going to be a
convolutional neural network
then you have a max pooling that pulls
those the the convolutional neural
networks returns
in this case they have two of those that
is very standard with convolutional
neural networks uh one of the ones that
i was looking at earlier that was
standard being used by um
one of the larger companies i can't
remember which one for doing a large
amount of identification had two
convolutional neural networks each with
their max pooling and then about 17
dense layers after it we're not going to
do that heavy duty of a of a code but
we'll get you head in the right
direction and that gives you an idea of
what you're actually going to be looking
at when you look at the flattened part
and then the dents we're talking like 17
dense layers afterwards
i find that a lot of the stuff i've been
working on i end up maxing it out right
around nine dense layers it really
depends on what you have going in and
what you're working with
and the vgg16 model
vgg16 is a pre-trained cnn model which
is used for image classification
it is trained on a large varied data set
and fine-tuned to fit image
classification data sets with ease
and you can see down here we have the
input coming in
the convolutional neural network one to
one one to two and then pooling and then
we do two to one two to two
convolutional network then pooling three
to two and you can see there's just this
huge layering of convolutional neural
networks and in this case they have five
such layers going in and then three
dents going out or uh more
now when they
took this setup this actually won an
award back in 2019 for this particular
setup
and it does it does really good except
that again
we only show the three dense layers here
and as you find out
depending on your data going in what you
have set up
that really isn't enough on one of these
setups and i'm going to show you why we
restricted it because it does take up a
lot of processing power in some of these
things
so let's go ahead and roll up our
sleeves and we're going to look at both
the setups we're going to start with the
the first
classification and then we'll go into
the vgg16 and show you how that's set up
now i'm going to be using anaconda and
let me flip over to my anaconda so you
can see what that looks like
now i'm running in the anaconda here
you'll see that i've set up a main
python
3 8. i always put that in there this is
where i'm doing like most of my kind of
playing around
this is done in python version 3.8 we're
not going to dig too much into versions
at this point you should already have
cross installed on there usually cross
takes a number of extra steps
and then our usual
setup is the numpy the pandas
your sk your scikit which is going to be
the sk learn your seaborn and i'll show
you those in just a minute
and then i'm just going to be in the
jupiter lab where i've created a new
notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook
now there's a couple of cool things to
note in here is that
one i use the the
anaconda jupiter notebook setup
because it keeps everything separate
except for cross
cross is actually running separately in
the back i believe it's a c program
what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multiprocessors on the
computer and i'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the code
and when we look in here a couple things
to note is here's our uh
oops i thought i'd grab the other
drawing thing uh but here's our numpy
and our pandas right here and our
operating system this is our sai kit you
always import it as sklearn for the
classification report
uh we're going to be using well usually
import like seaborn brings in all of
your pie plot library also
kind of nice to throw that in there i
can't remember if we're actually using
seaborne if they just the people in the
back just threw that together
and then we have the sklearn shuffle for
shuffling data here's our matplot
library that the seaborn is pretty much
built on
cv2
if you're not familiar with that that is
our image
module for importing the image
and then of course we have our
tensorflow down here which is what we're
really working with
and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
if you're doing a demo and you're
working with the partners or the
shareholders
this tqdm is really kind of cool it's an
extensible progress bar for python and
i'll show you that too
remember data science is not i mean
muscle's code when i'm looking through
this code i'm not going to show half of
this stuff to the shareholders or
anybody i'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works
uh so we need to go ahead and import
those different
setup on there and then the next thing
is we're going to go ahead and set up
our classes
now we remember if we had mountain
street glacier building c and forest
those were the different images that we
have coming in
and we're going to go ahead and just do
class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of i for i
class name
equals the class names so our labels are
going to match the names up here
and then we have the number of classes
and the print the class names and the
labels and we'll go ahead and set the
image size this is important that we
resize everything because if you
remember with neural networks
they take one size data coming in and so
when you're working with images you
really want to make sure they're all
resized to the same setup it might
squish them it might stretch them that
generally does not cause a problem in
these uh in some of the other tricks you
can do with
if you if you need more data
and this is one that's used regularly
we're not going to do it in here is you
can also take these images and not only
resize them but you can tilt them one
way or the other crop parts of them
so they process slightly differently and
they'll actually increase your accuracy
of some of these predictions
and so you see here we have mountain
equals zero that's what this class name
label is street equals 1 glacier equals
2 buildings equals 3 c4 4s equals 5.
now we did this as an enumerator so each
one is 0 through 5.
a lot of times we do this instead as
0 1 0 1 0 1 so you have five outputs and
each one's a zero or a one coming out
so the next thing we really want to do
is we want to go ahead and load the data
up
and just put a label in there loading
data
just just so you know what we're doing
i'm going to put in the loading data
down here
make sure it's well labeled
and we'll create a definition for this
and this is all part of your
pre-processing
at this point you could replace this
with all kinds of different things
depending on what you're working on
and if you once you download you can go
download this data set uh send a note to
the simply learn team here in youtube um
and they'll be happy to direct you in
the right direction and make sure you
get this path here um so you have the
right whatever wherever you saved it a
lot of times i'll just abbreviate the
path or put it as a sub thing and just
get rid of the directory
but again double check your paths
we're going to separate this into a
segment for training
and a segment for testing and that's
actually how it is in the folder let me
just show you what that looks like
so when i have my lengthy path here
where i keep all my programming simply
learn this particular setup we're
working on image classification
and image classification
clearly you probably wouldn't have that
lengthy of a list
and when we go in here
you'll see sequence train sequence test
they've already split this up this is
what we're going to train the data in
and again you can see buildings 4th
glacier mountain c street
and if we double click let's go under
forest
you can see all these different forest
images and there's a lot of variety here
i mean we have winter time we have
summer time
so it's kind of interesting
you know here's like a fallen tree
versus a road going down the middle
that's really hard to train and if you
look at the buildings
a lot of these buildings are looking up
a skyscraper we're looking down the
setup
here's some trees with one and i want to
highlight this one it has trees in it ah
let me just open that up so you can see
it a little closer
the reason i want to highlight this is i
want you to think about this
we have trees growing is this the city
or a forest
so this kind of imagery makes it really
hard for a classifier and if you start
looking at these you'll see a lot of
these images do have trees and other
things in the foreground weird angles
really a hard thing for a computer to
sort out and figure out whether it's
going to be a forest or a city
and so in our loading of data uh one we
have to have the path the directory
we're going to come in here we have our
images and our labels
so we're going to load the images in one
section the labels in another
and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders
in fact let me do this let me
there we go
uh as we look at this we're just going
to loop through the three to the six
different folders that have the
different landscapes and then we're
going to go through and pull each file
out
and each label
so we set the label we set the folder
for file and list
here's our image path
join the paths this is all kind of
general stuff
so i'm kind of skipping through it
really quick
and here's our image setup if you
remember we're talking about the images
we have our cv2 reader so it reads the
image in
it's going to go ahead and take the
image and convert it to from
blue green red to red green green blue
this is a cv2 thing almost all the time
it imports it and instead of importing
it as a standard that's used just about
everywhere it imports it with the bgr
versus rgb
rgb is pretty much a standard in here
you have to remember that with cv2
and then we're going to go ahead and
resize it this is the important part
right here we've said it we've decided
what the size is and we want to make
sure all the images have the same size
on them
and then we just take our images and
we're just going to pin the image pin
the label
and then the images it's going to turn
into a numpy array this just makes it
easier to process and manipulate
and then the labels is also a numpy
array and then we just return the output
append images and labels and we return
the output down here
so we've loaded these all into memory uh
we haven't talked too much
there'd be a different setup in there
because there is ways to feed the files
directly into your cross model
but we want to go ahead and just load
them all because
really
for today's processing and what our
computers can handle that's not a big
deal
and then we go ahead and set the train
images train labels test images test
labels and that's going to be returned
in our output append and you can see
here we did
images and labels set up in there and it
just loads them in there so we'll have
these four different categories let me
just go ahead and run that
so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on there
and then if you remember from before uh
we imported let me just go back up there
shuffle here we go here's our sk learn
utilities import shuffle
and so we want to take these labels and
shuffle them around a little bit
just mix them up so it's not having the
same if you run the same process over
and over
uh then you might run into some problems
on there
and just real quick let's go ahead and
do
a plot so we can just you know we've
looked at them as far as from outside of
our code we pulled up the files and i
showed you
what that was going on we can go ahead
and just display them here too
and i tell you when you're working with
different people
this should be highlighted right here
this thing is like when i'm working on
code and i'm looking at this data and
i'm trying to figure out what i'm doing
i skip this process
the second i get into a meeting and i'm
showing what's going on to other people
i skip everything we just did
so
and go right to here where we want to go
ahead and display some images and take a
look at it
and in this display
i've taken them and i've resized the
images to 20 by 20.
that's pretty small
so we're going to lose just a massive
amount of detail
and you can see here these nice
pixelated images i might even just stick
with the folder showing them what images
were processing
again this is
yeah be a little careful this
maybe resizing it was a bad idea
in fact let me try it without resizing
and see what happens oops so i took out
the image size and then we put this
straight in here
one of the things again this is
put the d there we go one of the things
again that we want to know
whenever we're working on these things
uh is the cv2
there are so many different
uh image classification setups it's
really a powerful package when you're
doing images but you do need to switch
it around so that it works with the pie
plot and so make sure you take your
numpy array and change it to a u integer
8 format because it comes in as a float
otherwise you'll get some weird images
down there
and so this is just basically we've
split up our we've created a plot
we went ahead and did the plot 20 by 20
um or
the plot figure size is 20 by 20
and then we're doing 25 so a 5x5 subplot
nothing really going on here too
exciting but you can see here where we
get the images and
really when you're showing people what's
going on this is what they want to see
so you skip over all the code and you
have your meeting you say okay here's
our images of the building
don't get caught up in how much work you
do get caught up in what they want to
see so if you want to work in data
science that's really important to know
and this is where we're going to start
having fun
here's our model this is where it gets
exciting
when you're digging into these models
and you have here
let me get
there we go
when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
2d
and
2d is an image you have two different
dimensions x y and even though there's
three colors it's still considered 2d
if you're running a video you'd be
convolutional neural network 3d
if you're doing a series going across
a time series it might be 1d
and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional neural network
if you look here there's a lot of really
cool settings going on
to dig into
we have our input shape so everything's
been set to 150 by 150
and it has of course three different
color schemes in it that's important to
notice
activation
default is relu this is
small amounts of data are being
processed on a bunch of little
neural networks
and right here is the 32 that's how many
of these convolutional null networks are
being strung up on here
and then the three by three
uh when it's doing its steps it's
actually looking at a little three by
three square on each image
and so that's what's going on here and
with convolutional neural networks the
window floats across
and adds up all these numbers going
across on this data and then eventually
it comes up with 30 in this case 32
different
feature options that it's looking for
and of course you can change that 32 you
can change the three by three so you
might have a larger setup you know if
you're going across 150
by 150 that's a lot of steps so we might
run this as 15 by 15.
there's all kinds of different things
you can do here
we're just putting this together again
that would be something you would play
with to find out which ones are going to
work better on this setup
and there's a lot of play involved
that's really where it becomes an art
form is guessing at what that's going to
be
the second part i mentioned earlier and
i can only begin to highlight this
when you get to these dense layers
one is the activation is a relu they use
a relu and a soft max here
it's a whole a whole setup just
explaining why these are different
and how they're different because
there's also an exponential there's a
tangent in fact
there's just a ton of these and you can
build your own custom activations
depending on what you're doing
a lot of different things go into these
activations
there are two or three major thoughts on
these activations and
rayleigh and soft max are
well relu
you're really looking at just the number
you're adding all the numbers together
and you're looking at euclidean geometry
ax plus b
x 2 plus c x 3
plus a bias
with soft max this belongs to the party
of um
it's activated or it's not except it's
they call it soft max because when you
get the the to zero instead of it just
being zero
uh it's actually slightly
a little bit less than zero so that when
it trains it doesn't get lost
there's a whole series of these
activations
another activation is the tangent
um
where it just drops off and you have
like a very narrow area where you have
from minus one to one or exponential
which is zero to one
so there's a lot of different ways to do
the activation
again we can do that would be a whole
separate lesson on here
we're looking at the convolutional
neural network
and we're doing the two pools
this is so common you'll see two two
convolutional neural networks stacked on
top of each other
each with its own max pool underneath
let's go ahead and run that so we built
our model there and then we need to go
ahead and
compile the model so let's go ahead and
do that
uh we're gonna use the atom uh optimizer
the bigger the data the atom fits better
on there there's some other optimizer
but i think atom is a default
um i don't really play with the
optimizer too much that's like the if
once you get a model that works really
good you might try some different
optimizers atoms usually the most and
then we're looking at loss
pretty standard we want to minimize our
lot we want
to maximize the loss of error
and then we're going to look at accuracy
everybody likes to say accuracy i'm
going to tell you right now
i start talking to people and i'm like
okay what's what's the loss on this and
that and as a data science yeah i want
to know how the lot what's going on with
that we'll show you why in a minute
but everybody wants to see accuracy we
want to know how accurate this is
and then we're going to run the fit and
i wanted to do this just so i can show
you
even though we're in a python
setup in here where jupyter notebook is
using only a single processor i'm going
to bring over my little cpu tool
this is eight cores on 16 dedicated
threats so it shows up as 16 processors
and actually i got to run this and then
move it over
so we're going to run this
and hopefully it doesn't destroy my mic
and as it comes in you can see it's
starting to do go through the epics and
we said i set it for five epics
and then this is really nice because
cross uses all the different uh threads
available
so it does a really good job of doing
that
this is going to take a while if you
look at here it's uh
eta
2 minutes and 25 seconds 24 seconds so
this is roughly two and a half minutes
per epic
and we're doing five epics
so this is going to be done in roughly
15 minutes
i don't know about you but i don't think
you want to sit here for 15 minutes
watching the green bars go across so
we'll go ahead and let that run
and there we go
there was our 15 minutes it's actually
less than that
because i did when i went in here
realized that
where was it
here we go here's our model compile
here's our model flip uh fit
and here's our epics uh so i did four
epics
so a little bit better a little more
like 10 to 11 minutes instead of uh
doing the full
15. and
when we look at this here's our model we
did we talked about the compiler uh
here's our history we're going to click
history equals the model fit
we'll go into that in just a minute
and what we're looking at is we have our
epics
here's our validation split
so as we train it
we're weighing the accuracy versus
you kind of pull some data off to the
side
while you're training it
and the reason we do that is that
you don't want to overfit
and i'll we'll look at that chart in
just a minute
uh here's batch size
this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time
the larger the batch it actually
increases the processing speed um and
there's reasons to go up or down on the
batch size because of the
the the smaller the batch
there's a certain point where
you get too large of a batch and it's
trying to fit everything at once uh
so i yeah 128 is kind of big
depends on the computer you're on what
it can handle
and then of course we have our train
images and our train labels going in
telling it what we're going to train on
and then we look at our four epochs here
here's our accuracy we want the accuracy
to go up and we get all the way up to
0.83
or 83 percent now this is actual
percentage based pretty much
and we can see over here our loss we
want our loss to go down really
fluctuates uh 55 1.2.77.48
uh so we have a lot of things going on
there
let's go ahead and graph those
turn that up
and our team in the back did a wonderful
job of putting together um this basic
plot set up
um here's our subplot coming in we're
going to be looking at um
uh from the history we're going to send
it the accuracy and the value accuracy
labels are set up on there
and we're going to also look at loss and
value loss so you can see what this
looks like what's really interesting
about
this setup and let me let me just go
ahead and show you because without
actually seeing the plots it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense
it's just basic plotting of
the data using the pi plot library
and i want you to look at this this is
really interesting
when i ran this the first time i had
very different results
and they vary greatly and you can see
here our accuracy continues to climb
there's a cross over here
put it in here
right here's our crossover
and i point that out because as we get
to the right of that crossover where our
accuracy
and we're like oh yeah i got point eight
percent
we're starting to get an overfit here
that's what this this switch over means
um
as our value uh as a training set versus
the value um accuracy stays the same and
so that this is the one we're actually
really want to be aware of and where it
crosses
is kind of where you want to stop at
and we can see that also with the train
loss versus the value loss right here
we did one epic and look how it just
flatlines right there with our loss
so really
one epic
is
probably enough
and you're going to say wow okay 0.8
percent
certainly if i was working with the
shareholders um
telling them that it has an 80 accuracy
isn't quite true and
we'll look at that a little deeper it
really comes out here that the accuracy
of our actual values is closer to 0.41
percent right here
even after running it this number of
times
and so you really want to stop right
here at that crossover
one epic would have been enough
so the data is a little overfitted on
this when we do four epics
and uh whoops there we are
okay
my drawing won't go away um let's see if
i can get there we go
for some reason i've killed my drawing
ability and my recorder
all right took a couple extra clicks
uh so let's go ahead and take a look at
our actual test loss um so you see where
it crosses over that's where i'm looking
at
that's where we start overfitting the
model
and this is where
if we were going to go back and
continually upgrade the model we would
start taking a look at the images and
start rotating them
we might start playing with the
convolutional neural network instead of
doing the three by three window
we might expand that or you know find
different things that might make a big
difference as far as the way it
processes these things
um so let's go ahead and take a look at
our our test loss now remember we had
our training data
now we're going to look at our test
images and our test labels
for our test loss here and this is just
model evaluate uh just like we did fit
up here
where was it
one more
model fit with our training data going
in now we're going to evaluate it on the
and and this data has not been touched
yet so this model's never seen this data
this is on
completely new information as far as the
model is concerned of course we
already know what it is from the labels
we have
and this is what i was talking about
here's the actual accuracy right here
point four eight
uh or four eight four seven
so this forty nine percent of the time
guesses what the image is
uh and
i mean really that's the bottom dollar
does this work for what you're needing
does 49 work do we need to upgrade the
model more
um
in some cases this might be
oh what was i doing i was working on
stock evaluations
and
we were looking at what stocks were the
top performers
well if i get that 50 percent correct on
i'm good with that
that's actually pretty good for stock
evaluation
in fact the number i had for stock was
more like
30 something percent as far as being a
top performer stock
much harder to predict
but at that point you're like well
you'll make money off of that so again
this number right here depends a lot on
the domain you're working on
and then we want to go ahead and bring
this home a little bit more uh as far as
looking at the different setup in here
and one of the
from sk learn if you remember actually
let's go back to the top
uh we had the classification report and
this came in from our sklearn or scikit
setup
and that's right here you can see it
right here on the um
see there we go
classification report right here uh
sklearn metrics import classification
report this we're going to look at next
a lot of this stuff
depends on who you're working with
so when we start looking at
precision
you know this is like for each value i
can't remember what one one one was
probably mountains so if 44
is not good enough if you're doing like
um you're in the medical department and
you're doing cancer is it is this
cancerous or not and i'm only 44
accurate
not a good deal
you know i would not go with that um
so it depends on what you're working
with on the different labels and what
they're used for facebook yeah you know
44 i'm guessing the right person i hope
it does a little bit better than that
but here's our main accuracy this is
what almost everybody looks at they say
oh 48 that's what's important
again it depends on what domain you're
in and what you're working with
and now we're going to do the same model
oops somehow i got my there it goes i
thought i was going to get stuck on
there again uh
this time we're going to be using the
vgg16
and remember this one is
all those layers
going into it so it's basically a bunch
of convolutional neural networks getting
smaller and smaller on here
and so we need to go ahead and
import all our different stuff from
cross we're importing the main one is
the v
g 16 set up on there
just aim that there we go
there's kind of a pre-processing images
applications pre-process input this is
all part of the vg g16 setup on there
and once we have all those we need to go
ahead
and create our model
and we're just going to create a vgg16
model in here
inputs model inputs outputs model inputs
i'm not going to spend as much time as
they did on the other one
we're going to go through it really
quickly
one of the first things i would do
is if you remember in cross you can
create
treat a model like you would a layer
and so at this point i would probably
add a lot of dense layers on after the
vgg16 model and create a new model with
all those things in there
and we'll go ahead and run this
because here's our model coming in and
our setup
it'll take it just a moment to compile
that
what's funny about this is i'm waiting
for it to download the package since i
pre-ran this um it takes it a couple
minutes to download the vgg16 model into
here
and so we want to go ahead and train
features for the model we're going to
predict that we're going to predict the
train images and we're going to test
features on the predict test images on
here
and then i told you it's going to create
another model too and the people in the
back did not disappoint me they went
ahead and did just that
and this is really an important part um
this is worth stopping for i told you i
was going to go through this really
quick
so here's our uh
we we have our model 2
um
coming in and we've created a model up
here with the vgg16 model equals model
inputs model inputs
and so we have our vgg16 this has
already been pre-programmed
uh and then we come down here i want you
to notice on this
right here
layer model two layers minus four to one
x layer x
we're basically taking this model and
we're adding stuff on to it
and so
we've taken we've just basically
duplicated this model we could have done
the same thing by using
model up here as a layer
we could have the input go to this model
and then have that go down here so we've
added on
this whole setup
this whole block of code from 13 to 17
has been added on to our vggg16 model
and we have a new model
with the layer ma input and x down here
let's go ahead and run that and compile
it
and that was a lot to go through right
there when you're building these models
this is the part that gets so
complicated
that you get stuck playing in and yet
it's so fun uh it's like a puzzle how
can i loop these models together
and in this case you can see right here
that the layers
we're just copying layers over and
adding each layer in
this is one way to build a new model
and we'll go ahead and run that
like i said the other way is you can
actually use the model as a layer i've
had a little trouble playing with it
sometimes when you're using the straight
model over
you run into issues
it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come up
let's go ahead and do the new model
we're going to compile it again here's
our metrics accuracy sparse categorical
loss
pretty straightforward just like we did
before you got to compile the model
and just like before we're going to take
our create a history
the history is going to be
a new model fit train 128
and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff
we're going to have to go ahead and it's
going to light up our setup on here and
this is going to take a little bit to
get us all set up it's not going to just
happen in a couple minutes so let me go
ahead and pause the video and run it and
then we'll talk about what happened
okay now when i ran that these actually
took about six minutes each
so it's a good thing i put it on whole
we did four epics i actually had to stop
it says at 10 and switch it to forks i
didn't want to wait an hour
and you can see here our accuracy
and our loss numbers going down
and just at a glance
it actually performed if you look at the
accuracy
0.2658
so our accuracy is going down or you
know 26
um 34
35 percent
and you can see here at some point it
just kind of kicks the bucket again this
is overfitting
that's always an issue when you're
running on
programming these different neural
networks
and then we're going to go ahead and
plot the accuracy
history we built that nice little
subroutine up above so we might as well
use it
and you can see it right here
there's that crossover again
and if you look at this look how the how
the uh the red shifts up how the uh
our loss functions and everything
crosses over we're overfitting after one
epic um we're clearly
not helping the problem or doing better
we're just going to it's just going to
baseline this one actually shows with
the training versus the loss
value loss maybe second epic so on here
we're now talking more between the first
and the second epic and that also shows
kind of here so
somewhere in here it starts overfitting
and right about now you should be saying
uh-oh uh something went wrong there i
thought that
we went up here and ran this
look at this we have the accuracy up
here it's hitting that 48
and we're down here um
you look at the score down here that
looks closer to
20 percent not nearly
anywhere in the ballpark of what we're
looking for
and we'll go ahead and run it through
the
the actual test features here and there
it is um we actually run this on the
unseen data and everything
point uh one eight or eighteen percent
um i don't know about you but i wouldn't
want you know at 18 this did a lot worse
than the other one
i thought this was supposed to be the
supermodel the
model that beats all models the vgg-16
that won the
awards and everything
well the reason is is that
one we're not
pre-processing the data so it needs to
be more there needs to be more
um as far as like rotating the data at
you know 45 degree angle taking partials
of it
so you can create a lot more data to go
through here
and that would actually greatly change
the outcome on here and then we went up
here we only added a couple dense layers
we added a couple convolutional neural
networks
this huge pre-trained setup is looking
for a lot more information coming in
as far as how it's going to train
and so
this is one of those things where i
thought it would have done better and i
had to go back and research it and look
at it and say why didn't this work why
am i getting only
18 here instead of 44 or better
and that would be wise it doesn't have
enough training data coming in
uh and again you can make your own
training data so it's not that we have a
shortage of data it's that that some of
that has to be switched around and moved
around a little bit
and this is interesting right here too
if you look at the precision
we're getting it on number two and yet
we had zero on everything else
so for some reason it's not seeing
the different variables in here so it'd
be something else to look in and try to
track down
and that probably has to do with the
input but you can see right here we have
a really good solid 0.48 up here and
that's where i'd really go with is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in
where's the setup on there
and that is the art of data science
right there is finding out which models
work better and why
so sequential models
so what makes this a sequential model
sequential models are linear stacks of
layers where one layer leads to the next
it is simple and easy to implement and
you just have to make sure that the
previous layer is the input to the next
layer
so you have used for plain stack of
layers where each layer has one input
and one output
tensor and this is what tensorflow is
named after is each one of these layers
is like a tensor
each node is a tensor and then the layer
is also considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about uh this is something this
is a teapot this is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating um
regret the actual values you know this
is worth ten dollars that's worth thirty
dollars uh the weather is going to be 90
degrees out or whatever it is so you can
use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas and different notations when
you're in data science so when we talk
about time series we'll talk about
sequential that is something very
different sequential in this case means
it goes from the input to layer 1 to
layer 2 to the output so it's very
directional
it's important to note this because if
you have a sequential model can you have
a non-sequential model and the answer is
yes
if you master the basics of a sequential
model you can just as easily have
another model that shares layers
you can have another model where the you
have an input coming in and it splits
and then you have one set that's doing
one set of nodes maybe they're doing a
yes no kind of node where it's either
putting out a zero or a one a classifier
and the other one might be regression
it's just processing numbers and then
you recombine them for the output
that's what they call across the cross
api
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do and do a demo on here
today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo on whatever platform you want or
whatever
user interface for developing python
i'm actually using anaconda and then i'm
using jupyter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created environment you can come in here
to open a terminal window
and if you don't have the different
modules in here you can do your conda
install whatever module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a seaborn in it which i
already installed
so here's our anaconda and then i'm
going to go back
and start up my jupiter notebook
where i already created a
new
python project python 3 i'm in python
3.8 on this particular one
sequential model for flowers
so lots of fun there
so we're going to jump right into this
the first thing is to make sure you have
all your modules installed
so if you don't have numpy pandas
matplot library and seaborn in the cross
an sk learn or site kit it's not
actually sklearn you'll need to go ahead
and install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
i get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
right off the bat though we have numpy
pandas matplot library seaborn these are
built on top of each other panda is a
data frame and built on top of numpy the
data array
and then we bring in our sklearn or
scikit this is the scikit setup sci
kit
even though you use sklearn to bring it
in it's a scikit and then our cross we
have our pre-processing the images image
data generator
our model this is our basic model our
sequential model
and then we bring in from cross layers
import dents
optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now
atom
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our sgd which is smaller
data does better on smaller pieces of
data
and i'm not going to go into all of
these
different optimizers we didn't even use
these in the actual demo you just have
to be aware that they are different
optimizers and the digger the more you
dig into these models
you'll hit a point where you do need to
play with these a little bit but for the
most part leave it at the default when
you're first starting out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have dropout they have
flattened they have
activation they have the convolutional
layer 2d max pooling 2d
batch normalization
what are all these layers and when we
get to the model we're going to talk
about them
a lot of times when you're just starting
you can just
import cross dot layers and then you
have your drop out your flattened uh
your convolutional
neural network 2d
and we'll we'll cover what these do
in the actual example when we get down
there
what i want you to take from here though
is you need to run your imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow tf because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally
import random is rn just for random
generation
and then we get down here we have our
cv2
that is your
open image or your opencv they call it
for processing images that's what the
cvd 2 is
we have our tqdm
the tqdm is for
is a progress bar just a fancy way
of adding when you're running a process
you can view the bar going across in the
jupiter
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have
we want to be able to shuffle some files
again these are all different things
pill is another
image processor it goes with the cv2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so when we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different
files for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an x and a z
and the x is the data of the image and
the z is the tag for it what kind of
flower is this
and the image size is really important
because we have to re-size everything
if you have a neural network and if you
remember from our neural networks let me
flip back to that slide
we look at this light we have two input
nodes here uh with an image you have an
input node
depending on how you set it up for each
pixel and that pixel has three different
color schemes usually in it sometimes
four so if you have a picture that's 150
by 150
uh you multiply 150 times 150 times
three
that's how many nodes input layers
coming in i mean so this is a massive
input a lot of times you think oh yeah
it's just a small amount of data or
something like that
no it's a full image coming in and then
you have your hidden layers a lot of
times they match what the image size is
coming in so each one of those is also
just as big and then we get down to just
a single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different
directories on here let me go and run
that
so i'm just setting the directories
that's all this is
archive flowers daisy sunflower tulip
dandelion rose
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
uh and then we want to go ahead and we
need to assign labels remember we
defined x and z
so we're just going to create a
definition here
and the first thing is a return flower
type okay
just returns it what kind of flower it
is i guess assigned label to it but
we're going to go ahead and make our
train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here
the first one is we're just appending
right onto our numpy array the image
we're going to let numpy handle all that
different
aspects as far as 150 by 150 by three
we just dump it right into the numpy
which makes it really easy we don't have
to do anything funky on the processing
and we want to leave it like that and
i'm going to talk about that in a minute
and then of course we have to have the
string append the label on there and i
want you to notice right here
we're going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones
this is something that's so important is
when you're resizing or reformatting
your data you really have to be aware of
what's going on with
images it's not a big deal because with
an image you just resize it so it looks
squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on there
and then we want to go ahead and make
our
training data
so make the train data
daisy flower daisy directory uh print
length of x so here we go let's go and
run that
and we're just loading up the flower
daisy
so this is going all in there and it's
setting
um it's adding it in to the our setup on
there
to our x and z setup
and we see we have 769
um and then of course you can see this
nice bar here this is the bar going
across is that little added
code in there that just makes it really
cool for doing demos
not necessarily when you're building
your own model or something like that
but if you're going to display this to
other people adding that little what was
it called
tqdm i can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just
created an array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and i want to
show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are or how good you are
programming
errors are going to come up and you got
to figure out how to handle them
and so when we get all the way down to
the where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
going in here there's a couple things
you can do and we're just going to hope
it wasn't there it is there's our error
i knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065.
now i can do a couple things one i could
go back into our definition
and i can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion this is where
the error is coming from
just skip it that's one way to do it
when you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
data at the end
you just say okay i lost three points
who cares
or you can go in there and try to delete
it
it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
error right along and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is a wonderful thing
about jupiter notebook
is that i can just continue on there and
the x and z which we're creating
is still
running and we'll just go right into the
next flower rows so all these flowers
are in there
that's just a cool thing about jupiter
notebook
and then we can go ahead and just take a
quick look and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with a
other people and showing them stuff this
is just kind of fun where we can display
it on the plot library here
and we're just going to go through and
see what we got here
uh looks like
we're gonna do like five of each of them
i think
is that how they set this up um
plot library five by two okay oh i see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data
no matter what you're doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150
you can see how it really blurs this one
up here on the tulip
that is that resize to 150 by 150
and these are what's actually going in
these are all 150 by 150 images you can
check the dimensions on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here
and again like i said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing
this different information so we need to
go ahead and take our labels
uh and run a label encoder on there and
then we're just gonna ellie is a label
encoder one of the things we imported
and then we always use the fit
to categorical y comma five x here's our
array
um x so if you look at this here's our
fit we're gonna transform z
that's our z array we created
um and then we have y which equals that
and then we go ahead and do uh to
categorical we want five different
categories
and then we create our x uh np array of
x x equals x over 255.
so what's going on here there's two
different transformations one we've
turned our categories into
0 1 2 3 4 5 as the output
and we have taken our x array
and remember the x array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
color arrays and those color arrays
range from 0 to 250.
so when we take the x equals x over 255
i'm sorry range from 0 to 255.
this converts all those pixels to a
number between 0 and 1.
and you really want to do that when
you're working with neural networks
now if you do a linear regression model
it doesn't affect it as much so you
don't have to do that conversion if
you're doing straight numbers but when
you're running neural networks if you
don't do this you're going to create a
huge bias
and that means they'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions
so now we have our
x and y values
x being the data n y being our known
output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training
so we have x train
we have our x test this is the data
we're not going to program the model
with
and of course your y train corresponds
to your x train and your y test
corresponds to your x test the outputs
and this is uh when we do the train test
split this was from the site kit sklearn
we imported train test split and we're
just going to go ahead and do the test
size at about a quarter of the data 0.25
and of course random is always good
this is such a good tool i mean
certainly you can do your own division
um
you know you could just take the first
you know 0.25 of the data or whatever do
the length of the data not real hard to
do
but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what i will do
is i'll just split the data into three
parts
and then i'll test it on two with one
being the
or train it on two of those parts with
one being the test and i rotate it so i
come up with three different answers
which is a good way of finding out just
how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
x train x test and the sk learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here and
you can see we did an np random seed
from 42 and we get a nice rn number
and then we do tf random we set the seed
so you can set your randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the
tf.random.set is
so that's a lot of prep
all this prep and then we finally get to
the exciting part
this is where you probably spend once
you have the data prepped and you have
your pipeline going
and you have everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting
is building these models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designate a sequential um they
have the api which is across the cross
tensorflow api versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together
it looks almost the same with the
exception of
bringing it back together so it's not a
huge step to go from this to an api
and the first thing we're going to look
at is
our convolutional neural network in 2d
so what's going on here there's a lot of
stuff that's going on here
the default
for well let's start with the beginning
what is a convolutional 2d network
well convolutional 2d network creates a
number of small windows and those small
windows float over the picture and each
one of them is their own neural network
and this basically
becomes like a
categorization and then it looks at that
and it says oh if we add these numbers
up a certain way
we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is 5x5 so we're
looking at a five by five square
remember it's 150 by 150 so this narrows
it down to a five by five it's a two d
so it has your x y coordinates
um and
we look at this five by five remember
each one of these is is actually looking
at five by five by three
so we're actually looking at fifteen by
fifteen different
pixels
and padding is just um
usually just ignore that
activation by default is relu we went
ahead and put the relu in there
there's a lot of different activations
relu is for your smaller uh
when you remember i mentioned atom when
you have a lot of datum data use an atom
kind of activation
or using atom processing
we're using the relu here
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
it doesn't give you a full yes or no it
has a
zero and then it kind of shoots off at
an angle
very common it's the most common one and
then of course here's our input shape
150 by 150 by three pixels
and then we have to pull it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2d
layer
we have to bring this back together and
pull this into a neural network and then
we're going to go ahead and repeat this
so we're going to add another network
here
one of the cool things if you look at
this is that it as it comes in it just
kind of automatically assumes you're
going down to the next layer
and so we have another convolutional
null network 2d
here's our max pooling again we're going
to do that again max pooling
and we're just going to filter on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they changed the kernel size they
changed the number of filters
and so each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently
and that's kind of cool because then you
get a little added filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
we get down to here one of the things we
see is flattened so we added we just
flatten it remember this is 150 by 150
by three
well and actually
the pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flattened just puts
that into a 1d array
so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the pixels and
everything it's just flat
and then the dents
is just another activation on there
by default it is probably relu
as far as its activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation as relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents
and there's a lot of different
activations but relu is the most common
one and then we also see a soft max
softmax is similar
but it has its own kind of variation
and one of the cool things you know what
let me bring this up because if we if
you don't know about these activations
this doesn't make sense
and i just did a quick google search on
images of tensorflow activations
um i should probably look at which set
website this is
but this is the output of the values
so as your x as it adds in all those uh
weighted x values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
that's a sigmoid activation and you can
see it goes between 0 and one and has a
nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives um and if we come down the
seven popular activation functions
non-linear activations there's a lot of
different options on this let me see if
i can find the
oops make sure we can find the specific
to relu
so this is a leaky relu
and you can see instead of it just being
zero and then a value between going up
it has a little leaky there otherwise
your railu loses some nodes they just
become inactive um but you can see
there's a lot of different options here
here's a good one right here with the
rayleigh you can see the rayleigh
function on the upper on the upper left
here and then the leaky rayleigh over
here on the right which is very commonly
used also
one of the things i use with processing
language is the
sig as the exponential one
or the tangent h the hyperbolic tangent
because they have that nice funky curve
that comes in that has a whole different
meaning and captures word use better
again these are very specific to domain
and you can spend a lot of time
playing with different models for our
basic model we'll stick to the relu and
the softmax on here and we'll go ahead
and run and build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there
we need to go ahead and have a batch
size on here uh 128
epix10
this means that we're going to send 128
rows of data or flowers at a time to be
processed
and the epics 10 that's how many times
we're going to loop through all the data
and then there's all kinds of stuff you
can do again this is now built into a
lot of cross models already by default
so there's different ways to reduce
the values and
verbose verbose equals one means that
we're going to show what's going on
value monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to 0
you don't have to watch it train the
model
although
it is kind of nice to actually know
what's going on sometimes
and since we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator
this is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing
most of the time you can actually just
ignore most of this
vertical flip so you can randomly flip
pictures you can randomly horizontally
flick them
you can shift the picture around this
kind of helps gives you multiple data
off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that
setup because we already have a huge
amount of data
if you're short data you can start
flipping like a horizontal picture and
it will generate it's like doubling your
data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have um
5 000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias
that is the downside of that
and so we have our model compile and
this you're going to see in all the
cross we're going to take this model
here
we're going to take all this information
as far as how we want it to go and we're
going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and i want you
to notice uh
learning rate
very important this is the default zero
zero one
there's there you really don't this is
how
slowly it adjusts to find the right
answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number
with larger with you have a very small
sample of data you might go even larger
than that and then we're going to look
at the loss categorically categorical
cross entropy most commonly used
and this is uh how how much it improves
the model is improving is what this
number means or yeah that's that's
important on there and then the accuracy
we want to know just how good our model
is on the accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
as you can run the model summary
i do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as
while it fits
the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that
doesn't really matter it does the same
thing and we'll go ahead and just run
that
and you can see while it's running right
here we're going through the epics we
have one of ten now we're going through
six to twenty five
here's our loss we're printing that out
so you can see how it's improving and
our accuracy the accuracy gets better
and better and this is 6 out of 25. this
is going to take a couple minutes to
process
because we are training 150 by 150 by 3
pixels across
six layers or eight layers whatever it
was
that is a huge amount of processing so
this will take a few minutes to process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because i did pause the
recorder to let this go ahead and run
all the way through its epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are and if you set the
verbose to
zero instead of one it won't show what's
going on in the behind the scenes as
it's training it
so we look at this epic 10 epic so we
went through all the data 10 times
if i remember correctly there's roughly
a gig of data there so that's a lot of
data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the 270 seconds
that's how much each of those epics took
to run
and so if you divide 60 in there you
roughly get about five minutes worth of
each epic so if i have 10 epics that's
50 minutes almost an hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh in on this particular
computer
i actually have what is it
eight cores with 16 dedicated threads so
it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in
and it still takes it five minutes for
each one of these epics so you start to
see that if you have a lot of data
this is going to be a problem if you
have a number of models you want to find
out how good the models are doing and
what model to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact i have a model
i'm running now that takes over uh takes
about a day and a half to test each
model
it takes four days to do with the whole
data
so what i do is i actually take a small
piece of the data
test it out to find out
get an idea of how the different setups
are going to do
and then i increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and i
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then i need to add in more dense layers
or whatever
uh so you can do a small chunks of data
and then figure out what it costs to do
a large set of data and what kind of
model you want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down
this is the error this is how much error
is in there it really isn't a
user-friendly number other than
the more it trends down the better and
so if you continue to see the loss going
down eventually get to the point where
it stops going down and it goes up and
down and kind of wavers a little bit at
that point you know you've run too many
epics you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you a
good model fit
the accuracy just turns us into
something that
we can use
and so the accuracy is what percentage
of guesses in this case is categorical
so this is the percentage of guesses are
correct
um value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy
just rounds it off basically and so a
lot of times you come down here and you
go okay we're doing 0.5.6
0.7 and that is 70 accuracy or in this
case 68.59
accuracy that's a very usable number and
it's very important to have
if you're identifying flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance in knowing what
flower you're identifying
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not you might want to rethink
it a little bit or re-key how you're
building your model
so
if i'm working with a
a group of clients
shareholders in a company or something
like that
you don't really want to show them this
you don't want to show them hey you know
this is what's going on with the
accuracy these are just numbers and so
we want to go and put the finishing
touches just like when you are building
a house and you put in the frame and the
trim on the house it's nice to have
something a nice view of what's going on
and so we'll go ahead and do a pie plot
and we'll just plot the history of the
loss
the history of the
value loss
over here
epics train and test and so we're just
going to compute these
this is really important and what i want
you to notice right here is when we get
to about oh
five epochs a little more than five six
epics you see a cross over here
and it starts crossing as far as the
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the data wasn't used
to program your model wasn't used to
train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming over fitted and so when you
put these two together
right around five and six you start to
see how it does this this switch over
here and that's really where you need to
stop right around five yeah six um
it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box
see but you know that right around here
if you're saving your model after each
run you want to use the one that's right
around five epics because that's the one
that's going to have the least amount of
bias so this is really important as far
as guessing what's going on with your
model and its accuracy and when to stop
it also is you know i don't show people
this mess up here
i show somebody this kind of model and i
say this is where the training and the
testing comes in on this model
it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them within about you know 68
accuracy whether it's going to be a
dahlia sunflower cherry blossom rose
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a
different tables to see where the errors
are coming from and what problems are
coming up
and that brings us to the end of this
video on artificial intelligence 2022
full course by simply learn i hope you
liked it if you have any queries then
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you